you're watching american history tv only
on c-span three
each week real america brings you
archival films that provide context for
today's public affairs issues
sponsored by the student nonviolent
coordinating committee also known as
snick will never turn back as a half
hour film that was used in their voter
registration campaign in the south shot
in rural mississippi the film includes
interviews with black farmers and
sharecroppers who describe violence and
intimidation they experienced when
attempting to register to vote julian
bond fannie lou hammer and snick leaders
also appear in the documentary
this picture is is essentially for
americans people who call themselves
americans
about those in the south today who are
trying to make democracy
live
it begins with the painful and heartfelt
assumptions that we are not an island of
perfection
but in fact
a
land of imperfection in an imperfect
world
negroes are trying to
register to vote and help to change the
situation that they're existing under
today help to bring about
democracy in our land today
[Music]
mississippi 1963
freed
for a moment
in this hillside home
they are secluded from the white
segregationists who carry guns and clubs
i miss i've been living in a mid county
52 or three years
i participated in everything
as they kind of saw fit for a citizen to
participate in
and also i read my family here in the
mid county
nine health children's
i only have two kids now going to
school
here in the county
i also was a
president of the naacp
here in mid county
and i would i do think that every
citizen
in the mid county should
to participate in an election
and i hope and trust
that i will have the privilege
to vote once or twice in my life
i'm mrs stanley hamer and i farmed on
the marlow plantation for 18 years
i had charge of keeping up with the time
and paying off and i went down the 31st
of august to try to register and after i
had gotten back home
mr marlowe told me that i would have to
go down
and withdraw my registration or leave
because they wasn't ready for that in
mississippi and i said mr milo i'm
trying to register for myself so i had
to leave that same night after i had
gone down in august
and then i spent one night with mrs
tucker and after about two days in
september they shot in the house 15
times thinking that i was there
resistance to change in the south is
great
and behind the headlines
there's a story of intimidation that is
seldom
told
the police dogs the
police brutality
the
use of fire holes and and
other forms of intimidation to turn
negroes back it's what hits the
headlines daily but there's a story
that's yet to be told
[Music]
washing up the freedom
mrs mcgee tries to make a living on a
farm for herself and four teenage
children
they sent me to the hospital
they put my lane in the side bank
they got a thousand ninety five dollars
they ran into other land for 375
they put my children on welfare
when i came out of the hospital they had
taken my fence down and wiring the road
down through my place they went around
got all of my creditors different people
that i owed to trust me
and they hadn't paid anybody
i got a lawyer to straighten my business
out
and he told me that he would
well he
didn't do anything about it he worried
me about selling some of the lane i told
him that i didn't want to sell the lane
that i wanted to punish so that i could
farm and make a living for my children
and so they just put pressure on me they
cut the wear off their check
to twenty dollars a month then they cut
it to seventeen dollars a month
they worried me so that i had a nervous
breakdown in sixty i had to go back to
the hospital
so when i came back
i came back home
i still tried to get a punish
he collected all the money read on the
place he didn't pay the federal lane
back the notes that i hold they put
pressure on me trying to get me to sell
the lane i refuse
so last year
i rented a portion of the lane for 200
cash he got that 200 he didn't give us
any of it i went down to illinois to
reddish
and vote i got down and made my revival
back
my landlord said unto me if you don't go
down take your name off the registration
to move
i took his word and i moved
to drew mississippi
couldn't get too much pressure to be on
the landlord there
had been move on to cleveland
mississippi
after arriving to cleveland mississippi
my wife
she had to go to the hospital down to
jackson
is there on the same generation
and i didn't know what step to take i'm
still working nine girls here
i'm working trying to take care of them
the best of my knowledge
this is mrs mildred evans she's 32 years
of age she lived on mr w d fields
plantation for 11 years
she's above eight children
her children do not attend school
regularly because of food
clothing
and money last year mrs evans made 11
bales of cotton
at the end of the year she only received
123 dollars
i am 17 years old i picked 300 pounds of
calories a day
i am nine years old i helped my mother
pick out i could pick a honda by day
i am 14 years old now i helped my mother
see cat i am picked by 200 a day
this is mrs p williams the great
grandmother of the five children here
she receives a small social security
check each month and from this she must
help support the children that mothers
earn and take care of
the reason i do
because my mother worked a crap and i
had to help her and so i quit school
so that i could help her
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
and the two girls
and our daughter were sitting on the
chair and they were
the girl was badly shot up and they had
to be rushed to the hospital
and and they suffered very much
we went over to see them and they were
very much in pain they had to be rushed
to another hospital in jackson
and one had to go and this is the
results
after i had
registered
my name is child i was working in rural
mississippi on the night of the
shootings
1762. i went to the hospital to check on
the condition of the two girls who had
been shot and was arrested shortly after
my arrival there by the mayor of the
town of louisville i spent the night in
jail
talking to the mosquitoes
with no charges preferred against me
the night the shot was made in my house
it was no one that would mean my wife
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
of and the next day when i reckless six
months last six month employment
conversation
my name is eddie nunnery
lady of a mitch county and live in the
state of mississippi
i've gone
to try to radish at this
register office
and after going there several times
they failed me and told me i was
disqualified to register
and after going there
once
it was a gone fight
lots of people in amid county are fair
to go to liberty and register our vote
because they're afraid of being killed
lots of them are afraid to join the
naacp because they'll be afraid to lose
their job and have to go hungry
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
i'm willie peacock the field secretary
for the student nonviolent coordinating
committee at president i'm working in
greenwood mississippi
in lower florida county on water
registration
our present activities are the
distribution of the food
which has been sent from the north
as an emergency relief
we feel that this this particular food
will will serve the needs of the needy
to the greatest advantage
i think that the that
they are very appreciative of this
and i think that they fear enough
concern about them
[Music]
all them silas they went to jail had no
money for to go their bail keep your
eyes on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i am william wesley i have gone down to
liberty mississippi
several times to try to register vote
the second time i went down
the reddit stuff which was filling out
the form
of a gone god on the ground part
i went out to see
what was happening my sons remain on in
filling out
when i come back we left my son when we
left our massan say uh
mr
white man coming across the hall and
told
mr someone body got the hell shot out of
him and he said he sure did
and the last time we went out fill out
the farm we complete
our farms
they asked them how did we come out he
said we had to come back in several days
they go around the publication several
days was up we went back in he said we
had several more days and when several
more days was up we went back down see
how it would come out and he got his
chair and pulled it to the desk and we
all sit down he went over the
application just like some past and some
didn't
and got to the
end of them
none of us didn't pass and so i asked
him what did i fail on my application or
my section or duty of a system and he
replied all of us
my name is maver lee weather i live in
liberty mississippi i was one of the
first ones to go to liberty to register
to vote
and wasn't anything said that day
because the office was very surprised
then later i carried some more people
and they did not finish because they
began to beat grit travis and they got
scared and ran out
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Music]
let your children go
[Music]
if
[Music]
and the young people there is hope
many of them have
dropped out of school for a year or more
to work as field secretaries for the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee
going into the rural areas of the south
to register people to teach the people
how to register and vote and to use the
franchises as an effective means of
change they exist on 10 and fifteen
dollars a week living with the people
working with the people trying to build
new horizons for tomorrow
i as a young [ __ ] grow up mr city
feel that um
she is not wanted
because due to the fact
the white people of the south
they don't seem to understand the
younger generation of negroes
we want to put up with the presence of
our situation
it makes the internet grow
uh who is sensible
uh kind of angry when he hears
any uh
person acts a negro
why do you want to do this do that why
you want to vote why you want to go to
uh the university of mississippi
well uh i think that the uh negro should
not be able to choose his own
institution as the
white uh youth when he finishes high
school
i think
that the negroes should be treated just
like the flight
i think when i will finish high school
that i will try to enter the college of
ole miss
as of james murder
my name is emma bell i'm from macomb
mississippi i'm 19 years of age i'm a
field secretary for the student
nonviolent club coordinating committee
i'm working for i'm working on voter
education programs in greenville
mississippi
i feel that the negroes in the south
especially the younger ones
would like to have the same
opportunities and privileges at any
other american citizen would have
and living within the system of
segregation they are aware that this
cannot ever exist therefore they are
willing to work and fight much harder to
do
to do away with segregation
uh the reason why i'm in the movement in
the south
is because i think that things have
gotten to the point where people have to
do things for themselves
they've got to stop depending on the the
federal government or the state
governments or even their local
governments to secure their rights for
them they've got to act to win the
rights that the constitution guarantees
and people must make up their minds that
if they want to be free and if they want
others to be free then they've got to do
something
uh something beyond just giving money or
just casting a vote
or just uh wishing others well but
they've got to
put their bodies in the movement as we
say they've got to get out on the front
lines and they've
got to do something for themselves and
for other people
my name is james jones i'm 20 years old
i was arrested and documented for
participating in the freedom ride i was
charged with bridget defeats incentive
practices and attention
while required being there two weeks
we heard the girls singing on the other
side
so we asked one of the trusted what was
wrong he told us that the guards are
taking the girls mattress so we decided
that we would protest that same night we
all started to sing it the shed came
down and put us in solitary solitary
about six feet wide
seven feet tall you put 27 of us in
solitary and that night one of the
fellows panicked
another guy painted and so we decided we
would cool down
and
and asked the guard and asked the
sheriff to let us out so he let us out
and now that i'm out of foxton attention
i'm now working on voter registration in
sunflower county parliament is located
in sunflower county
and i'm the seed of the sun
gonna stay right here and fight to feed
them until the spell is
[Music]
are you wrong
[Music]
don't listen to mr charlie don't listen
to his life those color folks haven't
got a chance unless we organize
boys
[Music]
for the very basic right to vote in our
country as seemingly an endless chain of
violence
you uh leave it to mississippi
to register
the uh rare shot gave me some paper to
fill out i've done the very best i could
and i turned them in
after i turned them in i
left
and then as i was leaving there's a
group of white men was interfering with
some of my friends
and i got them in my truck and got in
the way as quick as i could
my name is curtis dawson i was born
and raised in a mid-county
i was in liberty mississippi on the way
to the courthouse
but to reduce
the vote me and
knox
and
moses
we met three
white mens
and one of those men's jumped on moses
and began to beat him
herbert lee
was the father
of some nine children in the mid county
mississippi the county is 54 negro
he tried very
hard to get his fellow citizens out to
register and vote
he was killed by a state representative
from mississippi a white state
representative after he himself had
tried to vote
these are pictures of his wife
and his nine children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
the director of the student nonviolent
coordinating committee's voter
registration project in mississippi
robert
moses the young people working with the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee or snik as we call it
are characterized by restless energy
radical change in race relations in the
united states their world is upset
and they feel that if they are ever
going to get it straight
they must upset it more
my name is charles mclaren i work in
voter registration in sunflower county
on january 25th 1963
i went to the mayor's office in
indianola mississippi
my purpose the purpose was to see if
there were any laws on the book
that forbidded voter registration
activities in the city the mayor jumped
from his seat and
said you black son of a [ __ ] don't you
come in here arguing at me
i told him that we were there to do
voter registration
and that if there were any laws that
forbid it to let me know
and he said
he said no i turned and walked away
and he called me back
said
go out and teach everybody in the town
i don't care but if you go into any
churches
i will cut off the tax exemption
my name is jesse harry and i participate
in voter registration in the mississippi
delta it was during
1962 i was arrested in jackson for
contempt of court and fined one hall of
fine and 30 days in hinds county farm
the first time i was beaten was in hinds
county on the elevator when office asked
me my name and where i was from and i
told him i'm from jackson and so he beat
me and hit me side to head in the back
and thing the second time i was beating
on the hinds county farm
because he asked me where's our farm
also and i told him jackson and he said
are you one of those freedom riders and
i told him i didn't know what it was so
he beat me and the third time i was
beaten was on the counter phone because
i refused to move a 200 pound law
and the fourth time i was beaten because
my name is hollis watkins i participated
in a demonstration in macomb mississippi
and was arrested for breach of peace
along with 115 other students
while a mob waited on the outside after
being questioned i was carried into a
room where a police officer came in and
got a rope and said okay [ __ ] get up
from here and let's go we're going to
have a hanging here tonight and you're
going to be first i looked at the
officer as he looked at me and then he
walked out
i am samuel black
field secretary for the student
nonviolent coordinating committee
i've been working in greenwood
mississippi in florida county
my purpose of being in greenwood is to
teach the negroes their duties and
obligations and responsibilities of
citizenship on the constitutional form
of government
by doing this i teach how important body
is and voter registration
when my first trip to the courthouse i
carried eight people up to register i
was met by the sheriff
he asked me where was i from
i told him i was a native mississippian
he said yes yes yes i know that but
where are you from i told him i was a
native mississippian around him here
someplace he said well what count i said
well brown here's some of these kind of
well
he got angry
he spit it in my face
he walked away he turned around and came
back
he put his finger in my face he said
look
he said
i know every [ __ ] is mammy around here
i actually know him any color people
he looked at me
and he
walked away again and he came back
he said look
so i don't want to see you right in here
no no more in this county
say i want you to leave town pack your
bag and leave town right now get out of
town don't let me catch you around here
no more
so i wasn't
frightened i looked at him i told him
chef
if you don't want to see me around here
in town in the morning the best thing
for you to do
is pack your bags and leave
cause i'll be here
i knew that i wasn't leaving
today in 1963
the fight to enjoy the rights of
first-class citizenship is still being
waged in this country
the needs of the people on the front
line are great you need typewriters
papers
money for food and anything
that you can
find that is useful
you can find anything that is useful it
can be sent to the student nonviolent
coordinating committee
six raymond street
atlanta georgia
help us who have fought for so many
years
to make the world
safe for democracy
and our fight now to make democracy safe
for the world
[Music]
then
[Music]
you can watch archival films on public
affairs in their entirety on our weekly
series real america
saturday at 10 pm and sunday at 4 pm
eastern here on american history tv
it seemed to be happening just about
every week that somebody either a famous
person times during your project when
you told people what you were doing they
say fannie lou who
a lot far more than i care to think i i
have to wonder what the schools are
teaching kids in terms of civil rights
history i would get two responses i
would get wow from the people who knew
who fannie lou hamer was but i would
very often get who and you i quickly
learned i couldn't belittle that
question i just had to say
you know tell them a little bit about
who she was so that i view all of this i
view the writing of it and the talking
about it as
education has there ever been a book
written about her no
there i take that back there have been
several children's books one children's
book by june jordan and one for let's
say junior high
children that came out a couple years
ago but there has never been a
full-fledged adult biography that shows
her place
in the movement and frankly there have
been precious view about any of the
women in the movement
when did she live she was born in 1917
the youngest of 20 children a
mississippi sharecropper she died in
march of 1977
in the hospital not more than 20 miles
from
where she lived most of her adult life
you say in the introduction that you met
her once right
what do you remember
i remember that she filled up a room
that's the main thing i i decided to try
to write the book
after i came back from that trip from
that meeting
with her i met her in 1973 i had gone to
mississippi to do
some
uh
a set of stories on the civil rights
movement what had become
of it
i
i
specifically chose mississippi
because
it had
had so much of the violence that had
occurred there and i wanted to meet her
i had seen her testify at the 1964
democratic convention and i wanted to
meet her so i went to her house on a
very hot steamy
probably july day
and she wasn't well she was frustrated
she was angry but she spent
an enormous amount of time with me and
i charisma is an overused word but it
applied to her and when i left that day
i came back to washington because that's
where i was working then
and i had lunch i remember it was at the
penkeen restaurant
14th and
something or other in washington with
lawrence giotto who was one of the
people who had been in jail with her and
i told him
how
incredibly dazzled i had been by her and
he said why don't you write a book about
her
and so that's when the idea was born
and
how long did you spend in washington
total in your life well in my life while
i was born here
and in washington dc in the old garfield
hospital yes indeed i've been born in
washington d.c
i grew up in
um
in bethesda and then in chevy chase
maryland i left washington to go to
college and then i came back here and
worked
i would say from 1970
through 78 first for senator musky of
maine and then for the new house
newspaper chain where did you go to
school
we're in
college oh penn state was undergraduate
uh
in political science and then i got a
master's
in history from northwestern university
we'll come back in a moment to talk
about fannie lou hamer
but i wrote down a bunch of names that
swirled around her in this book
and i just wanted to just to list them
very quickly eleanor holmes norton
congresswoman from the district of
columbia
john doerr former watergate council and
assistant attorney general
stokely carmichael former head of
schnick
pat derrian former assistant secretary i
believe of state andy young former u.n
ambassador and congressman hodding
carter former spokesman at the state
department the card administration aaron
henry former candidate for senate i
believe in the state of mississippi john
lewis current congressman from georgia
julian bond former state senator from
georgia and host of a television show
and charles evers goes on and on how
come we know all those names and don't
know fannie lou hamer well of course i
would like to think that a lot of people
uh do know fannie lou hamer
so i think if someone followed the
movement at all or was part of it they
do know fannie lou hamer i think one
reason though
is
if they don't know who she is
was that she died
in 1977 when the movement was sort of at
its ebb
she didn't have someone
like coretta scott king
was to martin luther king to burnish the
memory she didn't have that so that
that's one thing and frankly i think
another reason is that um
a lot of the
women in the movement have not gotten
their due
because frankly it's been the men who've
written history and i think as you get
more and more women writing the history
you'll get more of these stories they're
any number of women almost
as powerful in terms of a persona as
fannie lou hamer and they haven't had
any story told
this little light of mine why the title
that was her theme song
that was what she sang in any number of
the mass meetings to sort of get people
fired up to go out and confront the
police dogs or the voter registrars or
or whatever or if people were scared
she'd sing it to
calm their fears
the other reason i think for the title
this little light of mine is
it really summed up her
she
she was a little light she was actually
a pretty big light and she
shone that light
on a lot of the dark places in the
american soul
and so i think there was sort of a
double meaning in that that was her
theme song that was what everybody
recognized from the movement was one of
the things that she sang often and
that's really uh also what she did was
shine her light on
a lot of the things that needed fixing
you know one i don't know what the
audience can tell or not it's one of the
more unusual covers
this is matted around here dull black
this is a shiny see the audience can see
that whose idea was this
well it was some genius at dutton who
designed the cover i i
it may say inside the book jack and who
the cover design
was with bob we ought to give that
person the credit um
by neil stewart right so neil stewart is
the genius who came up with that the
photograph is by a woman named charmian
redding
and the photograph is stunning
it was taken
during the meredith march in mississippi
in 1966
and it was
one of the few days mrs hamer was on the
march she didn't do marches very much
because she had a severe limp from
either a childhood case of polio or
one of her brothers who had been tending
her when she was little may have dropped
her broken her leg and it didn't set
properly it's not clear
which that was but
she was on the march for a day or so
and i had been looking
for a photograph of
mrs hamer with dr martin luther king
and i really wanted in case people
didn't know her
i wanted to place her
with
king so that they know sort of the crowd
she ran with
and
i went
to see charmy and reading
to see if she had a picture i i had seen
some other things
she had taken she showed me that picture
and then she said i have another one a
mrs hamer singing and then it was just
the head shot and
that became such a natural for the cover
go back to this photo just a second here
and ask you this is martin luther king
right how old was he then
you know
well let's see that was taken in 1966 he
died in 68 and he was not 40 when he was
shot in this picture and this is andy
young what was he doing then he was a
chief aide for dr king
and so he was always at king's right
hand and with the southern christian
leadership conference and mrs hamer was
a
field secretary for the student
nonviolent coordinating committee and so
she was one of the people who you could
always count on to rally the troops or
calm people down and that would have
been why she was on the march there's so
many connections in here and this is
this was a surprise to me when i saw
this picture and learned about who this
man was because our audience knows
don edwards the congressman from
california who is len edwards lynn
edwards is his son
who is now a
judge in san jose
and he was a law student at the
university of chicago
at the time of freedom summer in 1964
and he was one of the volunteers who
dropped what he was doing that summer
and went to mississippi he lived with
the hamers part of the summer and he
wrote some wonderful reports
that helped
really bring that summer to life because
you could interview somebody now you
know and they could sort of vaguely
remember
what
happened but his reports were written at
the time for the
i think it was for the council of
federated organizations which was sort
of the umbrella group that ran
the freedom summer and he told some very
uh detailed stories about how
when mrs hamer would
go into a meeting
with
the white summer volunteers it would
show people that
they were to be taken seriously and
she just could
sort of grease the skids for so many
things that would get done
and she also had written him a letter
before he went to mississippi that
summer telling him how dangerous
it would be that the highway patrolmen
were not your friend in mississippi at
that point and that
how pleased she was that he was willing
to come but how dangerous it was and for
him to be very careful and he said
she was the most inspirational person i
ever met
and he said he told me
she knew i loved her
and that
how how truly remarkable he found what
she and the other people in that small
town were doing you've got a map
here in the front of the book and we can
see
on that map you can see jackson down
here and then but up here in this area
where was she born
well she was actually born in montgomery
county mississippi which is just
slightly
to the right as i'm looking at it
from the shaded area she wasn't born in
the delta but when she was two years old
her family moved into the delta
and right outside ruleville which is on
the map and she lived the rest of her
life outside or in
ruralville mississippi which is in
sunflower county the youngest of 20
children
what was her life like
dirt 4 is about the
most concise way of summing it up
they
she was the child of sharecroppers
a sharecropper it means that the it's a
farmer who rents the land
or uses the land of a white plantation
owner and the sharecroppers can be white
or black but they were mainly black
they would rent the land the
plantation owner would advance them seed
and money to get through the summer the
sharecropper would plant the crop
chop the cotton which meant weeding the
crop would pick the cotton and then at
the end of the season they'd weigh the
crop and then figure out what share
that's where the term came from they'd
figure out what share
the
the worker got well the things managed
to get subtracted a lot from what the
worker got and so what it really was was
a modern-day form of slavery
so at any rate she was the child of
sharecroppers and at about six years old
she started picking cotton herself
she
had only a sixth grade education she was
very smart
but uh she had to go to work
after the sixth grade and in fact
that's almost false to say that she had
a sixth grade education because
the children of sharecroppers could only
go to school when they weren't working
in the field so that would be about four
months of the year they didn't have
very good teachers they didn't have
books they you know mississippi
basically wanted to keep an uneducated
workforce to pick the cotton
and so she was poor they never had
enough to eat
she didn't have shoes to go to school no
hot water no walking indoor toilet right
no shoes as you say and i just i wrote a
bunch of this stuff down
could she vote when she grow when she
became 21 years old
no and that you know i've thought about
that since then um the summer of 1962
i was 21 years old i registered to vote
i think by going to the courthouse or
the post office and signing something
where montgomery county maryland
she
in the summer of 1962 was 44 years old
wanted to vote had never been able to
vote because after reconstruction in
mississippi the
state democratic party systematically
disfranchised barred from voting the
black population because if they voted
then they would share power they would
want better schools they would want
roads paved they would want indoor
plumbing and they would want to share in
the system and the plantation owners
didn't want them to share in this system
so she wanted to vote
she
knew that the system was wrong but she
didn't know
anything
to do about it until the summer of 62
when the
young people from the student
non-violent coordinating committee came
to sunflower county
now what was the student nonviolent
coordinating committee right that was a
group that was formed after the
student sit-ins started in 1960 lunch
counter sit-ins that started in
greensboro north carolina and spread
across the south when the young black
students were trying to
get
equal use of
lunch counters
department stores and so forth they had
a meeting then
which i'm forgetting the date but i i'm
sure it was 1960
which they formed
originally
dr
king wanted them to be a student branch
of the southern christian leadership
conference the group that he headed
but the students really wanted
independence they wanted to do things
their own way now this is a picture of
james foreman right right here right who
was he he was one of the
directors of snick as it was called by
its initials sncc snick he was one of
the
leading
people in the student nonviolent
coordinating committee bob moses was
another his pictures there
and the young man with the sunglasses
over there charles mclaren was the lead
snick worker in uh in ruralville
mississippi now back in those days
um
there was a lot of talk about schnick
people being trained what at the at the
justice department or
you know there was a lot of suspicion
about the communist influence
where their money come from
they uh i mean they were they were the
revolutionaries in the group they were
much more militant than
sclc and kings sclc
the southern christian leadership
conference they were much more
militant they were in many cases
desperate and they would uh
take the legal help of anyone that would
help them so the national lawyers guild
was one of the few groups that would go
to mississippi and so there was a lot of
red-baiting there was a lot of
call of the group were communist that
were in fact
simply
working for social justice but
it was easy to
tar someone by accusing them of being
communist so
snick was accused of
communist ties miss hamer was accused of
communist ties and
no way i mean she
she said she knew about as much about
communism as she would say as a horse
knew about christmas day
she had absolutely she was not an
ideological person she was
interested in civil rights and then
later in human rights but that was a way
people could try to discredit the work
that was being done at the same time
there was a major figure out of
mississippi
the man on the screen right there james
o eastland who was he
he was the
senator from mississippi he was chairman
of the senate judiciary committee
he
i mean it fascinated me he was also from
sunflower county so here you had these
two
giants of that time
james o eastland and fannie lou hamer
who lived 10 miles apart in sunflower
county and worlds apart he had
he had gone to several colleges
he had been elected to the state
legislature when he was in his 20s he
had been elected to the u.s senate in
1942
quite young
he had a plantation
he had power fannie lou hamer
roughly the same age sixth grade
education couldn't vote until she was 44
or 45 years old
and lived in a house with no
indoor working indoor plumbing i mean it
was fascinating to me that these two
people were in the same county and in
fact it didn't really even dawn on me
until i was
well into the project she kept talking
about eastland this and eastland that
and then i finally realized you know i
think that was the spur
that helped goad her to do even more
than she did was that she knew
eastland's power over people and so she
really meant it when she said she was
opposing him and she wanted to bring
jimmy slim down and ultimately the work
that she did he didn't run again in 1978
he chose not to run
because he wouldn't have been reelected
enough blacks had been registered by
that time
you worked for senator edmund muskey did
you know
senator eastland when you worked for him
no do you remember seeing him during
those years
perhaps i passed him on the elevator i
don't think so i don't think i ever saw
him
jamie whitton also plays a role he is
still i believe the man with the most
time served in the house of
representatives the dean of the house
right now how does he figure in all this
he was the congressman
uh
back in those days
the state's been redistricted since then
he was the congressman who
was representing the area in which mrs
hamer lived and in 1964
the
mississippi freedom democratic party
which was organized that year to oppose
the regular democratic party had a mock
election
that they ran fannie lou hamer against
jamie whitten she had also tried to
participate in the primary
and
she
lost obviously the the freedom
democratic party i should back up was an
organizing tool it was an attempt to
show people what you could do how you
could get involved so she knew she would
lose she ran knowing full well she would
lose but it was to show people
how to do it
so she ran in the primary and then in
the fall they had a mock election
and in the mock election of course a
number of
the blacks could vote
in the mock election and so she beat
jamie whitton in the mock election no
surprise
so the following year 1965
fannie lou hamer
victoria gray and annie devine
challenged
the seating of the five members of
congress
from mississippi one of whom was jamie
whitton
there's a picture here can you tell us
who are these three folks are okay on
the left is fannie lou hamer in the
center is uh victoria gray now victoria
adams who lives in petersburg virginia
and on the right is annie devaughn who
is from canton mississippi uh and uh mrs
adams and mrs devonne are still alive
and still very active uh to talk to them
for them i sure did they were
extraordinarily helpful and when did you
start writing when did you start
gathering the information for this book
1989 i had i got a leave from my job at
that time with the los angeles times
i got a rockefeller foundation research
grant and the fellowship of the
university of virginia the carter
woodson institute i went there i spent a
lot of time in mississippi that year
doing interviews
looking at the archives
reading the transcript of the
trial which we can get to in a minute
but mainly to do interviews so i started
i spent
almost entirely that year
doing research because i knew when i got
back to california i could do the
writing and i had a contract
with dutton so i knew i had that
coming in i got back to los angeles and
then i wrote the book
back in los angeles i would say i spent
all told about three years
on the book but it had been in my mind
for since 73. why did dutton buy the
idea
well i think they knew it was a powerful
story i think they could see the drama
in the uh her attempt to vote
her uh the meeting in the winona jail
which as i said we should talk about
and the confrontation
with the
president of the united states
in 1964 at the democratic convention and
with the members of congress in 1965 i
think also they probably knew
that by now in america people are
looking for heroines
and fannie lou hamer was a heroine
you've written a couple other books
yeah what was that about
that's about women in the newspaper
business
it's called a place in the news
from the women's pages to the front page
it was published in 1988
and is
now available from columbia university
press
and it was about
where women are in the newspaper
business how they got there and what
still needs to change
in terms of their further advancement it
was also i also talked about what
difference it made that there were more
women you know writing editing
and assigning the news why did you leave
the la times editorial board
i left because i wanted to write more
books uh i i guess i'd had a taste of
that freedom that wonderful freedom of
being able to go to mississippi and do
research
being able to
sit out at my computer and write what i
wanted to write
i love working at the la times but i
love writing books and i hope that i can
keep doing it how long did you work at
the la times i was there for
13 years
how much of a change did you see with
the number of women at the l.a times
during the 13 years you were there
quite a number in terms of the women who
came onto the news staff when i started
on the editorial page
there was i was the only woman
i was
there had been a woman before but i was
the second woman on the editorial page
ever by the time i left and now they're
four or five so
that's a sea change there still are not
enough in the top management in the
whole newspaper business it's not just
the l.a time so women have made the
their women are making it to the sort of
managing editor and middle level but
there's still very few at the top levels
harry belafonte
he keeps popping up in this book what
did he do
well
he
helped finance
a lot of the
snick activities
he would send money he would help raise
money by virtue of his name he would
have concerts and people would come and
make donation he went to mississippi
several times
and
at some personal risk in 1963 i can
recall he went to greenwood with
cindy poitier
and
and and so they appeared
there at least one demonstration i'm
sure he was there more often than that
he also helped support mrs hamer at
times because
she
didn't make much money her husband lost
his job
on the plantation when she tried to vote
ultimately he got a job as a head start
bus driver but it was a gap of some
years there when they really didn't have
much income and she would not
keep
any of the money that she helped raise
for the movement or would keep very
little of it so every once in a while
it's under some money and the um
the man who runs the
general store there in ruralville would
remember sometimes that should get money
orders from harry belafonte and i think
probably at first he couldn't believe
that this was really from harry
belafonte but it became very clear when
she kept coming back with them that
indeed these were from belafonte so he
cashed them for
but
i i remember talking to harry belafonte
about mrs hamer and he
um
he sang with her some i think
did you ever hear her sing did you i've
heard tapes i did not personally hear
her say i've heard tapes it was a very
powerful
voice that she had and that's why i went
to see harry belafonte because
one of the most difficult things i had
to do in the book was
figure out how to describe her voice
printed page is um
hard to
describe what somebody sounds like so i
decided i would go talk to some of the
people who sang with her harry belafoni
and pete seeger so i went to see
belafonte uh this was not hard duty to
go see
belafonte or seeger who where'd you find
harry belafonte well it took about a
year to get the interview because he's
so busy but finally he was in los
angeles um doing some
work and i went to interview him at his
hotel suite and he could not have been
more gracious
and he
he really he was another one of these
people who loved fannie lou hamer and
wanted to make the time to talk to me
and he particularly told me some of the
wonderful stories about the trip to
africa that they made after the 64
convention
in which um
mrs hamer who they had just been
confronting the president of the united
states lyndon johnson
and
when they got to africa
secuture the president of guinea came to
visit them without an entourage and she
just wept because she said we can't get
in to see the president of our own
country and the president of this
country comes to visit us
as honored yes you got to tell the story
about
what happened right before she met the
president oh yes that was that was a
good one um
then gotten there it was hot now what's
the country against the country's guinea
and i'm if i'm mispronouncing it please
uh i don't want the whole embassy down
on my neck
in west africa
she went they had a lovely villa that
had been loaned by toure
and
um she'd gone and take a bath
and so secretary arrives with unescorted
so harry belafonte went up knocks on the
door says ms hamer
president toure is here oh she said i'm
you're just
funning me you know um i'm i'm i'm not
ready to meet no president
he said you know
he really is here
so she evidently just got herself out of
the bathtub in a big hurry dried off
threw powder all over to try to dry
herself off and came
steaming downstairs and indeed nobody
had been playing a joke on her there was
the president of the country
there and he
had on apparently a sweeping
white caftan
and just swept her into his arms
and she was rarely at a loss for words
but apparently for a few minutes there
she was dumbfounded and this was in 64.
1964 in september couldn't get in to see
london johnson right why not
he didn't want to see those uppity folks
from mississippi uh he
she had just challenged
him
and his selection of a vice president
and his well-ordered convention
and he just didn't want to deal with
chicago
no no no this is atlantic city city
right
i think i think he
you know lyndon johnson never left
anything to chance as we know what
happened with that election he swept
over very goldwater but he had just
signed the civil rights bill you'd had
all the turmoil in mississippi he did
not want
um his coronation if you will i mean he
didn't want his convention he didn't
want any reason for the southern
democrats to walk out
so he didn't want a floor fight over the
challenge to the all-white delegation
and what the
this the black mississippians were
trying to do was get their case in front
of the american people and lyndon
johnson didn't want it on television and
so he sent hubert humphrey to defuse the
situation with the either direct or
implied threat that if you don't take
care of this you won't get the vice
presidential nomination
so there are a lot of little things the
time flies i just want to i want to make
some connections here let this picture
right here and this
woman
is eleanor holmes norton right
when was this taken that was taken in
1964.
and i think eleanor must have just been
right out of law school
then and yale yes yale law school and
she had been working with joseph rowell
on the
challenge the legal brief to be
presented to the credentials committee
and you if you show the picture again
there's one other woman people should
see the woman on the right with the
sunglasses is ella baker who was sort of
the intellectual guru if you will for
the student nonviolent coordinating
committee she was the one who suggested
to them no don't be an adjunct of
the
sclc
do your own
thing and she was also the one
who suggested to them that they really
be
grassroots
organizing rather than top down the way
king's organization was that they were
from the bottom up because if
they didn't when the students left
then
the people wouldn't know any more than
they had beforehand about how to deal
with the powerful people so that was
that was
in large measure ella baker's
idea yeah two other
kind of non-sequiturs i could only find
jesse jackson's name in here twice where
was he during ole miss he was in chicago
i i can't be positive i'm not quite sure
at some point he was still in college uh
in north carolina
uh he went to chicago in the
mid
to late 60s i think
he was definitely
involved in the 68
convention
it was one of the things that i didn't
have space for
during the 68 convention i think i
mentioned
in there that
mrs hamer and unita blackwell and some
of the other people from mississippi
went to
jesse jackson's church
and rode through the streets of chicago
and saw the violence of the anti-war
demonstrators but
jackson
jackson's life touched fannie lou hamers
often
but
i just had to make some hard choices and
really deal more with the people who
were directly working in mississippi the
now deceased first black member of the
supreme court thurgood marshall's name
comes up once and it's in connection
with
harold cox right right
the story
is told this would indicate eastland's
power and his attitude uh harold cox was
had been his and ben eastland's roommate
i think in either law school or college
he wanted cox on the
federal court and lyndon johnson wanted
thurgood marshall
on the
i wasn't the supreme court then or was
it a solicitor general i can't remember
i think it was i think i think it was
supreme court so he said uh eastland
apparently ran into
bobby kennedy at one point on the hill
and he said and please forgive me my
friends he said if you tell
the president
senator eastman yes this is
and
uh boy this is where the memory plays
tricks whether it was john kennedy it
may have been john kennedy appointing
marshall as solicitor general uh we need
to look on this
and i should know this i wrote the book
after all
but
nonetheless it really doesn't matter
because what eastland said
you tell
i i'm thinking he said you tell your
brother
that uh if he gives me hero talks i'll
give him the [ __ ]
meaning thurgood marshall
uh
i'm but i've got the page number i'm
gonna go try to find out
i i think before
we end this
and we've got some time we ought to talk
about winona
and but go back to uh
when did fannie lou hamer make the first
public move that made you know that
started this whole process
it was the late summer of 1962
after the student nonviolent
coordinating committee
people had come to sunflower county they
held a meeting they told people what
they could do
if they
would register to vote it made perfect
sense to fannie lou hamer so then they
said this meeting was on a monday night
some things i can remember in others i
can't i was on a monday night and they
said who will go down with us
to the
courthouse on
friday to register she put up her hand
and when she put off her hand that night
i think she certainly changed her
personal history and she changed a lot
of the history for the people who
worked with her and lived around her
they went they made the drive to
indianola they tried to register and of
course the test was it was a literacy
test
and it was geared
for uh prospective black voters to fail
no matter how smart you were
they would always catch you on something
and and if you didn't fail that part
then make you interpret a sec section of
the state constitution you know state
constitutions they're incredibly
complicated so she failed the test uh on
the when she got back home that night
thrown off the plantation so that was
when she the man who threw her off the
plantation really threw her into the
arms of the civil rights movement and it
was then the following summer
that she
she's gone to several meetings to learn
how to train people to vote citizenship
education they called it she had been in
charleston south carolina she was on her
way home
and that's when she and half a dozen
other people who were on a bus
the winona bus station they were
arrested
then what then what
they were the charge was something
trumped up like disturbing the peace i
always like to say i think they were
disturbing the peace of mississippi but
they were taken to this little brick
jail
booked
have you been there i've been there uh i
went to june johnson who was one of the
women who she was only 14 at the time
um two summers ago
june took me to the jail with her talked
the sheriff obviously not the same
sheriff that was
in power then talked the sheriff into
letting us see it was an enormous
benefit
they put the people in the cells
i think june was probably the first one
that they
hit with their fists hit her in the
mouth
and hit her beat her
um is there a policeman doing this these
are policemen there was a sheriff
highway patrolman and the chief of
police
then
annelle ponder who was sort of in charge
of the group was brought out of her cell
they kept trying to make her say yes sir
she wouldn't do it she'd say yes
not that she was impolite she was
not going to be
humiliated and not going to be um
subjected to their indignities are all
the people in the wynona jail black that
we're talking about yes they're all
black and then
they took um
mrs hamer out of her cell took her to
what they call the bullpen which is
where they kept the male prisoners they
had two black inmates then that they
threatened that they would be they would
be beaten or worse if they didn't beat
mrs hamer they made fannie lou hamer
this at that point 45 year old
stout short woman who walked with a limp
they made her lie down on the cot and
then one beat her with a black jack
until he
got tired and then the other one beat
her with a blackjack at the order of the
law officers they break anything uh they
i don't think so she was left with
probably permanent kidney damage
i mean she was
black and blue
june said if you'd ever seen a snake's
skin it was like that
after she was beaten she couldn't sit
down for several days they took her back
to her cell
where i think she promptly passed out
um
one of the women who was in the cell
with her said that she ran a fever that
night i mean she had been brutally
beaten
and
they sang to keep their spirits up they
weren't given proper food
and they were in jail for about three or
four days
and
one of the
snick workers lawrence giott came to try
to get them out of jail he was thrown in
jail and beaten
finally
andrew young
james bevel and dorothy cotton came up
from a meeting they had gotten the call
that
that's where they were because when you
didn't check in
the
people would go to work and try to find
out where you were
and so they found they were in the
winona jail
and
um they called andy young they also
julian bond was at work in
atlanta he called the fbi so there were
a lot of calls coming into this little
jail
finally on about the third or fourth day
andrew young arrived with bail money and
they
they got out of jail when they got out
of jail
mrs hamer and the rest were told that
while they had been in jail
medgar evers who was the
naacp
director in jackson mississippi had been
shot and killed in the driveway of his
home
what proof do you have that she was
beaten that badly
well you know i asked the same thing
because i had this horrible thought
supposed the story
was made up
the law officers
you know testified in court that the
women particularly had resisted being
put in their cells and they had to be
dragged into the cell
so i wondered about this and i
spoke with the
man who was the u.s attorney
in
oxford at that point a man named h.m ray
he as it happened had been in washington
for a meeting
right after mrs hamer and the rest of
them
got out of jail
fannie lou hamer and the nell ponder
went to atlanta uh right after they got
out of jail
and they met with dr king he sent them
to the justice department so within
let's say two days after they got out of
jail they got to the justice department
h.m ray was there for a meeting
the
um
somebody said you've got to come and see
this he met these two women he said
there was absolutely no question in his
mind that they had been brutally beaten
there was no way he saw their injuries
he said there was no way they came from
being dragged across a floor
and
there was also a doctor that had
examined them when they got out of jail
but h.m ray was not
a radical he was and after all when you
got to be the us attorney in oxford
mississippi in 1963 you're not um you
know you're not a sniff worker so i took
his word for it he was a very upright
man by the way just so that everybody
will get the full story
thurgood marshall's appointment as an
appellate court judge in the kennedy
administration was being traded for
harold cox to be a district court judge
and that's on the page i won't forget
that again that's on page three well i
had it wrong too so it's on page 32. um
all right they were in jail they got out
of jail what got him out again andrew
young had the veil money okay
what happened then was there a trial
there was a trial the following december
uh lasted about three or four days it
was
right after john kennedy had been
assassinated
so there was no press coverage none none
none you didn't see anything in the new
york times or l.a could not find any
press coverage on this whole incident uh
there was
in the new york times there was a small
story
three or four paragraphs about the
they were suspected to be in jail then
there was a story that yes indeed they
were in jail this came out of the
uh snick
press operation the julian bond had
gotten this in the paper and gotten on
the wires
there was a story on the front page of
the delta democrat times that um they've
been released not no word in any of
these stories about that they've been
beaten let me interrupt the delta
democrat times was run by hot and carter
it's in greenville mississippi it was
the only paper
in mississippi at that point that
provided uh objective coverage of the
civil rights movement it's interesting
in that story mrs hamer's name was
misspelled it was j-a-m-e-r and so the
first time she gets in the paper her
name's misspelled you know what else is
new um but uh then there were some
stories that summer when the justice
department brought charges against the
law officers and the city of wynonna
they brought civil and
criminal charges and the interesting
thing is
this was very rare for the justice
department at that point to bring
criminal charges against a southern
law official it this was before
andrew goodman james cheney and michael
schwerner were
arrested and disappeared the following
summer so this was very rare if it
wasn't the first time it was certainly
one of the first times that this
happened bobby kennedy got personally
involved and announced the charges at a
news conference so that was
in the papers but when the trial came
it was a week after kennedy was
assassinated maybe somebody else has
some press coverage i couldn't find any
and so the trial lasted three or four
days
and
all white jury
in oxford mississippi all males yes
women didn't serve on juries at that
point in mississippi a whole other story
um
the jury deliberated a little over an
hour and acquitted
all the
law officers
acquitted the law officers
what happened to the whole movement
after that what did fannie lou hamer do
from that moment forward well i think
this was one of many cases that made
the people that were working in
mississippi decide that they needed help
and they weren't getting protection
uh black people were dying were being
jailed and beaten and it seemed that
nobody cared so that's when they
brought the
college students down to mississippi for
the summer of 64 and
challenged the all-white
democratic party delegation to the 64
convention but that
this was just one element i think that
led them to
bring
the students to mississippi that summer
they
tried to challenge the mississippi
delegation 64. what happened
they lost
they lost but they won
mrs hamer's involvement was she was sort
of the star and witness
their attorney was joseph rowe
who was active in the democratic party
who was a national committeeman from the
district of columbia he knew a good
witness when he saw it and he knew he
had heard fannie lou hamer's story so he
put her on the stand and in fact while
she was on the stand in front of the
credentials committee telling what it
was like to try to vote
try to be a first class citizen lyndon
johnson called a press conference in the
white house to try to bump them off the
air
well it was played on tape or on film
that night over and over so everybody
saw her testimony this is the first time
i ever heard of fannie lou hamer was
watching this testimony on on television
she talked about going to try to vote
she talked about
being beaten described it in
great detail she talked about
uh having shots fired into the house she
talked about um
the threats that she'd gotten and then
finally she said if the mississippi
freedom democratic party
isn't seated then i question america
so it was pretty powerful stuff
and then
she argued against a compromise that
hubert humphrey proposed what they said
they would do is give the mississippians
would come up there were 68 of them they
would give them two at large seats and
they would tell
the
democratic parties and all over the
country that hereafter no one could
discriminate but uh and and they said
anyone who
will um sign a loyalty oath to the
uh party's nomination can be seated
knowing very well of course that
the regular democrats wouldn't sign the
loyalty of but at any rate
mrs hamer said
argued against the compromise because
she said we didn't come all this way for
no two seats because all of us is tired
so
she
the
full convention never knew though that
the freedom democrat didn't want the
compromise it was voted on and it did
become
the
uh rules of the party and it really did
start opening up the party to the
uh diversity and overused word now but
to the diversity that we saw at the
democratic convention in 1992. just five
minutes left there's a lot more in here
in this book but let me jump to the end
and we've got some
you've got some pictures here this is a
picture of uh the funeral
what was her life like
in the last several years
again what year did she die 1977.
her life was i think one of very great
frustration in her last three or four
years she wasn't well
she had hypertension she had a nervous
breakdown at one point i'm sure from
overwork
she but she kept on going i mean it was
extraordinary
she
had very poor health care
she developed breast cancer
and had surgery for that 1970s
but she stayed active she
helped bring low-cost housing to her
hometown
she sued the local school system
i helped save the job of the black
principal in the high school there
she
her dream was a farm co-op that would
help people
have food produce their own food so they
could have some independence from the
man and she put it from the plantation
owner she stayed active she
i think five months before she died she
went to jackson for a demonstration
about
cuts in medicare
so she
wasn't well i think she
found
mississippi was resisting
the full enforcement of the voting
rights act this frustrated her
enormously so she
felt
somewhat abandoned that things were
moving on without her
so she uh
i guess
i get sort of sad when i think that
she didn't live to see the changes that
have happened today she would have loved
um i have to tell this story i was in
ruralville mississippi very recently
and at speaking at the public library
that 30 years ago she couldn't use
and
at the invitation of the librarian from
sunflower county
and
a
the new state senator black man named
willie simmons stood up he had defeated
the man who defeated fannie lou hamer in
1971 when she ran for state senate
willie simmons was the first black
senator from sunflower county he stood
up and said
i am living fannie lou hamer's dream
well a pretty powerful moment
here is the
tombstone and you can't see it clearly
on the screen but it says there i'm sick
and tired of being sick and tired you
read that a lot throughout your book
where did that come from she
said it a lot she said it to an
interviewer in about 1964.
she would say it
in speeches
all over and she meant it literally i am
sick and tired of being sick and tired
and and and all of the people were tired
of this of course i was um
extremely excited last summer during the
1992
democratic convention when
bill clinton quoted fannie lou hamer
saying i think he said something like if
like fannie lou hamer you're sick and
tired of being sick and tired then
whatever it was he was proposing um went
on i didn't hear what he was proposing
because i got so excited about what he
said that he mentioned fannie lou hamer
so
you know she is known by
at least certainly a lot of the
southerners who came of age
during that movement what do you hope
this book will do
i hope it will show young people that
one person can make a difference
next book for you
i'm about to sign a contract with dutton
for
a primer on women's history
other books you want to write
yes i'm not quite sure yet uh i don't
know when i'll get as good a subject as
this again
but i'm sure going to be looking would
you rather write biography
or policy oriented stuff i think right
now i'm a little um
i've been so immersed in her life i'd
like to do some policy stuff until i
find
another
this little light of mine
here's what the cover looks like and our
guest has been k mills
who's now a freelance writer used to be
with the los angeles times editorial
board the name of the book is this
little light of mine
the life of fannie lou hamer thank you
very much thank you brian
[Music]
next week on booknotes our guest will be
alex dragneesh who served as the public
affairs officer at the u.s embassy in
the former republic of yugoslavia he'll
discuss his new book serbs and croats
the struggle in yugoslavia
book notes can be seen each sunday
evening on c-span at 8 pm eastern time
and again at 11 pm eastern time the
program can also be seen each monday
morning beginning at 6 55 a.m eastern
time
coming up in a moment prime minister's
question time from the british house of
commons
[Music]
we'll show them both starting with the
extension of the voting rights act this
is 10 minutes
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
[Applause]
thank you good morning welcome
thanks for being here on this special
day
please be seated
america began with the declaration that
all men are created equal
this declaration marked a tremendous
advance in the story of freedom
yet it also contained a contradiction
some of the same men who signed their
names to this
self-evident truth
owned other men as property
by reauthorizing this act congress has
reaffirmed
its belief
that all men are created equal
it's belief
that the new founding started by the
signing of the bill by
president johnson
is worthy of our great nation to
continue
proud to be here with our attorney
general members of my cabinet
leaders of the united states senate
and house of representatives
i thank the bill sponsors
i thank the members of the judiciary
committee
i appreciate so very much
representatives of the hamer family who
joined us
representatives of the rosa and raymond
parks institute who joined us
members of the king family in particular
reverend bernice king and martin luther
king
thank you all for coming
honored to be here with civil rights
leaders like dr dorothy height
julian bond the chairman of the naacp
bruce gordon thank you bruce
reverend lowry it's good to see you
again sir
[Applause]
fortunately i got the mic this time
i'm proud to be here with mark morriel
thanks for coming mark
juanita abernathy's with us today
jesse jackson good to see you jesse
al sharpton
dr benjamin hooks and francis are with
us
a lot of other folks who care deeply
about this issue we welcome you here
it's good to welcome the mayor
mr mayor good to see you thanks for
coming tony williams
everything's fine in the neighborhood i
appreciate it
and the mayor of sam alabama james
perkins is with us mr mayor proud you're
here welcome sir
the right of ordinary men and women to
determine their own political future
lies at the heart of the american
experiment
and it is a right that has been won by
the sacrifice
of patriots the declaration of
independence
was born on the stand for liberty taken
at lexington and concord
the amendments to our constitution
that outlawed slavery and guaranteed the
right to vote came at the price of a
terrible civil war
the voting rights act that broke the
segregationist lock on the ballot box
rose from the courage shown on a selma
bridge one sunday afternoon in march of
1965.
on that day african-americans including
a member of the united states congress
john
lewis marched across the edmund pettus
bridge in a protest intended to
highlight the unfair practices
that kept them off the voter rolls
the brutal response showed america why a
march was necessary
the marchers reached the far side of the
bridge
they were met by state troopers in
civilian posse
burn billy clubs and whips
weapons they did not hesitate to use
the images of policemen using night
sticks on peaceful protesters were
carried on television screens across the
country and they stung the conscience
of a slumbering america
one week after selma president lyndon
johnson
took to the airwaves and to announce
that he planned to submit legislation
that would bring african americans into
the civic life of our nation
five months after selma
he signed the voting rights act into law
and the rotunda of our nation's capital
and a little more than the year after
selma newly enfranchised black community
used their power at the ballot
box to help defeat the sheriff
who had sent men with whips and clubs to
the edmund pettus bridge on that bloody
sunday
for some parts of our country the voting
rights act marked the first appearance
of african-americans on the voting roll
since reconstruction
and in the primaries and elections that
follow the signings of this act many
african-americans pulled the voting
lever for the first time in their lives
81 year old willie bolden was the
grandson of slaves and in the spring of
1966.
he cast his first ballot in alabama's
democratic primary
he told a reporter it felt good to me
it made me think i was sort of somebody
in the american promised by our founders
every citizen is a somebody
and every generation has a
responsibility
to add its own chapter to the unfolding
story of freedom
in four decades since the voting rights
act was first passed we made progress
toward equality yet to work for a more
perfect union
is never ending
we'll continue to build on the legal
equality run by the civil rights
movement to and help ensure that every
person enjoys the opportunity
that this grade great land of liberty
offers
and that means a decent education and a
good school for every child
a chance to own their own home or
business and the hope that comes from
knowing that you can rise in our society
by hard work and god given talents
today we renew a bill that helped bring
a community on the margins into the life
of american democracy
my administration will vigorously
enforce the provisions of this law and
we will defend it in court
this legislation is named in honor of
three heroes of american history who
devoted their lives to the struggle of
civil rights
fannie lou hamer
rosa parks and coretta scott king
and in honor of their memory and their
contributions to the cause of freedom
i am proud to sign the voting rights act
reauthorization and amendments act of
2006.
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
good
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
founder of the sunflower county freedom
project an academic enrichment program
for teenagers profiles the lives of
former democratic senator james eastland
of mississippi a segregationist and
civil rights activist fannie lou hamer
during the 1950s and 60s the event
hosted by the sunflower county public
library in indianola mississippi is an
hour
it's great i look around the room and
and i see all kinds of familiar faces so
it's not like uh a typical book talk uh
because it really is like coming home
and it's funny when i when i flew in the
other day and uh there's a big sign
outside the jackson airport says you
know welcome to mississippi uh it feels
like coming home
and it actually did you know most of the
time those slogans are pretty cheesy and
you know nobody pays any attention but
it really does feel like coming home uh
because i i did live here for for a long
time uh you know the first five words of
this book are you know i love sunflower
county mississippi i'm unabashed about
that uh some folks may say that makes me
an insider or makes me
unobjective or whatever but but it's
true i came here when i was 21 years old
1994 i worked for these two young ladies
here miss fields and miss gardner uh for
for a number of years with with uh teach
for america and as a teacher at east
sunflower elementary and spent many
years here working
as the the head of the sunflower county
freedom project so i really feel as if i
i know this place i know many of you on
on many different levels and and it's
it's fantastic and i really appreciate
your you're coming here uh of course i'm
coming here to talk about this this book
which which apparently you know they
must have been sold uh
they sold too many copies along the way
you know they hijacked the the the ups
truck and and sold them all so that you
couldn't get to them um but they will be
here and also turn row books in
greenwood tomorrow uh i will be there as
well so i apologize for that there was
some kind of mix-up
uh but
you know i think think back to when i
was when i was 21 and when i first came
came down here you know teach for
america said oh you're going to be sent
to sunflower county mississippi i'm from
washington dc city boy
and like many folks in the in the north
i had certain images
of mississippi i'd never heard of
sunflower county but i had images of
mississippi that had been kind of etched
in my my consciousness as an american i
think that many americans who aren't
from here have that have have that
stereotype of mississippi so i was
thinking oh boy you know i'm going to be
going they're going to be some racist
rednecks out there there's going to be
segregation you know i've got to worry
about my kids getting lynched you know i
had all these crazy ideas about what
mississippi was like 1994 when i first
came down
and i'll have to admit when i first got
here mississippi really did confirm the
stereotype because i was teaching
elementary school up in sunflower and i
actually was renting a house i didn't
realize it was on the white folks part
and and some of my kids came over
uh early on miss gardner may remember
this and and uh wanted to play baseball
with me and and that caused a lot of
trouble in town uh they tried folks
tried to get me run out of town you know
our houses and our cars were kind of
messed with and uh all kinds of trouble
erupted after that and i thought to
myself i was like god lee you know this
is as bad as i thought you know and i
was like where did i end up you know
this place hasn't changed a bit in a
hundred years and you know i got all
high and mighty about uh about this this
backward place i found myself in
uh
but instead of staying on that high
horse i i figured i'd get down for a bit
and and i i went on a mississippi
history kick and so i i started reading
up
on on mississippi history and i i was
fortunate enough to run into a man named
hodding carter relatively early on and
he opened up his library to me and so
he'd give me a book and i'd read it and
then i'd send it back to him he'd send
me another so i started to learn about
this place and and it started to really
fascinate me because
this place wasn't wasn't backward at all
in a lot of ways it was on the cutting
edge of of global economics and and this
place wasn't wasn't static at all and it
changed a lot it was transformed
tremendously in the mid 20th century
in ways i hadn't even thought of and
didn't even know about when i first got
here and so what i what i realized also
the longer i stayed was was that
sunflower isn't all that much different
from washington dc where i grew up or or
north carolina where i went to school or
or la or new york or any of these other
northern places that like to consider
themselves so much fancier and
sophisticated and better than everybody
else
but it's smaller of course and more
rural but what sunflower county can do
is it crystallizes issues of race and
class and power that sometimes get
obscured in other places so i figured
well you know if i
learn a little bit more about this i
could tell a story that's actually
of interest not just to folks in
sunflower county but also folks anywhere
around this country because i think what
what this story is is an american story
and so
i started to figure out well you know i
could i could write about this
especially because there are these two
amazing people
so different so transparently opposite
from each other that are just so
fascinating and okay mills is in the
audience and then you know i was well
your book was one of the first ones that
was on that on that list where i started
to learn about this this woman named
fannie lou hamer and also this man named
james eastland and they were so
different you know you you had you had
you had white and black you had rich and
poor male and female you had senator
sharecropper planter picker uh you know
tall short methodist baptist i mean they
were different you know everything about
him was different so
i thought if i could tell the story of
sunflower county through their lives
people would be really interested in it
and i could learn something myself and
so that's what i did that's what this
this book is about it's it's about
change and continuity in this
home of ours uh and told through the
lives of of the two people it's not a
biography of either mrs hamer or senator
eastland kay mills has written a
fantastic biography of mrs hamer the
biography of james easton is has yet to
be written but it'll be written by
someone else more patience than i have
uh but what it is is it's a it's a story
of change and continuity in sunflower
county
uh and and
it's the story of two lives and i'll
start with senator eastland because in a
lot of ways he's he's the one we don't
know as well today uh you know you drive
into rural and you see home with fannie
lou hamer you can go to fannie lou hamer
daycare center in the in the graveside
complex and that many people remember
fannie lou hamer as a heroine of the
civil rights movement as they should but
not so many people remember james
eastland who was the u.s senator for 36
years chairman of the u.s judiciary
committee one of the most powerful men
in washington uh and and what's
interesting about him and the first
thing we have to just get it on the
table first thing to know about him he
was a racist and for some people that's
all he wants and and he was proudly so
profoundly so unabashedly so he he
talked about it plenty of times his
children that i interviewed talked about
it and and and set it straight up and so
there's no no need to mince words uh you
know he grew up in an era of of white
supremacy and brutal white supremacy and
we're talking about a man who grew up uh
in in the early 20th century his father
he was actually he was named for his
uncle james eastland who had been
murdered by a worker on the plantation
the family plantation
back in 1904 and his father had cobbled
together a lynch mob of several hundred
men
who chased the murderers down the
murderer down the murderer and his wife
along the way they killed several blacks
who happened to be in the wrong place at
the wrong time they captured
this man luther holbert and his wife
they tortured them they brought them all
the way back to doddsville publicized in
the newspapers
tortured them with a corkscrew and then
burned them alive
it's one of the most hideous
things i've ever
read or heard about in human history and
happened right up the road in doddsville
and nine months later
the senator was born named for the man
who had been killed so that's the family
in which she grew up they weren't proud
of it the senator easton's children
didn't learn about this until the 1970s
but this is what had the white folks in
mississippi in sunflower county felt
they had to do
to maintain their their position of
power and it was a position of power and
the second thing to know about james
easton is he was a planter
it was it was a major part of his life
even though he grew up in forest
mississippi he would come and spend the
summers in sunflower county and took
over the farm as an as an adult and that
was a big part of his identity he even
after he was a senator he'd fly back
home every weekend to spend time on the
farm
and and being a planter gave him a
certain perspective uh on on
how
how the world worked basically i mean he
he basically saw the world working the
way the plantation worked and that there
was a certain hierarchy a certain order
you know and at the top were the the
planners the oh you know the the the
owners of the plantation folks like him
who were who were wealthy he was one of
the wealthiest senators uh in in the u.s
senate uh who who had
basically unrestricted power over their
workers you had so you had white over
black you had rich over poor you had men
over women this was the natural order
and to him that what freedom meant to
him was was being able to preserve that
order
there was a certain responsibility on
the part of the the people at the top of
the order
and folks like him
to preserve that natural order because
if if people got out of their place then
then chaos would erupt
and so that's that's what he considered
to be true freedom of course that
clashed tremendously with mrs hamer who
grew up about five miles from the easton
plantation she was from ruval
mississippi the the 20th child where
easton was an only child she was the
20th and last of
of a family of sharecroppers and so
one of the things to understand about
her that that's that was that was
fundamental to our her identity was her
christianity she was a christian uh it
was the the church was one place where
where
sharecroppers could be somebody you know
they worked they bent they toiled all
week long uh and and sunday was a day
they could stand up straight put on
their sunday best and go and and be a
deacon or or raise a song or or
or have have control over one aspect of
their life and and
religion was a profound influence on on
her he gave gave her a language in it to
speak in a and a framework in which to
understand what was going on in in her
world i mean she very much saw herself
and the and and her fellow black
sharecroppers as the israelites and that
they had you know senator eastland and
the planners were pharaoh uh and and
they they were they were looking for
freedom
and and that that identity as a
christian combined with her identity as
a as a sharecropper and being a
sharecropper was fundamental to who she
was
even after she left the fields and went
to work as a as a civil rights activist
for the last 15 years of her life she
still considered herself first and
foremost a sharecropper and her
understanding of freedom was deeply
rooted in that that sense that that
freedom wasn't just about what's on a
piece of paper it wasn't just about
political equality it was also about
economic equality it was also about
having the chance to to
earn a real living a chance to to be
able to enjoy the fruits of god's god's
earth equally uh and so
the thereto their two identi
ideas about freedom clashed just as they
they clashed although they they never
met uh and what's what's interesting is
that
as much as they clash they also shared a
great deal they shared this sunflower
county uh earth you know this this
little patch of land and what they
shared also was was this connection to
cotton
which which of course still is so
important to this area although i'm
amazed by how much corn is being grown
this year i'm shocked uh
by by all the corn i see around it felt
like i was in iowa or something but hey
for for most of sunflower county's
history up until maybe the last year or
two
cotton
was king cotton has been dominant cotton
was the reason why uh the delta was
developed in the first place cotton is
the reason why it was a black majority
county from the beginning because you
had planners coming in they were the
only ones who had the money who had the
capital to clear
what was a jungle and turn it into
something profitable so that's why you
always have had a black majority here
what what cotton did is it created
dependence it created profound
dependence i mean first of all you had
the the the pickers the the the
sharecroppers like fannie lou hamer who
were profoundly dependent on the
planters uh they depended on the
planters for for healthcare and for for
their jobs and for their shelter and for
for everything
and the the the planters provided it
through a system of
of sharecropping and a system of
paternalism i want to read a little bit
from the the book about how this system
of paternalism used to work
basically
paternalism helped whites to explain and
justify sharecropping the paternalist
white planter was the head of the
plantation household he was the father
in charge of his ignorant sometimes
unruly but often charming black children
by this logic all the stressful
responsibility the heavy burdens of
overseeing a complex agriculture
operation rested upon the planters and
black share properties simply had to
work the land without worry about prices
and housing and yields and the like
paternalistic planters such as james
eastland made sure that their workers
were treated well enough to stay
contented with their lot
so long as the sharecroppers didn't
protest their condition or agitate for
equal rights
the eastland plantation was a relatively
good place to work
long after they no longer could work in
the fields black workers could remain in
their camp cabins on the plantation
but as named james eastland's daughter
anne remembered
if they'd been faithful over the years
they were allowed to stay there
but if they didn't do what you told them
to do
you didn't pay their bills or furnish
them what they needed
the eastlands also offered their workers
protection from law enforcement like
other planters they received deferential
treatment from the local police
fieldhands recalls that that woods
eastland father and later his son james
wouldn't let the police come on the
plantation and prevented local officials
from enforcing the law against their
laborers
if an eastland field hand managed to
make it across the sunflower river and
onto the plantation
cops pursued no further
once you made it across the bridge it
was all right went the saying that was
in sunflower county
so black workers were protected from law
enforcement they didn't suffer for
housing and emergency health care and
food
but that paternalism came at a high cost
by looking to the eastlands and other
planners to provide these basic needs
they became profoundly dependent on the
planner's goodwill
this dependence often cultivated within
sharecroppers a plantation mentality an
outlook on life that encouraged
immediate gratification and deference
while discouraging individual
responsibility in collective protest
the plantation owners provided a kind of
insurance in return for the security of
food shelter and a job you paid with
your freedom
so you had this dependence of the the
pickers folks like fannie lou hamer on
the planters folks like james easton but
you also had the reverse planters like
james easton were profoundly dependent
on their workers the planters needed
those workers to be in the fields
picking their cotton or else there would
not be any plant plantation empires any
amassed wealth you wouldn't have james
easton as one of the richest senators in
in the u.s senate because black black
sweat make white folks rich
it was just that simple woods eastland
the senator's son
who's named for his grandfather
grandfather
told me point blank he said the
lifestyle of the delta planters was
built on one thing abundant dirt cheap
labor without that labor nothing could
work and so the
planters went to extreme lengths in the
early 20th century to keep those workers
under control and to keep them on the
plantation
so you have the the pickers dependent on
the planners you have the planners
depending on the pickers and and then
you had both of them dependent on the
global cotton economy
you see what's happening is
globalization doesn't start in the 1990s
with the world wide web i mean cotton
was globalized a century earlier in fact
the the rise of the cotton trade in the
textile industry is what drove the
industrial revolution so from the
beginning cotton is a global crop it's
an export crop it connects this isolated
rural mississippi county to the the
world and so changes in in world demand
for for cotton uh world wars uh the rise
of synthetic fibers like like rayon and
spandex and all that all those
international developments have an
impact on what goes on on the
plantations of sunflower county and it
breeds within both the planters and the
pickers this profound sense of
dependence which may help explain why
there was such a profound desire for for
freedom both james easton and family
hamer had a sense that they
it was up to them to protect and defend
and promote freedom
and this world that they that they grew
up in this cotton world that they that
they shared really comes under attack
during the middle of the 20th century
and and you know the civil rights
movement is is what captures the the uh
the media attention and that's very
important but
also fundamental to to this time period
is the agricultural and economic
revolution that actually begins with
with the new deal in the 1930s when
federal agricultural policies start to
change
they actually benefit the large planters
like james eastland suddenly they're
getting fed getting more and more
federal money if they're getting
economic incentives to consolidate their
operations
to turn their sharecroppers off the land
and turn them into wage laborers so that
they don't have to be paternalists
anymore they don't have to provide the
housing and the health care and all that
they can just pay them wages and it also
starts to give them economic incentives
to turn to machines
now this this incentive is is enhanced
during world war ii when there's a
tremendous labor shortage because the
black workers start to go north into
into factories
and into uh into southern cities as well
where there are all kinds of jobs that
don't that that pay more and don't have
the same stigma as the plantation so the
the they're also being drafted by the
military so on the farm they have these
tremendous labor shortages labor
costs go up the planters start to turn
more and more to these machines the
cotton picking machines and re more and
more money goes into research and they
finally start to build machines that
actually work they've been trying to
build a cotton picker for decades but it
wasn't until the late 40s that something
that actually worked could be put in the
fields and so you start to see over the
course of the 40s and 50s a shift away
from hand-picked cotton toward machine
pick cotton you see a shift from
workers who have to chop cotton to to
get all the weeds out toward chemicals
that can just kill the cotton so by the
end of the 1950s the census bureau
thinks that sharecropping is on its way
out it doesn't even consider
sharecropping an occupation anymore in
the 1960 census and so what you have is
this this world of where the planters
were profoundly dependent on black
workers
is disappearing because suddenly
they don't need those black workers
anymore the eastland plantation had 800
plus people
living and working on the land
by the 1960s you only needed a dozen
maybe 18 men
that was it
so this this world has been shattered
the the the dependence of the planters
on their pickers has been shattered by
the agricultural revolution the economic
revolution
this is all happening at the same time
in the 50s and 60s as the civil rights
movement is going on and the civil
rights movement doesn't get to sunflower
county until 1962 but for eastland
it was ongoing he really became a
national figure in 1954 with the brown
versus board of education decision and
what's interesting and i didn't realize
this before i was doing my research he
was on the verge of retirement he was
never a very healthy man he didn't like
living in washington he never bought a
house he was thinking about retirement
lots of folks were thinking about
running against him in 1954 and then the
supreme court passed gave its its ruling
in brown versus board and suddenly it
was like it was like a jolt of
electricity in in him suddenly he saw
himself as as
being on a great crusade he he thought
back to his grandparents who had fought
in the civil war and had fought against
reconstruction and he thought it was his
turn to stand up for the south and he
became through a variety of speeches he
became one of the the
most widely known segregationist
senators time magazine put him on the
front cover and called him the spiritual
leader of the segregationists
but what made him different
was he became the chairman of the
judiciary committee in the senate this
is a very powerful committee this isn't
just your random little committee in
washington this is where sixty percent
of all bills
that that pass through the senate have
to go through the judiciary committee
and so he had this tremendous power i
want to read a little bit about how he
he wielded uh that power
by the middle of 1956 senator eastland
had learned to wield his tremendous
power ruthlessly developing a
well-deserved reputation as an
intransigent and effective foe of racial
and economic reform
the chairmanship of the judiciary
committee was a position ideally suited
for eastland a man born wealthy wealthy
and reared to assert unquestioned
authority over his plantation laborers
and household
it gave him not only the ability to
alter the nature
and course of legislation particularly
in in the realm of civil rights and he
used to brag he said he had special
pockets sewn into his suits and that's
where he put any of any civil rights
bills that came to him so they they'd
never see the light of day again so you
know he had these special suits made
but it also gave him the opportunity to
wield power quietly behind the scenes
much the way he used his authority as a
planter
his vitriolic public speeches had earned
him a reputation as a as a demagogue in
the mold of theodore bilbo but even
after two terms in the senate he was a
relatively obscure segregationist with
little clout to influence policy on a
national level
up until the 1950s of the mid-1950s he
sought to assert power through through
bombasts through these these tremendous
speeches often racist speeches
but that approach hadn't earned him the
respect of his colleagues
or
the ability to prevent progress on civil
rights
with his ascension to the chair of the
judiciary committee however
he came to be seen quite differently the
chairmanship gave him for the first time
in politics the authority he enjoyed on
the plantation
he learned to run the committee the way
he ran his farm and he began to see that
whether in the fields or in the hearing
room
true power didn't require
vitriolic speeches or ostentation rather
it gained strength from deference and
dependence
far from the racist redneck politic
populism of his mississippi predecessors
islam represented in the words of one
reporter the epitome of respectability
the gentleman planner who masked his raw
power with the outward appearance of
graciousness
of course he didn't have as much control
over what was going on outside of the
hearing room and outside of his
committee because the civil rights
movement continued to make progress and
it finally broke through into sunflower
county in 1962 when the student
nonviolent coordinating committee came
into sunflower county they came to
sunflower county because of senator
eastland they wanted to shine the light
on senator easton show him to be a
hypocrite and so they came here started
holding mass meetings and they found
this woman a stocky time keeper from the
marlow plantation in revel name a woman
named fannie lou hamer and mrs hamer
went to one of these mass meetings uh
she got fired up about voting she
decided she was going to come on down
here to indianola uh to the old
courthouse before they built the new one
and she was going to register to vote
and she tried and they kicked her on out
and sent her back up to rule by the time
she got home her plantation owner had
heard about it
got upset with her kicked her off the
plantation
that in an ironic way really freed her
up it freed her up to pursue civil
rights as a as a vocation as a as a
career as a as a living and so she spent
the rest of her life working full-time
on on civil rights
and it's extraordinary what she what she
had to go through i mean sunflower
county is very different today than it
was back then it was it was a very
dangerous thing to even talk about black
people voting and here she was going out
and talking to sharecroppers and
organizing going around the country
making speeches uh going to workshops uh
and she faced all kinds of of harassment
and i'll read about one thing that that
happened to her on her way back home
from uh from a conference in south
carolina where she was learning about
voter registration and
she was she was on a bus back into uh
just crossed back into mississippi and
she made it they made it as far as
wynonna
out on highway 82 before they uh got
stopped by the police for for riding in
an integrated bus
and uh so i'm going to read what
happened next they were all arrested
and then suddenly arriving to find white
folks appearing from everywhere with
guns the members of the group were
interrogated and then separated and
thrown into cells
and that's when the beatings began
the police first targeted june johnson
an enthusiastic 15 year old from
greenwood who had pleaded with her
mother to be allowed to go on the trip
despite her youth the officers beat her
mercilessly for several minutes before
moving on to anil ponder the group
leader
listening nearby hamer started here and
screaming like i'd never heard before
at least three police officers along
with another white man not in uniform
peppered ponder with antagonizing
questions and demanded that she show
them respect
they really wanted me to say yes sir
ponder recalled that's the one thing i
wouldn't say
they made her pay for her boldness
beating her with black jacks a belt
fists and open palms
she never would say yes sir hamer
remembered and i could hear when she
would hit the floor and i could hear
them licks just sounding
hamer's turn soon came
get up there fatso one officer told her
you [ __ ] we're gonna make you wish he
was dead and it wasn't an idle threat
what followed him recall was the most
horrifying experience i'd ever had in my
life
it's an exercise in racial and sexual
brutality that scarred her literally and
figuratively
she was thrown face down on a bunk bed
in a room with five might white men and
two plaque prisoners who were forced to
participate in the beating
given a long blackjack the first
prisoner beat hamer tilly give out at
which point the second prisoner was
ordered to start beating her
she tried to protect herself from her
bro the blows
but they beat my hands till they turn
blue
as she struggled her dress worked its
way up her body and she attempted to
pull it down but one of the white men
watching stepped in and pulled it back
up
the ordeal continued until the prisoners
grew tired and a bloody hamer who was
hard as a bone
barely able to walk or sit down had to
return to her cell and her body would
never fully recover
now what's interesting is the next day
she and the rest of her group were
arrested
for disor disorderly conduct and
resisting or excuse me convicted for
disorderly conduct and resisting arrest
they remained in custody for two more
days without medical treatment
upon leaving the jail they learned that
a white supremacist from greenwood named
had gunned down medgar evers the intense
world war ii veteran who had spearheaded
the naacp's mississippi efforts
evers murder
combined with her own uh savage beating
served to strengthen hamer's resolve
the day after her release she was
interviewed about the incident by staff
members of the southern regional council
and she bristled with indignation
something's going to have to be done it
really is i don't know how long we can
keep on going like this something's got
to break
her frustration bubbled over as she
thought about how long she and her
people had been suffering
just keep on saying wait we've been
waiting all our lives and still getting
killed still getting hung still getting
beat to death and now we tire to wait
and she was tired and she
did not let that beating hold her back
did not let her that stop her that was
1963 that she suffered that beating the
next year she was was actively involved
in freedom summer of 1964 bringing
hundreds of volunteers from around the
country to mississippi to help uh black
mississippians registered to vote after
the civil rights act and the voting
rights act were were passed she didn't
just stop and stop and say okay the
job's done she kept working for it and
because a lot of what she wanted to
achieve again was not just about
political equality although that was
important it was also about economic
equality for her uh the the the pinnacle
of her efforts was was freedom farm you
know she really wanted to create a
different kind of economic system for
black sharecroppers and white
sharecroppers poor sharecroppers
in the delta and so she created a
cooperative farm up in in northern
sunflower county uh where
people would share kind of like the the
early christians in the book of acts
they would they would share the the
harvest they would work together dole it
out based on who was hungry who needed
it
and freedom farm you know prospered for
several years before fading away in the
in the early 1970s uh as hamer's health
declined
and she died she died in 1977. uh but
what's interesting if you you know folks
it was a well attended funeral you had
andrew young from the united nations who
came and gave the eulogy he had hundreds
of people who had worked and were
inspired by mrs hamer who came to to
rule for the funeral
if they left william chapel and they
just walked about half a mile to
downtown ruble they could have visited
senator eastland in his office he was
still in power even after all the civil
rights movement had gone 1977 he was
still in power he retired a year later
and so it's it's interesting to to see
how their lives paralleled each other
and you know certainly when i came
just uh 20 years not even 20 years after
mrs hamer died
and and i came
and
what i came into was it was a
transformed
sunflower county it was transformed in
so many ways and we talked about the
economics you know if you if you drive
along the fields today
you don't see people
you know 50 years ago 60 years ago if
you'd had driven along the fields that
you know any time of the year especially
in the fall there'd there'd be people
everywhere there'd be there'd be
sharecropper cabins every every few
hundred acres there there would be
people bent over picking picking cotton
now there's nothing but machines very
few people so it's been transformed
economically it's been transformed
politically i mean look at the mayor of
indianola is is black the the
congressman who represents this area is
a black man the woman who represents the
the the
area and the house of representatives is
a black woman it's transformed
completely
from what it was a century ago when
senator eastman was born and yet at the
same time there's a resilient poverty
there's a resilient separation and
there's a resilient inequality that i
think all of us in this room know we see
it in our schools
in particular and we see it in in our
economics we we see it in the fact that
the the train tracks still
separate
to a large extent white from black rich
from poor
and and a lot of that resilience a lot
of that that poverty i mean part of it
is due
to to the recalcitrance of uh you know
the the unwillingness of some people in
the white community to give up power and
to and to transform as much as the the
rest of the the area has
some of it is due to what i mentioned
before the plantation mentality that was
kind of ingrained um in both whites and
blacks uh and and and has made it
difficult for for changes to be to to
take hold
but a big part of it is that economic
transformation it's it's global
economics it's what happens when when
the global economy comes through it it
produces changes in how we do business
it creates it forces changes in
technology
and then it moves on
and those people remain
people are the people are free they're
free to vote what are they free to do
and i think that's the conundrum that's
what we face nowadays that's what miss
fields and ms gardner are working with
with the kids every day to to to deal
with i see my my friend greg mccoy who
runs the sunflower county freedom
project you know that's what that's what
folks are dealing with today is how do
you deal with this this new world this
new sunflower county of the 21st century
that that doesn't have the same kind of
challenges that we faced in the 20th
century
so that's a little bit uh about my book
i i don't want it to to seem like it's
you know some people read and say oh my
gosh you know is is there any hope what
do we do you know it's such a depressing
book i don't think it's depressing i
think learning the history is exciting i
think it's it's inspiring it it
certainly inspired me in in my work with
the sunflower county freedom project uh
and and i think that that uh it can
inspire other people too to to do what
you know abraham lincoln called it you
know he said we have to strive on in
this work that we're in it's the it's
the work of making this country as well
as this county live up to the founding
ideals the ideals that are
are written into into the constitution
into the declaration of independence and
and and the the ideals of this country
uh we're a long way from that but all of
us have a part to to play
so that's my my my story um i i do
encourage you to to pick up a copy of
the book when they are available um
and uh as i said there are some at the
crown ms evelyn will be happy to get you
a copy and there's some at greenwood's
bookstore turn row bookstore and as well
as online of course you can get always
get them online but i'm happy to take
whatever questions that you may you may
have
[Applause]
oh it's a quiet bunch
all right front row mr cosman
have any educators in mississippi
taken and taken an interest in your book
for purposes of
exposing students to your writing
uh number half uh
certainly mostly at the at the college
level i see that alice has
has eight books okay so that you know
we'll we'll have we'll have a sparring
ring set up you guys can duke it out
over who gets the first eight uh eight
copies
that's right actually i i have one i
have one extra one here too so we have
nine
okay nine books um so educators have
educators picked up on this uh they have
in fact um
even before it came out
um
there's a young man jason ward who used
to teach up in rural i think he taught
with you ms gardner um he's he's now a
professor of history at southern miss
and he wants to use this book uh in a
course that that he uh that he teaches
on mississippi and in american history
uh so so that's certainly one and and
they have i think part of it is because
uh what i wanted to do is i wanted to
make this this book accessible i wanted
to make it readable uh you know i love
history but a lot of times just history
books can be really hard to get through
so i tried to make this more interesting
and i think having these two uh very
different characters is kind of you know
the protagonists of this story makes it
more readable i think more interesting
for for people especially young people
and students
other questions
if you don't watch out i'm going to call
on you that's that's what i used to do
with the freedom project kids right fred
so you better think of a question
yes
you spoke as uh when you first got into
sunflower county into mississippi
you felt like your perceptions were
correct that you know mississippi was
backwards how long after being here and
and really living the delta life so to
speak did you start to see that maybe it
wasn't quite what you it wasn't what
your perceptions really were how long
did it take you to really
see that you know that history had a lot
to do with the way people saw things
uh it's hard to remember you know i'm an
old man now and all those years just
kind of blur together
but but uh i think i think or relatively
early on uh you know i i recognize that
that incident i or i hoped it was a was
an aberration that it was it wasn't the
typical way and i also started to meet
more people i met you for example i i
met
lots of different people in the white
community and the black community um
who helped me
see how complicated the picture was i
think it's very easy for people who come
here temporarily i know teach for
america types are famous for this you
know we come in here and we're like oh
this is terrible you know i can't
believe how backward these people are
and then they run off and go home and
and you know i don't want people to
think that that this is one of those you
know those kind of books where they're
just like this is what a terrible place
aren't i a saint for having lived here
no it's not that that at all because i i
grew to love the place i i enjoyed uh
the the teaching that i was doing uh i
had had fun with what i didn't feel like
i was sacrificing anything by by being
here uh and uh you know i think that
there was there's so much about this
town in particular uh indianola but also
the area that that people from
washington need to learn you know about
how to live life and and and how to take
time for family and take time to visit
and to how to how to enjoy the what what
nature has to offer even if it's 95
degrees uh you know
it there's so much about this place and
i started to learn that early on it's
part of why i stayed uh you know i ended
up being living here almost almost a
decade
overall um because it is such a such a
beautiful place and it's such a such a
difficult place such a complicated place
uh if all you see is the the black white
the the the
the caricature
then it's not going to be very
interesting
other questions i see you too april so i
hope you're thinking of a question
all right um you spoke at the beginning
about how
uh fannie lou hamer and
james eason existing have two very
separate separate ideas of what freedom
is and i just wondered i feel like
you're pretty in touch with
politics today and i'm wondering if you
still see this
these two separate kind of ideas of a
freedom of you know the responsibility
of keeping everything in order and then
the other sort of
i mean the the the
the quick answer would be to say oh you
know it's that it's how the parties see
things are you know it's how you know in
general you tend to see conservatives
like senator eastland who see freedom is
much more uh being about structure and
order and protecting uh what what
society has has built up whereas someone
like family hamer would be considered
much more on the liberal side saying we
need we need to change things we need to
provide a safety net for people who are
falling through and and and so forth but
but again it's it is a little more
complicated you look at fannie lou hamer
she was as anti-abortion as as you could
possibly get uh in a lot of ways she
would be pegged as a as a cultural
conservative um that she was not a big
fan of the the women's movement which is
ironic because she was as strong and
powerful and and independent of woman as
you could get but she believed very
strongly in in a patriarchal article
society and and so it is a little bit
complicated but but i do think in
general that's where they would they
would the would play out and certainly
that's what's happened in mississippi
politics uh in the last generation is
that what there used to be just one
party in mississippi it was democratic
and it was white and and fannie lou
hamer and the mississippi freedom
democratic party smashed that they
changed that they integrated the
democratic party and so a lot of the
whites who were upset by that moved to
the republican party and created a new
republican party in mississippi
and now you have a very a very separate
uh political system but it's a two-party
system
other questions
okay
yes
what inspired me to write the book
that's a fantastic question what
inspired me to write the book uh well i
i felt like this was a this was a an
area of american history that that not a
lot of people understand certainly the
further away you get from sunflower
county fewer and fewer people understand
it so i thought that there might be a
lot of people who could benefit from
learning from this history who could be
inspired from learning this history i
was inspired by folks like like your
brother and sister who uh you know who i
worked with for many years and and who
uh you know who learned about this
history that as i was writing it uh you
know i would work in the mornings on the
book and then i go and work with the
freedom project students in the
afternoons and evenings and weekends uh
and it was it was a great way to to sort
of balance my my life because history
was never just something that that you
read about in the books or in the
libraries it was always something that
was very alive and that that could and
should be passed down to to
a new generation
thanks for the question
yes
enjoy the thorough history of what
you're presenting i heard you making
your comments that van lou hamer
considered herself a christian person
fighting for the rights of
african-americans
didn't james eastman consider himself a
christian as well
very good yeah he did he was a methodist
where she was a baptist it was not as
central to his identity
as it was for for mrs hamer certainly
the eastern children were raised were
raised in a christian household they
would usually go to church sometimes it
was methodist sometimes it was baptist
it was it was not the essential
organizing principle of their lives
however uh certainly his christianity
was very different from her christianity
you know and again you is this sort of
like you you see what you want to see uh
in in religion or in politics and what
he saw when he read the bible
was an emphasis on on order you know he
would look at first corinthians where it
says slaves obey your masters right
that's what he wanted to to emphasize
this idea that that you had to abide by
the the the rulers of the day and the
natural order the way god had prescribed
it and certainly segregationists like
him believed that they were
very good christians and that
segregation was god's way uh and mrs
hamer obviously had a very different
reading again looking at exodus and and
the the story of the israelites getting
freedom from egypt uh as as as the
fundamental story that the bible told
her
yes
i just wanted to know if in your book
you included
uh the education of black children that
had to do with the seasons of the cotton
was that included in there i know you
read parts of it
it is it's it's it's uh it's what fannie
lou hamer had to to grow up with um
what the question was what about the
education system that that black
children had to had to deal with and it
was a segregated system i mean one might
argue that we still
have a relatively segregated system
today but this was by law uh segregated
and the the black schools in sunflower
county were oriented around the cotton
growing season and so
students could only be in school when
there was not nothing left for them to
do on the farm and so generally that
worked to three or four months usually
in the worst times to to go to school in
the winter months when it's cold and
those drafty buildings were not the best
place to to try to to learn
but they would go to school three to
four months out of the year uh what's
interesting i i found a there was a
study done by by the mississippi
teachers group based in jackson they did
a study of of the curriculum that was
taught in black schools
and what they found was and and these
were white
uh surveyors and white researchers
making this study in the 1930s and they
were appalled they said
you if you look at this the the
curriculum that black students learn
there's there's no black writing there's
no black literature no black poetry
there's nothing about black scientists
black
black athletes black anybody
everything that is being taught to black
children teaches them to to accept uh a
subordinate status in society and this
was a white teachers group that was
condemning mississippi's own curriculum
and and so you can imagine that the the
schools that were set up were set up
with a with one purpose in mind and that
was to to
protect the the docile labor force uh
that the planners depended on uh you
know governor vardaman who was the
governor in the early 20th century he
said you know education only spoils a
good field hand
because you know once a person is
educated then you can't do nothing with
them right because now they want to read
now they want equality now they want to
vote now they want you know they will
they want to run their own farm now you
know that's a mess if you're a white
planter right so it's better to keep
away from keep keep
black students away from school or at
least
send them to schools that'll teach them
to be subordinate uh and and so that's
what fannie lou hamer dealt with she had
to leave school at sixth grade there
were very few uh black students who were
able to make it uh all the way up
through high school
yes
uh concerning the process of
interviewing the two families
were you received similarly by each or
was there
a difference how would you describe it
how was i received by people that i
interviewed it really depended on the
individual as opposed to
the the race of a person i was fortunate
because i i lived here and so i i had
people who could make connections for me
i i remember talking to jim abbott long
ago when i was first starting this
project and asked him how i could could
uh interview the eastland children and
he helped get me in touch with woods
eastland the senator's son woodson was
very gracious he he welcomed me into his
office
and we we had a number of good
conversations uh and similarly with andy
eastland up in up in memphis uh and sue
eastland down in jack jackson so uh i i
was i was
pretty much welcomed in
there was a little bit of suspicion i
think and and and concerned that i might
might just write a book that was like
the caricature of senator eastman um but
but i think because i lived in sunflower
county for a long time because i knew
many of the same people that they knew
that helped
pave the way similarly in the in the
black community i knew people who could
introduce me to to relatives who had
been sharecroppers on the on the
plantation and to and to
people who had been involved in the
civil rights community a civil rights
movement in sunflower county and and
again because i knew people already in
the community i wasn't just some
some stranger parachuting in you know
suddenly gonna you know write this
expose of sunflower county
yes
um
as a teacher and also a community member
but also as a historian it seems that
you had a
unique position where you had access to
both the black and white communities in
ways that maybe other folks didn't was
there anything in your research in
during the time you were conducting your
interviews that really stood out in your
mind as something that maybe you didn't
expect or surprised you
uh notice you can see greg listens the
directions like he stood up
paused waited for the microphone to get
there you know that's the sign of a
teacher right there uh
so that that's a that's a a great
question there was a lot that i i
learned that i that i didn't expect i
mean one thing that that i found really
interesting is that sunflower county is
i don't know if it's this it's a magnet
i don't know what if it's in the water
but it seems to attract people to come
here and and study and learn about it
the two books in particular that are
extraordinary are uh
horton's powder makers after freedom and
john dollard's casting class in the
southern town now these two scholars
came here in the 1930s uh and came to
ninola and lived and worked and wrote
about it and what's what's tremendously
fascinating to me is how alive how real
how similar what they were writing about
seemed to me when i first read them when
i got here in 1994 i was like wow this
is this is amazing and a lot of what
they what they they wrote wound up in my
in my book of course because they were
doing really good research and and
interviews uh on both sides of of the
the racial divide and so those two books
had all kinds of of nuggets of
wisdom that that i that i stole
else
mark pett
uh
chris can you tell us what you're
working on now
what about why did i leave if it was so
great why did i leave mississippi and
you know take off and and not teach in
the freedom project anymore uh what i'm
working on now is a is a national
project um it's based in washington it's
called the u.s public service academy uh
and and what we're trying to do now is
create a civilian counterpart to west
point in the military academies so we
want to build using the military
academies as a model we want to build a
federally funded four-year college where
students would get a free education and
in return they would owe five years of
service to the country instead of being
sent to serve in the military they would
be sent to serve in civilian public
service jobs uh at the local state or or
federal levels
so this would be we have we have five
military service academy this would be
the first one for people who want to
serve the country but don't want to go
into the military so that's what i'm
working on now full time in washington
but i'll tell you what i i think about
sunflower county all a lot my experience
here and with the freedom project
uh influences what i do and how i how i
view the world uh every day
yes i've i've heard hotting carter tell
speak and tell he can tell wonderful
stories did he help you with your book
and
my time frame is real different i it
seems to me like he's been gone for a
long time was he still here
he's not still here he yeah he's been
all all over the place uh
i i happen to run into him in washington
since that's where i'm from and i knew
he was from mississippi
and uh he helped me with this book in
the sense that he as i said he kind of
opened up his library to me um and he
really he he told me about horton's
powder maker and after freedom he told
me about uh i believe k mills and and uh
this little light of mine and a lot of
these books that had been written about
mississippi and you know he told me
before you go on off half cocked you
better learn a little something about
this place that you're in um and he's
been a good friend ever since he's
actually very supportive he's on our
advisory board for the u.s public
service academy as well uh and on the
with the freedom project so he's helped
in every endeavor that i've done in the
last 15 years
anyone else
ah again mr cosman
what um
what could members of the public do to
help you advance the public service
academy
ah
how could you help well there are lots
of things you can do to help
well you know we have volunteers all
across the country if any of them if you
know happen to know thad cochran's cell
phone number
um i'll take it you know after
afterwards i'd love to call them up we
certainly need senator cochran on board
he was the one who actually won senator
eastland's seat when senator eason
retired back in 1978 he's been there
ever since he's extraordinarily powerful
a very different man than senator
eastland certainly
and we think he might be very supportive
of the public service academy so i know
many of you in this room have already
written to senator cochran uh and we
just need to keep pushing putting
pressure on him to to support the bill
that's the number one thing we need done
young folks can get involved in our
national youth council which
which is nationwide and helps get more
and more people involved
yes sir
you've stated and i think you're correct
that we've made a lot of progress in our
area
and i'm interested to wonder
what you think
senator easton and ms hamer
would say to us today
about how we move forward from where we
are
economically and otherwise so it's
always hard to imagine what what uh
someone else might say 20 years after
their their passing i know under many of
the changes senator easton would have
found intolerable uh and
and unimaginable um although he did
start to change towards the the end of
his life after he retired he he actually
donated money to the naacp uh he wrote a
500 check to the naacp now this is an
organization that he tried to destroy um
he tried to destroy in the 1950s so that
was extraordinary he became very good
friends with aaron henry who was the
leader of the naacp uh out of clarksdale
and and so he started to to move he even
tried and you know you as he was
thinking about 1978 election he tried to
to do better uh with black voters he
hired a black staff member for the first
time and he started to change uh but i
think it was just it was a little too
much for him and it was a little too
late uh for him
what would he say
what would he say now i think again his
mindset was first and foremost as a
planner he would think about the
economics and and he would emphasize the
the economic nature of the problem that
we're that we're dealing with that we
need to find a way to provide jobs for
people who who aren't the planters who
aren't the bankers of the world who
aren't the college educated folks uh
because there there are lots of people
in this area who don't even graduate
from high school
they need something productive to do
when they were sharecroppers on the
plantation it was a very hard living but
it was a living
they were doing something with their
with their lives every day uh and so he
would emphasize the the importance of
industrial
development or or trying to figure out
some way
to put those people to work uh and
ironically i think that's what mrs hamer
would say too i mean i think she would
be
she would be
both excited by senator obama's
candidacy obviously i mean i think that
that that it was uh something she
probably couldn't have imagined when she
when she stepped on that bus to come to
indianola in 1962 to to register to vote
that you know here we were 40 46 years
later
with a black nominee as the the head of
the democratic party man it's it's
mind-boggling so she'd be very excited
by that uh i think she might be a little
bit disappointed though in in black the
the vote the record of black voting uh
in sunflower county in particular and
and in the delta as a whole that people
have the right to vote now but they
don't use it uh people have access to
education the public school education
but a lot of times the kids don't don't
take advantage of it
people have opportunities that she and
her generation couldn't imagine
and yet they're not being taken
advantage of and so i think she would be
very frustrated by by that she was even
in the years before her death uh and so
i think she would she would really harp
on on young people getting
more out of their educations and and
adults
not only doing more for kids but doing
more politically
yes ms gardner
today we have eastlands and the schools
in sunflower county we have miss
eastland teaching in roville
we have lynn hamer who teaches in rural
who is one of my teachers and then we
have a little children the local
children coming we have the eastland
coming in to do bibles with the gideons
today
will there be a sequel to this to show
what the descendants of islam are doing
today
i hadn't thought of that actually i
hadn't thought of that i mean there has
been a lot of transformation and i think
that that uh
that it is to me it it's it's a story
that's still being written you know it
certainly could be written yet but but i
think 30 40 years from now another
generation or so uh it would be
interesting to to see what what's going
on because i think the schools are the
crucible that's why i think it's it
i think it's particularly frustrating
for me and i think for a lot of people
in in the community to see such division
in the schools because you know if young
people aren't growing up together they
aren't learning together uh it it
separates the community and it
it directs people's interests and energy
apart rather than than together um so i
think that that's the the real challenge
that that we that we face
okay i think i'll wrap it up so that
those who need to go can go but i'm
happy to stay around and uh and continue
the conversation uh in the green room so
to speak um and and uh
thank you so much for coming i really
appreciate your your being here and we
do have nine books i'm sorry again
chris myers ash was a teacher for three
years in sunflower mississippi as part
of teach for america americorps he's
also a co-founder of the sunflower
county freedom project an academic
enrichment program for teenagers for
more information visit thenewpress.com
operations at the treasury department
and the federal reserve's pandemic
response
protesters and journalists who were shot
by police during demonstrations
following the death of george floyd
described their experiences before a
house panel jamie raskin leads off the
meeting commenting on the president's
actions in going to a nearby church that
evening amid the violence around the
white house
the subcommittee will come to order good
morning everyone and welcome to the
subcommittee on civil rights and civil
liberties briefing on the first
amendment under attack examining
government violence against peaceful
civil rights protesters and the
journalists covering them i want to
thank each of our briefers for joining
us today the written testimony you've
submitted is riveting and searing and a
major contribution to public
understanding and discourse about this
moment in time we thank you for it i
also want to thank our colleagues
representative mary gay scamland and
representative jackie speer who are not
on the subcommittee but have joined us
today the 8 minute and 46 second
videotape strangling and murder of
george floyd by officer derek chauvin
ignited a mass non-violent movement with
black lives matter to demand repair of
the broken social contract in america
this mass movement touching every state
large cities small towns farm
communities and suburbs has won the
support of more than two-thirds of the
american people in public opinion polls
and galvanized the conscience of our
nation provoking rigorous historical
analysis and serious legislative action
police brutality has been an essential
element of violent white supremacy and
racial injustice for centuries which is
why many of us are proud that we passed
in the house last thursday on a
bipartisan basis the george floyd
justice and policing act the most
sweeping and comprehensive police reform
bill in the history of the united states
of america but the movement against
police violence has itself led to
serious violations of the first
amendment at the hands of government
authorities and here i refer not just to
episodes involving individual police
officers but officials at all levels
from local police chiefs all the way up
to the attorney general and president of
the united states
this is the subject and focus of our
hearing of our briefing today
official violence against
first amendment protest threatens the
channels of political and social change
in america it turns the police power of
the government against the people
themselves unjustified unnecessary and
disproportionate government violence
against the people is an attack on
democracy itself it demands immediate
and serious response by the people's
representatives in congress it's true
that we live in a society where violence
threatens us as citizens in many
different ways
gun violence takes the lives of
thousands of americans every year which
is why we passed hr8 for a universal
violence felon background check
legislation we hope the senate will
still take up domestic violence affects
more than one million women a year which
is why we reenacted the violence against
women act in 2019 and we hope the senate
will finally take that up too lethal
violence by racist white supremacist and
ideological extremist groups has taken
the lives of hundreds of americans over
the last several years including nine
african american parishioners in 2015 at
the mother emanuel church in charleston
south carolina heather heyer who was
murdered in 2017 in charlottesville
virginia by white supremacist james alex
fields jr 11 jewish worshipers at the
tree of life synagogue in pittsburgh at
the hands of neo-nazi robert gregory
bowers 23 mostly latino persons killed
in a racial massacre at a walmart in el
paso texas in 2019 by white supremacist
patrick cruzias and so on and even in
the current wave of protests extremist
provocateurs like boogaloo and identity
europa have sought to infiltrate and
instigate violence in the marches and
rallies called by groups practicing the
traditional non-violence of reverend
martin luther king and the american
civil rights movement
tragically one federal security officer
david patrick underwood was killed on
may 29th the night of protests in
oakland california his sister his sister
testified before us movingly in the
judiciary committee on june 10th
although his killers had not been
apprehended at the time of her testimony
certain members tried to point the
finger at antifa but the fbi caught the
actual culprits and charged two men
associated with boogaloo a right-wing
extremist group advocating and planning
for race war in the united states one of
whom wrote boogaloo slogans in blood on
the hood of his car
every kind of violence we see in america
gun violence domestic violence white
supremacist and extremist violence is a
threat to the people and our police
officers too but today in this briefing
we zero in on the threat of government
violence unleashed against the american
people because of the content and
viewpoint of their political speech
their free assembly and their demands
for redress of grievances we similarly
focus on repressive violence unleashed
by the government against reporters and
photojournalists exercising their free
press rights to cover mass
demonstrations related to police
brutality we should never use background
conditions of social violence or gender
violence or extremist violence to
normalize the practice of state violence
against the people as justice brandeis
observed our government is the potent
the omnipresent teacher for good or for
ill it teaches the whole people by its
example crime is contagious if the
government becomes a law breaker it
breeds contempt for the law it invites
every man to become a law unto himself
it invites anarchy before i begin my own
opening statement i want to take a
moment to play a video compilation of
some egregious attacks on protesters
that have been caught on camera over the
last several weeks of protest clerks
please go ahead and play the video
[Music]
[Music]
back it up
[Music]
hey this is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
light them up
go inside
get in get in get in get in get in
get in
[Music]
[Music]
i'm trained in first aid i haven't done
it in a while and i was helping a man
who got shot in the leg with a rubber
bullet he was bleeding
so much you saw this
i was helping him i was cutting his
pants
i was trying to help him i was trying to
look at the wound and
and they came up and they they were
shooting right at us
that's number yeah
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
please keep these images in mind as we
begin today's briefings and now i will
recognize myself for an opening
statement because i'm a professor of
constitutional law people often ask me
what is the most important part of the
constitution and i'll talk for a minute
about representative government and
separation of powers and judicial review
and these days the
foreign and domestic emoluments clauses
which prevent uh
government officials theoretically from
converting the government into an
instrument of self-enrichment and profit
but the truth is that american democracy
lives and dies by the first amendment it
is the heart
of our constitution
and
the first amendment
contained six rights
and amazingly president trump and
attorney general barr
managed to violate and offend every
single right contained in the first
amendment when they assembled a secret
and unidentified paramilitary squad of
federal officers and unleashed pepper
spray
tear gas and rubber bullets on a crowd
of peaceful protesters many of them my
constituents and attending reporters all
in order to clear a path for the
president to get uninvited to the saint
john's church episcopal church so he
could perform certainly the most
grotesque photo opportunity in the
history of the united states waving
someone else's bible upside down
over his head
this violin and cartoonish display of
banana republican values trampled the
right
to one peaceably assemble on the streets
and sidewalks without being assaulted by
government forces too the right to
petition your own government for a
redress of grievances without being
physically attacked by unidentified
federal agents three the right to
freedom of speech
four the right to free press
five the right to free exercise of
religion without government officials
coming to occupy your church property
for political reasons and then barring
you from
access to your own church the next day
and finally the right not to have
government establish religion by fusing
governmental and ecclesiastical power
which is surely what president trump
intended to do in his own in artful and
incompetent way by brandishing the bible
like a political prop provoking outraged
responses from both the episcopal and
catholic bishops of washington dc dc for
this act of narcissistic idolatry the
performance was both unconstitutional
and blasphemous as the president
trampled the first amendment rights of
the people so he could violate the first
commandment of the bible which a lot of
our religious citizens do take seriously
the government's photo op riot in
lafayette square has been not an
aberration from but an illustration of
the kinds of official abuse of the first
amendment rights of the people that we
have seen in the traditional public
forum of streets and sidewalks and parks
over the last five weeks
since mr floyd's murder over ten
thousand people have been arrested
protesters journalists and even members
of the clergy have been hit with tear
gas pepper spray rubber bullets batons
and more police have used cities white
city-wide curfews as an excuse for
intimidation and violence in minneapolis
police shouted light them up and shot
paintballs at residents standing on
their own front porches for recording
police marches after curfew in los
angeles police methodically arrested
participants in a peaceful demonstration
just because it was after curfew and in
washington dc police kettled over 100
protesters onto one block and then into
one house on swan street waiting outside
all night ready to arrest any protester
who tried to go home there have been
disgraceful episodes of violence against
protesters and we will hear
unforgettable testimony today from two
different women one ms ratliff a citizen
protesting and the other ms tirado a
journalist who was on the scene both of
whom were shot in the eye
in two different protests in two
different states
police have used so-called less than
lethal weapons including tear gas and
rubber bullets fired directly at the
heads and in the faces of both
protesters and journalists in total at
least 60 people have suffered serious
head injuries at the hands of police at
least 20 of these people suffered eye
injuries and at least seven people have
lost an eye
the unprovoked brutality of some of
these offenses against citizen
protesters are only known because so
many americans refused to stop
exercising the very freedoms that are
under attack videos captured by
journalists and protest protesters alike
have shown police indiscriminately
spraying tear gas from their vehicles
into crowds firing rubber bullets and
seemingly indiscriminate ways in
clubbing and shoving protesters who are
kneeling or walking with their hands in
the air in one of the most haunting
videos america watched as buffalo police
officers shoved a 75 year old protester
to the ground inflicting a grievous head
wound and leaving him motionless in some
instances videos have forced police to
retract false official statements
attempting to excuse or deny misconduct
the free press has been targeted a cnn
news crew was arrested live on the air
cameras had been pulled out of the hands
of reporters in dc and louisville
kentucky news crews were shot with
rubber bullets and brutalized with
police shields as they live streamed
the president has praised and encouraged
this authoritarian response he's called
hundreds of thousands or millions of
peaceful protesters terrorists thugs
anarchists agitators looters and
lowlifes he has consistently placed
blame on demonstrators who have been
brutalized by the police going so far is
to call that 75 year old victim of
sickening police violence in buffalo an
antifa provocateur yet another revealing
figment of the presidential imagination
he has repeatedly taunted and threatened
protesters urged officers to get tough
with them and use violent imagery to
pour rhetorical kerosene on the fire he
berates and taunts reporters describes
the press as the enemy of the people and
calls any unflattering reports fake news
in american democracy the free press and
reporters are not the enemies of the
people they are the people's best friend
those who mean to be their own governors
james madison said must arm themselves
with the power that knowledge gives and
jefferson said if i had to choose
between having a government without a
newspaper or a newspaper without a
government i would not hesitate a moment
to choose the latter this president and
those officials that follow him have
been at war with the first amendment
which protects
wide open uninhibited and robust public
debate loud protests vigorous
controversy and democratic engagement
destruction of the civil liberties and
rights of the people is the road to
authoritarianism the people in the
streets who moved us to pass the george
floyd justice and policing act last
thursday are not the enemies of the
people they are the people in american
democracy the constitution the streets
in the future all belong to the people
not to the government much less to one
person who temporarily occupies public
office let's protect the precious first
amendment rights of the people with
everything we've got before i turn this
over to mr jordan i would like to play
one additional video compilation this
time of attacks on the press clerks
please play the video
press press
[Music]
i'm pressed
[Music]
exactly what it looks like
[Music]
or your cameraman
i was lining up a photo
and
then my world kind of exploded i
immediately realized that i'd been hit
in the face with something there was too
much blood i couldn't see i just closed
my eyes and started yelling i'm pressed
i'm pressed and so we walked away
i'm sorry
okay do you want to tell me why i'm
under wrestle
why why am i under arrest
we're going to end up in a place we
don't want to be here if we're not
careful katie so ah damn it
just move out of there as quickly as you
can we got plenty of time here
are you okay
i'm getting shot i'm getting kate katie
are you okay rubber bullets rubber
bullets who are they aiming that at
night
[Music]
please
[Music]
sorry
many americans are horrified by these
scenes of violence playing out on the
streets of the united states i now
recognize our very distinguished ranking
member mr jordan for his statement
uh thank you mr chairman we weren't able
to see any of the of the video you just
referenced i wish we could have been
able to uh
view that um mr jordan it was made
available to all the staff so your
office definitely has that and yeah
it's nice to see it during the actual
briefing if you're gonna run this like a
hearing it'd be nice to actually see
what what what you're putting out there
for folks to see i think the chairman uh
look the chairman in his in his um
opening
talked about
america lives and dies by the first
amendment he talked about people's
rights being trampled
for the past several months we have seen
democrat mayors democratic governors
tell tell american citizens you can't
open your business you can't go to
church you can't buy a gun you can't go
to your loved one's funeral
uh we saw
but somehow when it came to the protest
it was all different
we saw the mayor of new york city
in early may nine protesters pushing for
the empire state to reopen from the
coronavirus lockdown were busted outside
of city hall
he told the jewish community said my
message to the jewish community in all
communities is this simple the time for
warnings has passed i've instructed the
nypd to proceed immediately to summons
or even arrest those who gather in large
groups but oh how that changed
he went from we're not going to allow
any kind of gathering i don't care if
it's 20 people he went to a month later
during the protest i want to see a light
touch
a light touch
that mr no wishes that there was more
than a light touch from the police in
portland a year ago when he was attacked
we had the mayor of we had the mayor of
los angeles
he ordered utilities to shut off
uh ordered utility comes shut off
utilities anyone attempted to reopen
their business
so you try that you try to give someone
a haircut they're going to cut off your
water
he punished skaters by throwing sand in
the state parks the skate parks um
he arrested people going to the beach we
wouldn't want kids skating we wouldn't
want people going to the beach even by
themselves and yet during the protest a
month later he knelt down while
protesters were shouting deep on the
police and as we all know he wasn't
wearing a mask mr raskin when he uh when
he did that
we have the mayor of minneapolis
who a few months ago said imperishable
worship services would be a public
health disaster
but then he said we encourage people to
exercise caution when they're
demonstrating wearing a mass physical
distance as much as possible so how
things have changed
and that is my concern
this this unequal treatment under the
law it's not supposed to work that way
in our country as the attorney general
said
two months ago
the constitution is not suspended during
a crisis and yet based on the actions
we've seen from so many of these
individuals democrat mayors democrat
governors
during the coronavirus
prohibiting them from operating engaging
in their livelihood preventing them from
exercising their first amendment
liberties to go to church preventing
them from exercising their second
amendment liberties to purchase a
firearm preventing them from even going
to their loved one's funeral
but when it came to the protest
when it came to the protest an entirely
different story
and that is my concern and i hope we get
into those issues as well today and hear
from our witness
interesting the democrats put out their
press statement today they included
their witnesses but not the witness that
we invited mr no
which is highly unusual i don't know if
that's ever happened to any briefing or
hearing i've been a part of
we look forward to hearing from mr no
and his
his experience dealing with antifa this
terrorist organization that has attacked
him and been and threatened him numerous
times so with that mr chairman i would
yield back and i look forward to hearing
from our witness
who's our briefers today
first we have linda tirado who is a
freelance journalist
next we have gustavo martinez a
freelance journalist for the asbury park
press in new jersey next we have dean
tomiko brown nagin of the radcliff
institute for advanced study at harvard
next we have latoya ratliff an activist
and protester next we have andy noe
editor-at-large at the post-millennial
who was invited at the request of uh the
minority mr jordan and last but not
least we have the reverend ginny gerbazi
a constituent of mine and rector at the
saint john's episcopal church in
georgetown i would like to note that
several of our witnesses are joined by
council today council may intercede to
advise their clients on whether they may
answer a question i know that there's
outstanding litigation in some of the
cases that will be discussed today and
if it's necessary we ask the council
unmute and identify yourselves before
speaking
with that we will turn to ms tirado
ms
tirado has asked that i advise members
that due to her injuries she may at
times need to close her eyes or bow her
head but she will still be able to fully
participate and to answer our questions
ms terada we're extremely grateful to
you for joining us today and for
speaking out about your experience you
are now recognized for your five minutes
thank you mr chairman uh mr chairman and
mr ranking member today it marks the one
month anniversary
of the last time i will have woken up
with sight in both of my eyes
tomorrow will be the one month
anniversary of the morning i woke up in
a hospital and doctors informed me that
i had been blinded in one eye i had been
in minneapolis for fewer than 48 hours
my name is linda tirado and i am a
journalist i'm a writer a photographer
and a published author
i've covered civil unrest in america
since 2014 and my work on this issue has
taken me from ferguson to chicago to
washington d.c to the melher national
wildlife refuge and finally to
minneapolis i'm here to bear witness to
my own experience
i went to minneapolis because i expected
that george floyd's death was going to
be a catalyst for civil unrest
i arrived in minneapolis on thursday may
28th and i was out on the streets taking
photos until 4am
on friday may 29th i went out again at
about 8pm it was the first night with a
curfew but press had been exempted from
that so that we could do our jobs and
cover the news
i was wearing my usual clothes for these
situations a t-shirt and a pair of
shorts with a lot of pockets
i had a backpack and i wore my press
credentials conspicuously on a lanyard
around my neck
i always carry my reporter's notebook in
the right side pocket of my cargo shorts
and my recorder in the left i was also
holding my professional grade nikon
camera with a full flash
protesters could tell immediately that i
was working they asked me more than once
who i was working with
protesters had no trouble identifying me
as a journalist
as i've learned from covering other mass
protests these types of events have
similar patterns no matter where you go
police form ranks and push protesters
back uh protesters repeat or retreat a
few blocks and then a certain dayton
settles in on
both sides while everyone waits to see
what will happen next
i arrived during one of those loves and
i took pictures of the police line
because it is my job to try to explain
to the public what is happening on their
streets
on may 29th when i heard from protesters
that police were deploying tear gas
nearby to where i was i put on my
goggles and my respirator and headed
toward the fifth precinct
i would like to share some of the
photographs that i took that night
these photos show clearly what i saw
here's one of my photographs showing the
police during one of the moments i just
described they're holding their line
the photos that i'm going to show you
now were among the last pictures i took
with my camera on friday night i took
these in in the no man's land between
police and protesters and it's not
uncommon for the press to exist in that
space particularly photographers
so this is the fifth from the last
photograph i took
it shows an officer loading his gun from
the bandolier on his vest
ballistics experts will probably be able
to tell from this photograph what sorts
of rounds were being used by the police
i turn now to the third from the last
photograph i took
the police are in riot gear and wearing
vests that clearly say minneapolis
police department
finally here is the last photograph that
i took before i was shot
you can see an officer pointing his gun
directly down my camera lens
you can also see that at least one other
officer is pointing their gun at me
you'll also notice in this photograph
that a group of officers seem to be
milling around on that street corner
this was not a particularly dangerous
moment for them this was a moment of
pause this group of officers were not
part of the ranks who had been holding
their line one even seemed like he was
using his phone the photos do not show
police that seemed concerned about my
presence nor do i recall feeling as
though i were in any imminent danger
i felt confident in my position because
i was readily identifiable as press and
because i was not impeding the police
i recall lining up a photograph
and then i recall pain and wetness i
registered a dull thud and i realized
that i had been hit in the face with
something
my goggles came off and tear gas hit my
eyes i realized i was bleeding so i
squeezed my eyes shut
and started instinctively screaming
press i'm pressed hoping that that would
protect me
protesters came and took me by the arm i
recall someone saying they were taking
me to the medics
i followed them blindly and let somebody
bandage my eye
i did not realize how badly i had been
hurt because head wounds bleed freely so
i didn't panic i i thought i might just
need a few stitches
someone put me into their van and drove
me to the hospital
doctors told me i was going into surgery
immediately to try to save my eye i
tweeted a photo of my face and a picture
of my backpack which i noticed had been
hit with a bright green track around
because i wanted friends and family to
know that i was getting medical care in
case someone had seen me on a live
stream
i reported it duly and told the world i
would be offline for a while because it
is a bad idea to tweet when you are
under sedation
i woke up the next day in the hospital i
remember doctors coming to tell me that
i had lost sight in my left eye
i remember that all i wanted was a
whiskey and a steak or at least like a
really artery-clogging cheeseburger but
instead i was given extra bananas for
the potassium
i called my husband and asked him to fly
to minneapolis to drive me home he's a
veteran who served with the marine corps
in fallujah
he's now my nurse and i joke with him
that i've taken more combat injuries
than he has
for the first week i was not allowed to
take a shower and let me tell you trying
to wash tear gas and dried blood out of
your own hair in a bathtub without
getting water in your face is tough
i smelled of gas and smoke and sharp
copper for a week i could not get the
stink off me
i do not know what the rest of my life
will be like i do not know if i'll ever
be able to cover protests again or if my
injury will make this work that i've
engaged in since 2014
to risky but i will write and i will
report and i will try to do my job as
competently as i always have
i am angry of course and i am grieving
and i am worried that the united states
is becoming a more dangerous place to be
a journalist
i have lost an eye
but not any moral clarity
i was shot in the face for being a
reporter
i'm grateful that the subcommittee takes
up the issue of first amendment
violations of black lives matter
protests i will be as responsive as i
can with the hope that we have all seen
enough rage and pain and fire
thank you for the opportunity to address
the subcommittee i look forward to your
questions
your testimony thank you for being with
us today and thank you for your your
brave service as a journalist and to the
people of america
mr martinez you are now recognized for
five minutes
thank you
um
thank you very much uh good morning
chairman raskin congressman jordan and
members of the subcommittee thank you
for this opportunity to speak before you
today
my name is gustavo martinez and i'm a
staff reporter for the asbury park press
i have been a journalist for 16 years
and have covered political protests and
similar events across three countries
for more than a decade
until june 1st when i was arrested while
covering a protest in asbury park new
jersey i had never been arrested or
detained for reporting on a political
protest
i speak up today because silence the
silencing of journalists by law
enforcement is a fundamental threat to
american democracy
a press that should not be a bullseye
on the morning of june 1st 2020 i was
assigned to cover the black lives matter
protest in asbury park
that day i gather protective gear to
take with me that evening including a
safety helmet protective eyewear
a reflective bracelets and a yellow
bandana
i also plan to carry my usual equipment
my iphone to document action in real
time and my press passes from the new
jersey police press credential program
and from the asbury park press
i wear these badges on a lanyard around
my neck
around 7pm that evening i put on my
press batcher and head over to the
protest
for about two and a half hours
everything was fine
during that time i spoke with several
police officers who asked me why i was
there
i explained that i was a reporter
then around 9 30 there was a sudden
shift in the atmosphere
first law enforcement began using a
bullhorn to tell people to go home
next a police officer approached me said
it was past curfew and asked me why i
was still there
i faced the officer and with my press
batch around my neck i told him that i
was a reporter with the asbury park
press and was there to report on the
protest
i also explained that reporters were
exempt from the raspberry park curfew
he just looked at me and said quote so
you want a taste of the action you'll
get you'll get a taste of the action
then end quote
soon after i saw officers in riot gear
arrive at the area i double checked that
my press latch was clearly visible and
immediately put on my helmet and
protected i were
i
continued i continued live streaming the
events around me
around 10 p.m i stood with other members
of the press
and we suddenly found ourselves in a
group of protesters
um
who were being forcibly pushed out of
the area by osborne park police
i stood to the side with other members
of the media who were documenting what
was happening
as i stood there i heard streams i along
with other journalists turned and headed
in the direction they came from
i saw people being pepper sprayed by the
police i headed towards them to document
what was happening
i heard another scream
i churned again and saw asbury park
police pushing two young protesters a
man and a woman
i heard the young woman say that they
were leaving when suddenly the young man
was saddled to the ground and handcuffed
by several police officers
the young woman who i later learned was
his sister tried to intervene in his on
his behalf but a police officer grabbed
her and slammed her to the ground
i was live streaming on my phone as this
happened
then i heard quote evan here's the
problem and info
and from the corner of my eye i saw a
large police officer launching toward me
a moment later i found myself tackled to
the ground
my iphone was still recording as i was
knocked to the ground but the live
stream went dark just as the police
officer who tackled his scream quote
you're under arrest put your effing
hands behind your back end quote
no sooner had i hit the ground than
another officer yelled
quote take down his effing phone end
quote
the phone was slapped out of my hand my
press batch was around my neck the
entire time and i even verbally
identified myself to one of the
arresting officers as a reporter
i was handcuffed and handed over to
another officer to be loaded onto a van
with other individuals under arrest
that officer saw my batch and asked what
it was i said it was a press action that
i was a reporter and he
and he and the other officers then
stripped me of my helmet reflective
bracelets protective eyewear bandana and
backpack my press batch was still around
my neck when they loaded me into the van
police headquarters
more than five hours later i was
released from jail the next morning i
learned that all pending charges against
me had been dropped when new jersey
attorney general gerber greywall issued
a public apology and tweeted that quote
in america we don't lock up reporters
for doing their job end quote
i also receive a personal call from him
where he once again apologized
my experience on the night of june 1st
at the ashbury park protest continues to
haunt me there is no question in my mind
that i was targeted tackled and arrested
because i was reporting on the events
around me even though the first
amendment protects my right to do so i
hope that by speaking out today it helps
to ensure that countless other
journalists are able to freely report
the news without censorship by law
enforcement
thank you very much
testimony
and for stepping forward to give us that
mr martinez uh we are now going to go
to uh latoya ratliff
who will be introduced by her
representative in congress ms wasserman
schultz
i asked her to say a few words about ms
ratliff
thank you mr chairman i'm very proud to
introduce latoya ratliff an activist at
fellow south caribbean
whose courage inspired our community in
the nation
ms ratliff was among the millions of
people nationwide peacefully assembled
in recent weeks to demand an end to
police brutality and racial injustice
misratleaf attended a peaceful protest
on may 31st in fort lauderdale that
called for racial justice following in
the footsteps of her great-aunt fanny
lou hamer this
civil rights leader who organized voter
registration drives and fought against
white supremacy and the jim crow south
just regrettably just like her great
aunt before her mrs ratliff faced
indefensible acts of violence while
exercising her first amendment rights as
she held a protest signed and retreated
in a cloud of tear gas
an officer shot her with a rubber bullet
fracturing her skull and causing lasting
damage and pain
i'm so honored to welcome this ratliff
and i'm so pleased she joined us today
to share more about this harrowing
experience and lessons we can all learn
from it fighting for justice is clearly
in her dna and i am so proud to
introduce her to you this morning i
yield back
i know that ms ratliff's counsel has
asked that before she goes ahead to do
her testimony that we play a brief video
showing the moment that she was shot by
the police
in the clip that will follow viewers can
see ms ratliff being shot near the
center of the screen at about 19 seconds
into the video i understand that ms
ratliff does not wish to see the video
herself being played so she doesn't have
to relive the trauma of the event so ms
ratliff i will let you know when it is
safe to open your eyes so that you may
go ahead and launch your testimony
clerks please go ahead and play this
video
what are you doing what
[Music]
member members of the committee good
morning my name is latoya ratliff and i
work for a national religious non-profit
organization i want to thank the
committee for inviting me to share my
story today
in 1964 my great aunt fannie lou hamer
told the story of how she and 17 other
freedom riders risked their lives to
register to vote and how police were
used to intimidate assault and violate
the civil rights of she and other
citizens who had broken no laws that had
simply attempted to exercise their right
to register they called her [ __ ]
arrested her and took her to a cell
where she was beaten mercilessly
my great aunt was famously sick and
tired of being sick and tired i never
met fannie lou hamer but i've always
felt her spirit with me as i've
exercised my first amendment rights to
speak out against racial inequality and
policing
she suffered permanent injuries at the
hands of the police i still don't know
if i have as i sit here today i have
little to no vision in my right eye
doctors don't know if that will change
like hundreds of millions of people
around the world i was shocked and
disgusted by the murder of george floyd
i wanted to do something
i heard about civil demonstrations and i
joined in i have first attended one in
miami on may 30th we exercised our first
amendment rights without incident of
violence from the police
because of this experience i decided to
attend another demonstration the
following afternoon as i walked through
fort lauderdale that day i looked around
i saw a diverse group of people who
shared a common goal i saw young and old
wealthy and poor black white hispanic
and every other demographic you could
imagine at one point we took a knee to
show that we were no threat and meant
the police no harm at other
demonstrations the police actually
joined the demonstrators not here the
police began firing tear gas and
shooting rubber bullets
i will forever be scarred by the fort
lauderdale police shooting me in the
head on may 34th
officer eliezer ramos shot me a peaceful
demonstrator an unarmed woman in the
head with a rubber bullet
while merely exercising my first
amendment right to speak out against
police brutality i became the type of
victim that i was there to support
25 days after incident reports were
filed which make no claim that i did
anything unlawful or wrong i still await
an apology from officer ramos chief
maglione or anyone in leadership in the
city of fort lauderdale rather than an
apology what i have received from the
city is repeated criticism of my
decision to exercise my first amendment
rights less than 48 hours ago the chief
issued yes yet another state statement
in which he attacked me for speaking to
you today
i have sought a meeting with the city
the city but rather than speak to me the
police department seems intent on
continuing their attack on me since
demonstrating their disdain for the
first amendment on may 31st they have
continued their assault on my first
amendment rights in the months since i
know they're watching this morning so
i'd like to say this as clearly as i can
if you want to work together to make
needed reforms i'm ready to sit down and
talk but if you think you're going to
silence me with rubber bullets or
attempt to intimidate me through
statements to the press you've thought
wrong
while i seem to be the person who was
most significantly injured at the hands
of the fort lauderdale police that day i
am by no means the only one
a published photo seems to show the
damage done to a young man who was shot
in the face multiple witnesses claimed
to have seen two black men shot from
behind with weber bullets as they
escaped tear gas a white photographer
ran between them and was not shot
i appreciate those people
who honor the oath they took and
demonstrate the courage and sacrifice
and dedication so many of us associate
with the badge
it takes a special kind of person to be
willing to run towards dangers when
others run from it but too often police
unions make the rules which allow bad
cops to continue to abuse their power
and the public
too often the systems which are supposed
to create accountability and justice end
up failing and sometimes even after
someone is murdered
in the civil rights era of my great aunt
they fought for incremental change
though i recognize that progress is
often achieved incrementally the time
for incremental improvements to equality
and justice for people who look like me
has passed
we must entirely close the gap that
divides the treatment of most of you and
joy and the treatment that millions of
black people in this country suffer
i sit here today because miami
journalists sarah blaskey and nicholas
nahamas told my story and because of
countless of others who have dedicated
themselves to be the eyes and ears of
the public
i want black people in america to come
to a point where a routine traffic stop
doesn't make them fear for their lives
where protests are unnecessary but if
they do become
necessary no one life is at risk for
exercising their first amendment rights
it is truly grueling to watch videos of
trauma let alone be the victim in one
for black people we have lived in this
country for far too long without truly
being free and without truly being safe
thank you
uh thank you so much for your very
eloquent and powerful statement and like
you i never got to meet the great fannie
lou hamer but you are your great aunt's
great niece
and uh i i dare say that uh if you were
here today or if you were watching down
on you should be very proud of your
courage in following in her path of
creative and brave non-violence to
confront injustice so thank you for what
you're doing we go now to dean brown
nagin
you are now recognized dean brown nagin
for five minutes
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is tamika brown nagin
i'm dean of the radcliffe institute for
advanced study at harvard university and
also professor of constitutional law and
history at harvard i'm honored to have
been asked to offer testimony and a
subject of such great importance
the first amendment to the u.s
constitution protects the rights of
speech assembly and protests
and it is sacrosanct
the right to air grievances against
government including law enforcement
distinguishes democracies such as ours
from repressive regimes
as supreme court justice william brennan
noted in a landmark case
the freedom of individuals to oppose or
challenge police action without thereby
risking arrest is one of the principal
characteristics by which we distinguish
a free nation from a police state
nevertheless the long arc of american
history shows that the rule of law is
often tested during times of social
conflict political turbulence and
economic distress
during the great depression the cold war
the civil rights movement the vietnam
war and in recent weeks during protests
following the police killing of george
floyd some police officers have ignored
the principles enshrined in the first
amendment
now we must not hesitate to acknowledge
that law enforcement includes many
individuals who honor their
responsibility to safeguard the rights
and dignity of all communities a number
of these officers have been among those
demanding justice for george floyd even
so a legacy of repression lives on in
the actions of some and it must be
addressed
as an historian of the civil rights
movement that is the period from which i
will draw examples
in memphis more than 50 years ago
dr martin luther king jr delivered his
final address in support of striking
sanitation workers
after a court had enjoined plans for a
march
although king was familiar with
government violence bull connor's fire
hoses and police dogs in birmingham in
1963
bloody sunday in selma in 1965
among many other incidents he implored
those gathered to hold our nation to his
principles he said in part
all we say to america is be true to what
you said on paper
if i lived in china or even russia or
any totalitarian country maybe i could
understand some of these illegal
injunctions maybe i could understand the
denial of certain basic first amendment
privileges because they hadn't committed
themselves to that over there but
somewhere i read of the freedom of
assembly somewhere i read of the freedom
of speech somewhere i read of the
freedom of press somewhere i read that
the greatness of america is the right to
protest or write
the next day the court lifted its
injunction allowing the march to
continue
king cut down by an assassin's bullet
would not be there
but we still hear his message in our
streets today
since the 1960s there have been
significant changes in the relationship
between government and african americans
and between law enforcement and
communities of color
at the same time we have witnessed
recent violations of the right to
protesters that recall earlier backlash
against peaceful efforts to ensure
government accountability and equality
many of these incidents have been
captured on video and by journalists an
appendix to my written testimony
provides an extensive listing
to be clear
government can regulate the time placed
in manner of protests and cities and
states can impose curfews and pursuance
of public safety but such regulations
are strictly limited by the constitution
government cannot penalize the peaceful
expression of views even unpopular ones
and even perhaps especially strident
criticisms of public officials and
public policies
and this is true even if similar
activities in the past led to are
involved violence
to uphold the first amendment and equal
treatment under the law government
cannot discriminate on the basis of
viewpoint in 2020 any more than it could
in 1963.
it is crucial that the individuals
entrusted with upholding and enforcing
the law do more than observe this
bedrock principle of our democracy they
must protect it thank you
dean brown nagin thank you very much for
that discussion of the fundamental
importance of government respect for the
first amendment rights of the people i
appreciate that and we go now to mr no
you were recognized mr noah for five
minutes
thank you chairman raskin ranking member
jordan and committee members i'm a
journalist who reports on american
political violence
by speaking to you today
i'm putting my life in my own hands
for years i've been the victim of
hundreds of threats by anti-folk
streamers
they threatened to kill me
they spread lies about me being a
fascist
a neo-nazi
even a terrorist
they showed up to my family's home in
the middle of the night
and they nearly killed me when they beat
me in broad daylight within view of the
police in the middle of downtown
portland last year
i spent 30 hours in hospital as my brain
bled from subarachnoid hemorrhage
this past week
murder andy no was written on a large
wall in downtown portland next to the
antifa slogan
acad
all cop sebastians
i received more threats when it was
announced that i would be speaking to
this committee
i am in fear
the truth is too important to remain
silent
i've seen the photos of the injuries
sustained by my co-panels they're
absolutely horrific their complaints
must be taken seriously and properly
investigated
however
it is incomplete to focus on injuries
perpetuated by law enforcement
during the past month of riots without
examining the violent extremists like
antifa and others who instigate and
carry out violence from the cover of
peaceful demonstrations
from coast to coast american cities have
been convulsed with riots they have now
claimed dozens of lives injured hundreds
and caused countless millions in damages
over policing did not cause this
violent extremists and criminals did
in portland oregon where i do most of my
reporting
violent protests have continued for more
than 30 days
like in many cities law enforcement here
is routinely demonized by the public and
elected officials
i reported earlier this year for
newsweek about how the mainstreaming of
police hatred in portland has created a
culture of passive policing and a
tolerance of criminal moral behavior
on the evening of the 29th of may 2020
violent rioting spread to portland
after rioters stormed and set fire to
the ground floor of the justice center
which houses the central police precinct
and the sheriff's office they turned
their rage to downtown businesses many
were opportunists looking to carry out
carnage but i also saw antifa militants
dressed in their black uniforms taking a
leadership role in smashing windows and
breaking into windows so that looters
could pillage in a span of five hours
they destroyed countless businesses and
started fires with impunity
you could hear the distant sirens of the
police but no one would show up
police in portland and elsewhere have
sustained serious injuries from rocks
concrete chunks ieds and more
the weapons antifa extremists use are
intentionally designed to be deceptive
to legal observers media and those
around them
for example projectiles that may look
like water balloons are actually filled
with paint and used to blind police
before they're pelted with rocks
umbrellas are fastened with discreet
pocket knives at the end
projectiles that look like plastic water
bottles are actually frozen solid
innocuous looking handheld lasers are
shined in an officer's eyes before
someone with a slingshot ain't ball
bearings at his face
in new york candace
in new york nearly 400 officers
in a two-week period
150 local and federal officers were
injured in washington d.c in the week
police have been shot and killed
elsewhere i've seen with my own eyes how
antifa and other violent extremists used
peaceful protests to carry out acts of
wanton violence against property
law enforcement and citizens when i was
undercover in seattle's so-called
autonomous zone which was inhabited by
many antifa i received manuals and
booklets providing instructions on how
to use protesters as human shields and
cover
these are organized and committed
violent extremists who look
to destabilize the country
they are trained to use encrypted means
of communication to hide their trail
those who get injured or arrested are
regular protesters and even journalists
antifa melt away into the black wall
the first amendment is paramount the
street protests must be constrained by
the rule of law
law enforcement play one of the most
important roles in keeping
demonstrations safe
we've seen how this can work during
protests in dc at the end of last
month's self-described antifa legba
cara4 was recorded in a viral video
hammering chunks off the street to throw
up police
peaceful protesters made a citizen's
arrest and handed him over to law
enforcement he's been charged
george floyd deserves justice but so do
countless americans journalists and
others victimized by militant extremists
who use us as human shoes
thank you
mr no
and now reverend gerbezi you were
recognized for your five minutes
chairman raskin ranking member jordan
and members of the subcommittee thank
you for the opportunity to contribute to
today's briefing
my name is jenny gerbasey and i serve as
the rector at st john's episcopal church
in georgetown
before assuming my current role six
years ago i previously served on the
clergy staff of st john's lafayette
square
it was my ministry that brought me to
lafayette square on the afternoon of
june 1st
the day before during my sermon
i looked directly into the camera on my
laptop because that's how i was
preaching that day
and i called the church the church as a
whole
to account for its lack of courage and
leadership in dismantling systemic
racism
that sunday was the feast of pentecost
when christians celebrate receiving the
gift of the holy spirit
and i lamented
that literally for centuries the church
has squandered this mighty gift and has
not had the courage to stand up
and cast out the evil of systemic and
institutional racism from our civic body
in the name of love
racial justice
rooted in scripture
is now a critical ministry of the
episcopal church in the diocese of
washington
and it was that ministry at the
invitation of my bishop
that drew me and my colleagues to st
john's lafayette square
that monday i was there on behalf of the
church to provide comfort and support to
the peaceful protesters and to stand in
solidarity with them and with the cause
of racial justice
i was there in support of people
protesting the government's use of
violence and brutality against innocent
people
and with my own eyes
i saw the government use brutality and
violence against peaceful people
to be clear that day was marked by
peaceful protests
our group of clergy was based on what i
call the patio of saint john's lafayette
square
a large outdoor area on the corner of h
and 16th street regularly used by the
church for gatherings and for ministry
we were passing out water
snacks
hand sanitizer masks
and trying to ensure that the patio area
was a place of respite and peace for the
people gathered
it struck me that the patio had also
become a deeply spiritual place that day
i called it holy ground
and while you may not think that
episcopalians do this we were literally
laying hands on people and praying with
them
we offered them spiritual comfort and
support
people sat in the shade and on the steps
as a place of peace and
respite i would venture into the crowds
right around that corner offering water
and snacks
you could hear the people with
megaphones inside the park leading the
crowd in protests like no justice no
peace no racist police
for hours that afternoon
it was
absolutely peaceful
and then sometime after 6 15
things changed in an instant
suddenly i saw and heard protesters
running from lafayette park
i saw trails of smoke and billowing
clouds of acrid smoke billowing through
the crowds
people began to run north on 16th street
and pile onto the patio some of them
crying and asking for help asking for
paper towels or water or their eyes were
streaming with tears and their eyes were
stinging
the first flash grenade rang out
sounding like gunfire and i saw people
dropping to the ground in fear that it
was gunfire
i remember looking at my watch because i
couldn't understand what had happened to
trigger this sudden change in the
behavior of the police
it was 6
36
well before the 7 o'clock curfew
i was on the patio of saint john's
lafayette square and right across the
street from lafayette park i hadn't
heard any warning i hadn't heard any
message from the police the first thing
i heard were the screams of people
running people were running crying
dropping to the ground in terror
it was dehumanizing
as the protesters ran from the park i
called out water
and attempt to assist the fleeing
protesters
a man knelt in front of me
coughing and terrified his eyes swollen
and red he begged for something to help
the stinging and i began to rinse his
eyes
i heard someone yell rubber bullets and
i looked up from washing the man's eyes
to see a man in front of me holding his
stomach and bent over
he moved his arms and i saw marks on his
shirt
and then i looked over his shoulder
and i could not believe my eyes
a wall of police in full riot gear was
physically pushing people off the saint
john's patio maybe 15 feet away from me
the scene was shocking
and the terrified faces of the
protesters continue to haunt me they
were peacefully protesting and the
government used violence against them
that alone left me badly shaken
but when i later found out
that the president had just minutes
later
stood in front of the church and held up
a bible i was outraged
my clergy colleagues and i were there in
the name of those same scriptures
but we were praying with people giving
them water and food and then after they
were attacked by the police first aid
care
to hold up those same scriptures after
using tear gas and rubber bullets and
flash grenades and police in violent in
riot gear
was horrifying
and i say this not to make a political
point but to raise an objective truth
a scene i witnessed would have been
equally devastating regardless of who
was occupying the white house the
following wednesday although there was
no more tear gas or rubber bullets
police in full riot gear not wearing any
identifying information
blocked us from getting to a prayer
vigil at the church
let me reiterate that
we were not permitted to gather at our
church to pray
and this
like the events of june 1st
is antithetical to everything we hold
dear in this country
it's antithetical to my faith both
individually and as a clergy person and
should be abhorrent to people of all
faiths
i am here today to offer my account of
these events
but more broadly to add my voice to the
chorus demanding racial justice
and to ensure that what happened in
lafayette square that evening will never
happen again
and i look forward to answering your
questions
reverend gervais thank you very much for
your eloquent testimony
uh i understand that representative
wasserman schultz is about to board an
airplane but would have her five minutes
now to do her questioning am i correct
debbie
yes i'm coming to you then
thank you so much and first of all
really
my kudos to you for convening this
important briefing it is absolutely
critical that we use our
authority as the committee on oversight
and reform to shine a bright hot
spotlight
on these abuses of power and the harm
that are coming to people from
simply
standing up and expressing their first
amendment rights and that's exactly what
people were doing in fort lauderdale
when uh when latoya ratliff was uh was
badly injured i remember seeing the
accounts on tv and right after all of
this happened speaking
of females and constituents who
participated
in uh in in this
rally in protest for racial justice is
rally
as i understand it i i have to tell you
it was just absolutely astonishing to me
that uh that in our community that we
could have had this kind of police
overreaction
um
but as i understand it at the protest
that you attended in fort lauderdale
police tear gassed the crowd of
protesters and then fired uh foam
bullets did you hear any warning before
either the tear gas or the rubber
bullets were fired and i also want to
understand the ramifications
what the ramifications have been for you
for showing up to this protest can you
describe some of what your life has been
like since your injury i mean we're
talking about mr chairman people
standing up for their first amendment
rights and they shouldn't end up as a
result of doing that being gravely
injured and having physical and
emotional
ramifications for the rest of their life
miss valley
thank you
at no point um prior to being tear gas
or prior to the firing of rubber bullets
was there ever a verbal wedding um
unfortunately the warning that the
protesters and demonstrators were
provided with tear gas and even as we
were being tear gas as we've seen from
videos then people were still being shot
by rubber bullets and unfortunately
after what happened to me there still
wasn't any type of vertical warning or
acknowledgement from the officers to say
bring her here or come over and help me
as well
and um since that day um and actually
for a little over the first week after
what happened i i couldn't chew for over
a week i was actually kind of surviving
off of smoothies and soups uh beyond
that um my eye i still have vision
issues in my eyes i still have extremely
extreme light sensitivity
i'm still unable to look at the computer
so if you see me sometimes i'm veering
off
and
i have to continuously look away because
you know just my daily routine of
working and looking on the computer and
trying to write grants and trying to you
know perform social media outreach for
different organizations i'm no longer
able to do that
so
as a person who went to the fort
lauderdale protest to you know simply
exercise my first amendment rights
coming from that situation not only
being a victim but a lot of the goals
that i wanted to achieve afterwards
consisted of connecting with community
organizations and being able to help
them with funding and also being able to
help them with any initiatives that they
were looking to create or um
create or generate um
momentum around in regards to the police
brutality issues and because of what
happened to me i'd have to put that on
the background for now
you know thank you very much
mr chairman by all accounts
uh i had first-hand accounts immediate
in the
as the as the violence was unfolding
and in by all accounts this was a
peaceful protest and mayhem ensued after
the police overreacted towards the end
of the protest
so um this rally
what message does it send
in your in your belief when police shoot
at a peaceful protester as she marches
against police violence or knocks over
as also happened during this uh during
this protest a peaceful protester who
was on their knees
and uh
what what message does it send to
protesters and people who want to stand
up to their for what they believe in and
express their
from the first amendment rights of the
future
thank you congresswoman um
and thank you for mentioning what
actually took the demonstration from
peaceful to the state of the chaos that
ensued and as we've seen in other videos
there was a young woman that was
kneeling on the ground an officer
shelter and that was the pivotal moment
that took it from the peaceful day that
took it from that community rally and
people coming together simply to
exercise their first amendment rights
and simply to be a part of a change
uh seeing that video and actually
recognizing that that was the moment
that actually took the crowd from
peaceful and understanding that it was
never anything from the individuals that
attended the rally it was never them
saying we want to bring violence to this
administration it was the officers that
created the violence and knowing that
even after that even after that
situation had calmed down the officers
still from there were still you know
coming with tear gas and they were still
shooting rubber bullets and
what it means to to me and what it comes
off to the community as is that even
though they are enlisted the city of
fort lauderdale police department
they're put there to protect and serve
they're put put there to
protect the lives of the community at
that point and at that moment of me
being shot and afterwards and afterwards
with the four weeks after the incident
i don't know if that's accurate anymore
i don't know
if
i i feel comfortable attending events in
fort lauderdale where the police are
present because again i haven't received
an apology i haven't received an
acknowledgement of the trauma the
physical and emotional trauma that i
endured and that i'm going to continue
to endure so as a citizen that was there
that was peaceful that was simply
wanting to be a part of change and
seeing the police brutality that i was
met with it just comes off as if they
don't care or as they didn't want us to
be able to express our opinions
mr chairman thank you so much for your
indulgence and ms ratliff
i i hope and trust that because of your
uh family history of leadership and
standing up for justice and human rights
that uh that we will see you out there
standing up for what you believe in once
again and uh mr chairman the last thing
on earth in the united states of america
that should happen is people having
their first event right remnant rights
snuffed out through intimidation by
those that are there to serve and
protect
thank you so much for your indulgence
thank you very much miss wasserman
schultz uh i'm going to recognize myself
for my five minutes um
ms ratliff let me just pick up on that
you said that it was the officers who
created the violence you didn't see any
rioting or looting taking place
you need to unmute
sorry
no mr chairman i've been at the
demonstration for over three hours we'd
walked to multiple locations i spoke to
several individuals that attended the
rally and at no point during those three
hours did anyone become violent did
anyone express the the need to become
violent or the desire to come by
and as i've seen from the video and just
the timing of the video of the girl
being shoved by the police officer
that's the only thing that i can
recognize that shifted the peaceful
momentum of the event to the chaos
that's what broke the ice
but i've got one other question for you
you in fact serve on a police reform
board in in order to try to help police
build stronger community community
relationships is that right
yes
i was appointed to the police advisory
committee for the city of delray beach a
few months ago prior to about a month
and a half prior to warranty
i actually spent about six or seven
months applying and finally i was able
to be nominated to be on the board well
why did you apply
i'm sorry
why did you want to do that why did you
want to serve in that way
because
even as we look at the issues that um
the black community suffers from police
brutality or the issues i think there's
always a place to
to um fix that damage relationship i
think that i think as we continue to
look at ways to discuss reform i think
one of the biggest things that we can do
is look at rebuilding the relationship
with police officers and all communities
and specifically the black community so
being able to be an active agent in that
change and being someone that could
you know offer advice on different
initiatives and different approaches to
rebuild those relationships very
important to me because if the officers
that are patrolling the communities if
those citizens know the officers if the
officers know the citizens and know that
they're good people and know that they
don't mean any harm then my hope is that
that will reduce the incidence of police
brutality thank you very much um
reverend gerbazi um first of all uh as a
representative for a lot of people who
were caught up in that
um
paramilitary riot that was staged by
attorney general bar and president trump
in lafayette square i want to thank you
for trying to shield people from the
violence and the tear gas and the rubber
bullets and so on um i i wonder if you
would uh you relive for us that scene of
horror um
and uh also you're shocked at being
displaced from your own church property
uh both by in advancing uh police
phalanx and also the next day when you
weren't even allowed to enter your own
church but i wonder if you would comment
on some of the police tactics that you
experienced in terms of the pandemic
that were in the middle of um
the every medical authority has told
people to be wearing masks in public and
to try to maintain social distance what
did the use of a tear gas pepper spray
and these rubber bullets do to people's
ability to obey the best medical advice
in the middle of the pandemic
so first i i just want to clarify that
that the church that i'm the director or
head pastor of is a different st john's
it's in georgetown
the um i i had served on the clergy
sapphire saint john sofia square and it
is an episcopal church and i was there
as part of that ministry
right but they were unable to get into
their church the day after on june
and the whole diocesan prayer vigil
all of the clergy and our bishop and
clergy from around the city gathered
there for a vigil at st john's lafayette
square and we were not able the police
kept us from getting there so then your
question about
uh covet in the masks
my experience at the protest was that
everybody was wearing a mask
people were also regularly coming to us
and asking for hand sanitizer
outdoors we've been told by help public
health officials that the risk of
sharing of spreading covid is lesser
outdoors
and the whole experience of being
outdoors where everybody is moving
around and and people mostly keeping
a distance
from each other
i felt no concern at all about covid
my concern later became
when the people who whose eyes i was
washing out and i'm thinking first of
the first man whose eyes i was washing
out
he was coughing and coughing and he
pulled his mask down because he was
coughing and i had to lean in close to
be able to clear out his eyes
and although i kept my own mask on
i realized several days later that that
was um was the first of what turned out
to be several
very close intimate encounters i had
with people who had had to pull their
masks down so that i could effectively
wash their eyes and who were coughing
i was also coughing because i didn't
mention it earlier but i had also gotten
tear gas um and unlike linda was able to
wash the tear gas out of my hair that
night
thank you very much reverend uh gervais
my time is up in uh
out of deference to ms wasserman schultz
we've let her go first so i'm going to
call on uh our distinguished ranking
member to go and then we'll go also to
the republican side uh after him so mr
jordan you're recognized for your five
minutes
thank you mr chairman mr no uh why do
democrats try to ignore you
i mean mr raskin the chairman of the
committee couldn't even put your name on
the notice that went out to uh the press
notice that went out about this hearing
why do you think they try to ignore you
i don't know if it's intentional i want
to try to give people the benefit of the
doubt i think uh i would hope it's not
intentional because my message is not be
partisan one
uh i've written for very major
publications about this violent
extremist threat
my family is based in portland oregon
which is the epicenter of aunties for
militant violence we've had 30 straight
days of violent rioting in downtown last
week they
barricaded the north piecings and set it
on fire when police were inside so this
is the reality of what i'm seeing on the
ground
every day through my reporting
mr now let me ask you this uh last last
week on the house floor the democrat
chairman of the judiciary committee said
imaginary things like antifa is antifa
real
yes it's real when i heard that i was
quite surprised
i hope
it was just that out of ignorance and
not out of political expediency i'm
holding up for you here an affidavit
from
the multnomah county district attorney's
office
okay i'll just read you from it
shimrowitz stated they started the fire
using a molotov cocktail and she is part
of antifa
chamrowitz was reported to be extremely
excited about being labeled a terrorist
and was very animated about her hopes
that police officers would be killed and
injured by the riots now this individual
here has been charged with numerous
felonies for arson
riots and other crimes um this is a
press release from travis county texas
ga's office and that i'll read from this
the three people arrested are known
members of a local anti-government group
which is a self-identified communist
socialist antisocial group the damage to
property and merchandise stolen is
valued at over twenty thousand dollars
so it's not a conspiracy theory that's a
information warfare term this is we need
to come together as americans to counter
volunteer students on the far right and
the far left i couldn't agree more uh do
you agree with the president's
designation of antifa as a terrorist
organization
yes based on the activities i see what
they're doing on the ground
let me tell you how sophisticated their
organizing is
so in portland we've had arrests as
individuals the woman on the left asara
butler you know what she's accused of
police said that
she's been charged with multiple
felonies they say that
uh on the 2nd of june
she
was part of a unit who was driving
around during a violent riot in downtown
and resupplying her comrades with
weapons and more supplies when police
attempted to question and then detain
her [ __ ] sped off hit other cars and the
only way they could stop her was by
using a
a strip of spikes and she injured an
officer
uh in the process of being arrested the
man on the right dakota lee lassrop
he was driving a car with a allegedly
driving a car with a fake license plate
from north carolina
when police pulled him over because of
suspicious behavior they found his
weapon filled with cash of weapons
mr noah why didn't the police intervene
uh last year when we've all seen the
video at least at least i've seen the
video of you being attacked
uh when you were exercising your first
amendment liberty that as part of
freedom of the press um
why didn't the police intervene when the
police were right there seeing what was
going on and seeing you being attacked
portland is a few years ahead of what
the rest of america is experiencing ever
since donald trump's surprise election
win at the end of november in november
and 2016 there's been
consistent
routine violent rioting in portland
involving antifa and people on the right
street brawls very brutal
clashes and police have been demonized
over and over for responding have they
been in trying to stop these riots have
they been instructed by the mayor uh and
and the city council not to intervene in
this situation
well i don't have the evidence of that
but our mayor is also a police
commissioner and he's made his dislike
of the police pretty clear at times so
through my own reporting i've just found
out that this this culture of police
hatred has created an environment where
police are passive and they're
tolerating
mob violence and you know we're seeing
some data coming out now in the weeks
since some of the writing broke out at
the end of last month showing the
increase of violence all across america
as police are retreating so i fear that
america is i'm about out of time so uh
mr let me ask you one more question uh
it's about this double standard um
as you know the city council in
minneapolis voted unanimously to disband
the police department in minneapolis but
we find out today according to news
reports
that members of the city council who
voted to eliminate the local police are
being protected by private security
details
and not just being protected by private
security deals they're using taxpayer
dollars to pay for that protection uh
give me your thoughts on this this
obvious double standard
public of elected officials need to be
protected from
terrorists and those who seek to harm
them
and you know who else deserves to also
be protected by law enforcement regular
civilians regular citizens people like
my co-panelists and people like myself
thank you mr no the gentleman's time is
expired and we will go now to
representative presley for her five
minutes of question
thank you chairman raskin for bringing
us together for this important
conversation and
i want to thank our briefers for joining
us and our survivors of violence for
lifting their traumatic experiences
i want to specially thank dean brown
nagin for joining us in the
massachusetts 7th congressional district
she's a constituent and i thank you for
sharing your compelling testimony and
historically contextualizing that
testimony and i'll pick up on that in a
moment a few weeks ago i stood proudly
among thousands of my fellow bostonians
at a demonstration in franklin park
it was a beautiful sight to bear witness
to a multi-racial
multi-generational coalition peacefully
protesting demonstrating standing up and
speaking out in one voice against
systemic inequity structural racism
police brutality which has robbed us of
black and brown lies these peaceful
demonstrations are a continuation of the
long-time work and organizing
of many black and brown freedom riders
and freedom fighters before them who
have fought to gain
and had to fight
to gain equal rights for centuries
and while the chance may have changed
the violent tactics used by law
enforcement against many of these
peaceful demonstrators are eerily
similar to those used in other chapters
dark chapters in our nation's history
in 1965 on bloody sunday television
viewers around the country watched a
state and local police use billy clubs
whips and tear gas to attack hundreds of
civil rights protesters including our
esteemed colleague congressman john
lewis as they marched across the edmund
pettus bridge in selma alabama
dean nagin i'd like to uh really couch
this moment in our nation's history
how
how many of the protests
following the death of george floyd fit
this civil rights tradition in our
country
thank you uh representative presley i
would say that
so many of these protests are
reminiscent of the
peaceful
protests of the civil rights era that
were vital to
the the change in the law
um and change in society that our
country is
so appreciative of today
um the marchers uh in roxbury in
on the boston common throughout the
country
are really participating in an honorable
and so critically important
tradition of citizens demanding
accountability from government of
citizens seeking change
in a peaceful way we ought to be
happy in this country
that citizens are choosing this
honorable
pathway to pursue
reform it is their right
and we ought to
lift them up for engaging in that manner
thank you and ranking member jordan
earlier was talking about
equal protection under the law and um
his experience a violation of of the
first amendment in the
wake of a pandemic
and you know uh the ironic thing is the
reason why there is unrest in our
streets is because black americans have
never had equal protection under the law
that's why they're in the streets uh in
the midst of a pandemic and are being
met with more of a police state which is
the very reason why there is an uprising
and the protesters that are the front
lines today
would have been the diane nagins and the
john lewises and the dr kings
of uh the early days of the civil rights
movement we've seen the viral footage
law enforcement officers in philadelphia
using tear gas on individuals trapped on
an embankment police shooting rubber
bullets leaving severe and irreparable
physical and emotional damage and trauma
dean megan how do these historical
images compare to the images we've seen
throughout history
thank you for that question well as i
emphasized in my testimony uh the images
are in in some instances eerily similar
um to the tactics of people uh like bull
connor uh sheriff clark and selma and
other figures uh whose points of view
and whose tactics uh we had thought we
had left behind uh in you know 50 years
ago or so uh in this era of american
history
that
we believe
is inconsistent with the values of equal
protection under the law and one of the
things that
is
somewhat curious
is that the lesson that one sees in
history from those moments of violent
clash between police and protesters is
that it tends to crystallize the
injustice of the moment
i think that that is what we have seen
here
when americans see
um the injustice that others have lived
with for so many years
and have been talking about when they
see these images
that illustrate
these problems many americans who are
people of good faith who support the
principles of the constitution who
support equal rights and equal justice
have joined
the perspective have understood the
perspective of the protesters and so uh
the police violence is actually
counterproductive um it's
counterproductive it exposes
time so thank you i want to reclaim my
time just for as i closed here but
obviously one glaring difference between
the situations in selma and lafayette
square is the reaction of the person in
the oval office in 1965 following the
work of civil rights organizers and
demonstrators president johnson pushed
for the passage of the voting rights act
meanwhile the current occupant of the
white house on the other hand has
encouraged aggressive law enforcement to
dominate the streets demonize protesters
and to promote protection of property
over human life just last week he signed
an executive order threatening to
withhold federal funds from states
unless they enforce up to a 10 year
sentence for vandalism and damage of
confederate statues 10 years while
militarized police officers face zero
consequences for inciting violence and
engaging in reckless and deadly
brutality at protests when the people
spoke up and demanded justice president
johnson
used federal forces to protect black
americans today donald trump is using
federal forces to attack black americans
thank you ms presley the gentlelady's
time is expired
um and we're going to come now to
uh
mr keller
before i recognize him um i just wanted
to say i asked my staff to check on this
and the ranking member is correct that
there was a mix-up on the press release
which i knew nothing about but mr noah's
name is indeed on the website and we
thank you very much for your
participation in your presence here
today uh mr now i now recognize mr
keller for his five minutes of question
thank you mr chairman uh well i'm glad
we're having this meeting today
um i'm somewhat disappointed that we're
following the hearing structure the
house passed in hres 965.
if we're going to continue with these
briefings
what was the point of setting guidelines
for hearings
additionally
it should be conducted in washington
more and more workers are showing up to
do their jobs across the country we've
proven that congress can safely hold
hearings and meet on the floor
why can't we show up and work like so
many other americans
in any case uh i think it's important uh
discussion
that we're having america's
constitutional right to peacefully
protest is one of the things that makes
this country so great
i'm committed to working with the
majority of this committee to protect
constitutional rights
peaceful protests should be safe from
harm but it's important to note that
many of the protests we've seen
uh have been
uh
lately have been anything but peaceful
there have been radical anarchist groups
that have brought rioting
tearing down public statues and looting
of private property
and the very businesses that we protect
and work so hard to protect in many
cases the provision of the cares act
are being harmed
i'm not sure what other choice an
officer has than to continue to do their
job
in seattle we've seen anti-police zones
and in so many communities across the
country calls to defund police and
further violence for the radical left
their vision
of the future is mobs and not jobs
uh mr no attorney general barr has
stated that some of the rioting and
violence we've been seeing lately
was because
extremist groups hijacked
some of these protests
can you speak to some of the instances
and shed some light on what has been
happening with anarchist groups inciting
violence
i'm here on the ground
um
i just
i would like to bring your attention to
this manual that i received from that
so-called autonomous zone in in seattle
when i was there there was a lot of
radical anarchists antifa literature
that was being disseminated like candy
booklets and manuals this one in
particular provides instructions on how
to use crowds particular crowds of
ordinary everyday people is our first
line of defense against the police
attack
draw a crowd by calling a meeting of
some kind to discuss the crisis or just
to dance
if the police build barricades the crowd
will be between us and the cops so there
are very specific instructions
training going around
about using exploiting large numbers of
people as human shields and that's what
we saw
that's what we see happening every day
in portland so
for example last week when they uh
barricaded the north police precinct and
set it on fire you know what people in
the crowd were shouting uh at the same
time that they were doing this peaceful
protest so there's a lot of
misinformation and propaganda going out
there particularly from in my view
biased journalists and
many media crews on on the ground in the
situations because it's so
dangerous so uh it's important to
recognize that yes the majority of the
people taking to your streets across the
country are peaceful but it only takes a
very small amount of people to turn
a demonstration into a riot and cause
millions and millions of dollars in
damages as we've seen
uh destroying livelihoods and
in causing the deaths of people as well
let's not forget that
causing causing hurt i could see it and
if i understand what you're saying is
that uh you know
these uh these instructions that are be
putting out by this uh you know in our
you know these groups
um like antifa uh when they when they
hijack this crowd that's doing a
peaceful they sort of drown out the
message but then also by doing that the
police are trying to keep everybody safe
and there there's being some harm done
to people that that should not be
happening uh
in your case by by the groups and in
some other cases by the police trying to
keep people safe
yes i think police are in an impossible
situation so in portland for example
they retreated and you know what
happened on our first night of rioting
for five hours
uh mobs of people had full control of
downtown looted the mall started fires
all over so there was pressure for
police to respond so the next day they
did they used tear gas and others to
just um uh disperse violent rioters and
then that was framed as police brutality
and the city council then uh restricted
some of their tools to be able to
effectively control the crowd the same
thing has happened in seattle with the
injunction there so
i don't know what politicians want
police to do do you want them to protect
life and protect property or do you want
to give
riders the ability
to destroy
and kill as they've done
the gentleman's time has expired thank
you i now recognize
representative mary gay scamland for her
five minutes of questioning
thank you so much and thank you for
allowing me to join you can you hear me
yes we got it okay great
i'm a reporter
i'm a reporter
i'm a reporter
i'm a reporter
i'm a reporter i'm a reporter
times
samantha melamed repeated that phrase as
she was arrested while covering
philadelphia protests last week
in response to police violence
you know
the ability of a free press to report on
and speak truth to power is a
foundational and critical
uh
piece of our american democracy it's a
value that even predates the
constitution it can be traced back to
the trial of john peter zenger in new
york in 1735.
zenger was a printer who published a
series of newspaper articles exposing
the corruption of the english governor
at that time he was defended and the
right to a free press was established by
one of my predecessors the
quintessential philadelphia lawyer uh
andrew hamilton not to be confused with
alexander hamilton but since that time
our country our countrymen our country
women and our constitution have
recognized the importance of a free
press to be able to
uh expose corruption
and and speak truth to power
um
in the past few weeks we have seen an
unprecedented number of arrests of
journalists and attacks on journalists
um there's even a website that
chronicles this the united states press
freedom tractor tracker this used to be
something we looked at other countries
um in shock and horror to see um attacks
upon the press assaults upon the press
but unfortunately we've seen growing
numbers of attacks and arrests of the
press in our country over the past three
years
um
i want to thank the the chair for for
bringing together this hearing because
it's so important right now
um
i do want to mention that i've joined
chairman adam schiff in introducing
house resolution 999 to condemn the
recent violence and arrest against
reporters on the front lines of of uh
covering protests and to reaffirm
congress's commitment to protecting the
free press which is how we all get
information so that we know what's going
on in our country
i hope my colleagues on this committee
will join us in this important
resolution
i did want to to talk to our two
reporters here um
mr gustavo
martinez i'm sorry
um
you said something that really resonated
about the silencing of journalists by
law enforcement is a fundamental threat
to our democracy can you expand upon
that sure uh well as
many of you have put uh well before me
uh it's it's the first amendment in our
constitution and um
it enables not just journalists but
people in general the citizenry to
go out and document and
report on what happens around them and
that's a great power and liberty that we
have uh enshrined in our constitution so
um
it's it's uh alarming to see that uh
different actors are are out there
trying to silence what we do as
journalists and also what people are
doing by documenting misconduct and
other uh
problems that are are happening in their
communities
and i note that both you and mr
have reported um the assaults and the
arrests that you experienced to the u.s
press freedom tracker but the
philadelphia inquirer reporter whose
arrest i just noted does not appear
there there are over 141
incidents that have been reported just
since the start of this year and most of
them occurring in the past month um so
we know that there's under reporting um
ms tirado you um i don't know if ms
terado is still with us but if she is um
you talk of talked about the fact that
the u.s is becoming more dangerous to be
a journalist can you expand upon that
um yes thank you congresswoman i as i
said in my opening statement i have been
covering protests and civil unrest since
2014.
and at no point did i have a reasonable
expectation that i would go and be shot
in the face in the course of doing my
job um as you noted we're seeing those
incidents of violence against the press
arrest
attacks uh ticking up substantially in
the past few weeks compared to what we'd
seen in previous years and that worries
me both as a citizen and as a journalist
thank you
um yes i was involved in an
investigation for npr back before i came
to congress that had to do with um the
first deaths in the line of duty of npr
journalists that took place back in
2016. the general eddie's time has
expired so please get right to your
question if you've got it okay
there i do have very very strong concern
about the escalation of violence against
journalists in the united states and i
view it as a fundamental threat to our
democracy so thank you so much for
having this hearing and thank you very
much ms scanlon
we will do one second round of questions
and so i will recognize myself uh first
for
five minutes and um
dean brown naked let me start with you
um there has been a lot of reporting
about these extremist elements trying to
uh exploit the non-violent movement by
black lives matter uh and the vast
majority of protesters protest for the
purposes of inciting a race war um we
know that uh several members of boogaloo
have been arrested for
um
the murder of officer underwood we know
that proud boys the ku klux klan other
white supremacist groups are there um i
had not heard about antifa i just pulled
an article
june 9th by ryan lucas
saying no sign of antifa so far justice
department cases brought
over unrest and it looked at 51 cases
brought by the department of justice
there's no one associated with antifa
who's been charged but let's assume one
were to get involved we know that
there's extremist right-wing white
supremacist activity and for some reason
there's this obsessive focus on antifa
and i hope that's not just a some kind
of political ploy but in any event my
question is when these extremists
get into a crowd to try to incite by
throwing a bottle or something if
boogaloo and the proud boys in the ku
klux klan throw a bottle or start saying
you know
kill the police or whatever
how does that change the dynamics of the
protest i've read about some cases where
protesters try to isolate them and say
stop what you're doing this is not um
how does it change the dynamics of the
protest and then what should the police
response be
if you've got a boogaloo guy who shows
up with a gun or who tries to exploit
the situation to create violence
sure thank you for that question i would
say that we ought to be able to and
police officers ought to be able to
distinguish between
peaceful protesters and those who come
into the protest to
uh exploit it
and
to try to overtake it uh
in ways that
undermine the peaceful demonstration uh
police officers are within their right
obviously um to try to isolate those uh
elements and and move them out um the
point that i would make is that uh
the presence of those elements those
violent elements
cannot undermine the rights of those who
are peacefully demonstrating but what a
great point i mean in a way it's
analogous to
derrick chauvin the police officer who
murdered officer floyd we don't blame
all officers for what that officer did
he's the one who's being prosecuted for
second-degree murder he was the one who
did that and we don't we don't believe
in
uh collective guilt and mass punishment
under our system of due process so if
you've got one boogaloo guy who shows up
to try to create trouble and throws a
bottle you don't start shooting
journalists and other people because of
that so i very much uh appreciate that
point
speaking of which mr martinez so you've
been a journalist for a long time in
asbury park
um which of course was uh the the home
of bruce springsteen for a long time um
and um
did you do anything to provoke violence
uh against you or to provoke your arrest
by the police i mean what what was it
you were doing when you were apprehended
and arrested
sherman thank you for the question um
what i was doing was uh following police
orders they were ordering ordering us to
leave the area so i was leaving as uh um
i started hearing screams coming from
behind me and turned i would turn to
record what was happening but i always
follow police orders i never uh
confronted or taunted any any police
officer
got you um and um if miss ratliff let me
come back to you i you've probably had
some time to reflect about your great
aunt's career uh as a civil rights hero
if she was one of the people who tried
to desegregate the democratic national
convention or as my colleagues across i
would say the democrat convention uh in
atlantic city in 1964
and
we're not we're not ashamed that the
civil rights movement came to the
democratic party we're proud
that we are a political party that
transformed itself and left white
supremacy and violent racism behind but
i wonder what your reflections are
about what your aunt went through and
then what you're going through today
thank you mr chairman for the question
um i think it's a it's powerful
testimony to the resilience of the black
community to resilience of the leaders
in the black community that are
continuing to be
on the front line of these issues i
think seeing that hearing about her
stories reading about her stories in the
past few weeks and even learning more
about her than i did as growing up as a
child
i think it's important to focus on how
powerful and amazing she was how even
after
she suffered brutalization at the hands
of officers before she went to prison
and even when she was arrested even
after she was arrested it speaks to the
fact that this issue is beyond was
beyond her the same way this issue is
beyond me and that the purpose of what
we're doing although we've encountered
um brutality although we've encountered
um opposition to what we're doing that
it's not going to stop us that this
isn't something that is going to prevent
us from continuing to use our voice and
continue to push until the immediate
reforms and changes take place in this
country and so since immigration is no
longer a big issue
thank you very much uh my time is up uh
but for anyone who's interested uh
section the episode five of eyes on the
prize has a wonderful profile of fannie
lou hamer uh in what took place uh in
1964. so i recommend to anyone
interested in the in the life of miss
ratliff's great aunt and i'm now uh
happy to recognize the ranking member
for five minutes of additional questions
if mr jordan is there
um
mr jordan are you there
yep i'm here
gosh
thank you you're recognized for five
minutes thank you uh dean brown nagin uh
in your opening statement you said some
police have violated americans first
amendment liberties uh have some
governors violated americans first
amendment liberties as well during this
uh during this lockdown
uh i'm not quite sure what you mean i i
do
i did hear you talk about the lockdown
orders and
the way in which
there's been differential treatment of
those protesters versus
the peaceful protesters against racial
injustice that has not been my
observation
my sense has been that the police
officers have been incredibly restrained
in the context of the lockdown protest
as to governors
my understanding is that cases have been
filed
against the orders of some governors and
um
let me ask you this uh a month and a
half ago
actually two months ago the the attorney
general issued a memorandum to us
attorneys telling them to be on be
concerned and looking for potential
violations of people's first amendment
rights religious liberty rights and
others um
and in that he said the constitution is
not suspended in times of crisis do you
agree with that statement
of course we ought to be able to
both take care of our citizens during a
pandemic and respect everyone's
constitutional rights okay then let me
give you an example here the virginia
governor has an order that you can't
meet in groups of larger than 10 16
people met in a sanctuary sanctuary that
could accommodate 225 people do you
believe that is a violation of the uh
those those uh american citizens first
amendment religious liberty rights
well um certainly those individuals are
able to take that case to court if they
want to make that governors of course
have police powers that are designed to
uh further public safety and i believe
that was the motivation behind that
order yeah what about the double
standard what about the same governor
governor northrup who is doing a press
briefing in a much smaller room where
there are 21 people in the room um
is there some kind of concern you would
have there when you have a governor
saying uh you can't assemble and
exercise your religious liberty rights
even though it's 16 people in a
sanctuary that accommodates 225 people
and yet he can do a press conference in
a much smaller room where there are 21
people
that concern you someone who who uh like
uh who lectures and instructs students
on the first amendment and on
uh their fundamental liberties
right well i don't know uh very much
about the facts that you discussed i
would want to know who those people are
were they journalists
um were they officers of the law were
they following uh the mandate that
raises an interesting situation because
i know in louisville kentucky the
governor had done the same thing you
couldn't have church services even drive
in church services and he was actually
citing people who had to drive in in
their car not going into a sanctuary he
prohibited even that but i wonder we
never hear of anything where the press
was there filming it of course only the
parishioners coming for a drive-in
service were cited the press wasn't
cited so some some first amendment
liberties were allowed to be exercised
but others weren't here's what the
governor of new jersey said
when asked about all this and whether
his lockdown order comported with the
constitution he said quote i wasn't
thinking of the bill of rights when we
did this
that give you much uh does that concern
you when you got a governor of a major
state saying he's not really focused on
the bill of rights when he issues these
lockdown orders
dean
well i would like to think that
the bill of rights
is always present in our minds
and as i said people are entitled to
challenge those orders if they would
like and they think they are they're
challenging them on their challenge of
mayor garcetti on his second amendment
his prohibition on gun stores being open
they're challenging governor newsom on
his uh
lockdown on not being able to go to
church they're they're definitely doing
that americans
uh americans certainly understand are
you concerned about the double standard
the idea that a mayor that a mayor can
walk out without a mass since mr raskin
is so concerned about that without a
mask a mayor in los angeles can walk out
while the protesters are chanting defund
the police kneel down without a mask
around all kinds of people but at the
same time he puts sand at the skate park
so kids can't skate outside in the skate
park you concerned about the double
standard that you see out there
well i'm not sure that i've seen the
same double standard that you are
articulating as i said
um i have noticed at the protests as
others have that many people are wearing
masks and so they're trying to reconcile
um
the governor northam takes a selfie at a
protest when he won't let 16 people go
to church in a sanctuary that holds 225
people and i'm asking if the double
standard is helpful to first amendment
liberties and protecting them are
harmful
well i believe the governor apologized
for not wearing a mask
so you can apologize but he still kept
the standard on everyone else this is
this is what drives so many americans
crazy is the the double standard they
see out there
um mr chairman i understand my time is
out so i would yield back thank you mr
jordan for your questioning and uh ms
presley uh you're up again for five
minutes
thank you very much mr chairman and just
picking up on my last line um again in
in the earlier
days of the civil rights movement when
the people spoke up and demanded justice
president johnson use federal forces to
protect black americans today
donald trump in a move that surprises no
one is using federal forces to attack
black americans dean negan has any other
president of the united states
responded to peaceful protesters in this
way
well i would say uh not uh to my
knowledge um it is important to
appreciate that uh president kennedy uh
and president johnson and others um
understood the power of peaceful protest
in our society and as you mentioned um
the protests at birmingham and the
protests at selma
gave rise to the legislation that has uh
made us substantially freer in this
country today on
in terms of race
yes
how does this response compare to the
anti-lockdown demonstrations we have
seen in dozens of states across the
nation to protest life-saving protective
measures against the coronavirus
what comparison would you draw
sure um i would say that
in the context of a lockdown protest
i've noticed that
police officers have been incredibly
restrained i have not noticed uh any
violence again
against protesters batons or bullets or
tear gas by contrast in the context of
the protest following the death of
george floyd we have seen a lot of that
and so there has been a remarkable
difference uh in terms of the response
thank you dean and um
i would just say that um
you know the fannie lou hamers and the
diane nagins and the john lewises and
the dr kings
um
you know we uh elevate them now as
luminaries of the movement
but i'm quite certain
that they were vilified
and
falsely
and hurtly mischaracterized
then in the same way
that the protesters and demonstrators on
the front lines of this movement are
being to today
those who do not learn from their
history are condemned to repeat it
thank you and i yield back
thank you very much uh miss scanlon if
you're still out there you have five
minutes more to question
thank you so much it's a favorite issue
for me so i appreciate the opportunity
to participate
um
dean brown negan i just wanted to go
back to you for a minute can you speak
as a constitutional scholar a little bit
to the importance of the exercise of a
free press um in our country and and
what that means as a a pillar of our
democracy
sure thank you for that question uh the
respect for uh the press is a part of
the bundle of rights that are protected
under the first amendment and
it's absolutely vital to a free society
the press members of the press are in a
position to
uh uh tell us to report on the facts on
the ground um to uh expose government
wrongdoing um and uh therefore it's it's
it's so important uh for us to respect
the role of the press and a free society
they're the eyes and ears of the
american people
thank you um miss tirado i wanted to
uh return to you for a minute um
you've described in rather harrowing
detail what happened to you but let me
just um
get into some of the details how would
police on the scene know that you or
anyone else is a journalist
yeah i'm so i was wearing my credentials
in a lanyard around my neck um i had a
professional grade camera and a full
flash um i also wasn't right in with the
protesters i was in between protesters
and police and i was clearly taking
pictures and acting in my capacity as
press
you've covered other presses or protests
before including in ferguson after
michael brown was killed correct
yes
and and that was 2015 16 2014 2014.
okay
um can you compare your experience in
ferguson to what happened in minneapolis
um compare us to what
um just in terms of interactions with
the police i i assumed that you were not
um shot at in ferguson
uh yes i i was not blinded in ferguson
certainly um unfortunately i was in
minneapolis on thursday and friday
whereas i was embedded in ferguson for
quite a long time um so what i can say
is uh
that it is very common
and it was common in ferguson to speak
to the police and identify yourself as
press i carried on that same practice in
in minneapolis to the extent that i
could um
but overall i i would say that even in
ferguson in the in the midst of that
situation i had no expectation that i
would be shot at point blank in the face
um during a lull
i when when it was reasonably quiet um
and as we learned i did not have that
expectation i did not walk away from
minneapolis uh with that same
sense of security of course not um you
also covered the bundy standoff in 2014
where armed cattle ranchers who happen
not to be black seize federal land can
you describe how the police responded to
that incident compared with what you've
witnessed in response to the black lives
matter protests
sure um and to clarify that was in
january of 2016 um in in yeah uh so the
there was main differences is that that
was a very tiny rural area um versus
urban situations so that's going to
change a lot of it um but i we rarely
saw a federal or a local police presence
down on the refuge itself and with the
exception of occasionally the sheriffs
would come and there would be a bit of a
summit at the top of that hill
largely the fbi confined itself to being
in town and in surrounding areas and so
that had been my experience out in
oregon
and and that was a situation where
cattle ranchers actually occupied and
took over a federal installation for a
period of time is that right
um yes with the the help of supplemental
militias from three surrounding states
okay
um
just um
looking back
how is your experience as a freelance
journalist different than journalists
who work for larger networks
so largely that's a question of
workplace protection so for example i
don't if i worked for a masthead i would
have an editorial staff um attached
lawyers for legal fees i i would have
you know presumably some insurance or
workers comp um since i'm self-employed
and i do work for various outlets
since this has happened to me i'm
responsible for
uh
all of the bills uh any legal claims
that i might have i
worry to get arrested i would be
responsible for bailing myself out um
and as we saw in ferguson when ryan
reilly and wesley lowery were arrested
um their mastheads came in and and you
know help them uh bail themselves out
and things of that nature so freelancers
really do have to look out for
themselves on a level that's different
than staff positions would
i see that my time has expired but thank
you for your journalism and your
photography skills and for being here
today
okay thank you very much um so before we
close and i'm going to come to mr jordan
for any closing thoughts he has but are
there any other um
uh briefers who would like to take a
minute to close uh miss toronto i don't
know if that uh encapsulates it for you
or whether there was anything else you
wanted to say
um
i'm i thank the committee for taking the
time for this issue i'm and and i really
hope that i
our all of our collective uh
witness has been helpful
very much so thank you uh dean brown
naked you have a closing thought for us
sure thank you for inviting me to be a
part of this panel and uh i thank the
house of representatives for uh taking
steps to affirm the rights of under the
first amendment of the american people
and journalists
thank you mr no would you
leave us with a parting thought
thank you so much to this committee
as well as my co-panelists
i hope those who have been injured get
the justice that they deserve
thank you very much for your testimony
ms ratliff
do you have a closing thought
thank you thank you for having me uh
thank you for holding this very
important briefing and i thank you to
all the panelists that have shared your
stories um thank you for being an
inspiration to people around the country
as we continue to advocate and continue
to use our first event rights
i appreciate that mr martinez
thank you
yes sure thank you chairman uh thank you
to the subcommittee for hosting me today
and
uh i just would like to remind everybody
that the constitution and the first
amendment affects everybody not just
journalists as we've seen today as we're
hearing from everybody here uh everybody
is protected under the law and that
should be respected
thank you very much and finally uh
reverend gerbezi
thank you
so my faith calls me to respect the
dignity of every human being and part of
what is antithetical
to my faith is the conflating of
peaceful protesters
with violent criminals
violence is never the answer
and i witnessed the government's use of
violence against peaceful people
which
violates the tenants of my faith and the
faith
of most peaceful
people
and i ache
for that
and i yearn
for racial justice in this country
thank you for your witness and your
testimony um and before i give a closing
thought i'm going to recognize the
ranking member mr jordan
mr jordan you still there
okay well let me just close i want to
first of all uh reverend uh gervais
you're my constituent so i'm especially
proud of the role that you've played in
this but i'm really proud of every
single person here uh for standing up
for the first amendment for the
constitution
in the freedoms that are the lifeblood
of our democracy
i i find it
terribly searing that there are two
people who appeared with us today
who were injured in
their eyes
and ms tarado i am very sorry you've
lost vision in one of your eyes but
uh this is
the year 2020 and you still very much
have a perfect vision in terms of
understanding what's going on in america
and we need you still on the front lines
of journalism
and ms ratliff
our thoughts and our hopes are with you
that you make a complete recovery
from the injuries you suffered and for
everybody here who has
suffered different kinds of wounds and
injuries at the hands of uh government
violence or other kinds of violence uh
our thoughts are with you it's a tough
time for america and we're in the throes
of trying to repair a broken social
contract a social contract that's been
broken for centuries because of violent
white supremacy and racism and you know
the supreme court said in the dred scott
decision in the 19th century that um the
african-american has no rights that the
white man is bound to respect and that
the constitution is a white man's
compact and we try to overthrow that
understanding in the civil war with the
reconstruction amendments and
reconstruction lasted for 12 years of
meaningful strong interracial
progress in democracy before it was
undone again by violent white supremacy
the ku klux klan and the night riders
and the literacy tests and the poll
taxes and the grandfather clauses and so
on and then it would be
almost another century before the modern
civil rights movement brought us a
second reconstruction
through the non-violent blood sacrifice
of dr king and schwarner cheney goodman
and medgar evers
and viola louisa and everybody who put
their lives on the line to build
the dream of america as a place of
justice and equal rights and opportunity
for all and
we have slid back
uh towards the baseline of violent white
supremacy in far too many ways but black
lives matter and
the wonderful young people who have been
out at the barricades in large cities
and small towns across america have
given us hope for a new lease on life
and for
a reformation of our social contract so
that it is meaningfully ex inclusive of
everyone so that we really can fight for
democracy and justice and freedom and
civil rights and civil liberties for
everybody so i want to thank again all
of our briefers for participating uh you
have done your country a great service
today and i want to thank all of the
members who attended and participated as
well with that the meeting is adjourned
live tuesday on the c-span networks the
house returns at 9am to begin debate on
a 1.5 trillion dollar slash history
welcome to tonight's program
a discussion of civil rights leader
fannie lou hamer
my name is marsha eli i'm the director
of programs at the brooklyn public
library's center for brooklyn history
and a part of the library's arts and
culture team bpl presents the team that
brings you climate reads whispering
library lit films and much much more and
if you're curious about any of these
intriguingly titled programs i hope
you'll visit the vpl website and find
out more
tonight three women
all leaders in their own rights will be
in conversation about the extraordinary
and inspiring life of fannie lou hamer
whose courage and spirit and faith gave
her the strength
to lead the fight for racial justice and
voting equality in jim crow mississippi
it is distressing that today in pockets
across the country voting rights are
again threatened
and hamer's story is all the more timely
so tonight's program is inspired by a
new book written by one of our panelists
kate clifford larson
titled walk with me a biography of
fannie lou hamer it is a powerful book
beautifully written
and i want to share that we will put a
link in the chat
for those interested in exploring this
title further the link is to a page on
the website of a local
brooklyn bookstore the community
bookstore our partner
in park slope
i also want to share that as with all
center for brooklyn history talks you
have the option to engage closed
captioning tonight
simply click that button at the bottom
of your screen
and finally you are all invited to share
your questions for our panelists tonight
type them throughout the program into
the q and a box also at the bottom of
your screen and towards the end of the
program
we will they will take as many as there
is time for
so now let me briefly tell you a little
bit about karen larson and her
conversation partners and hand it off to
them
sorry i said karen i mean kate
so dr kate
clifford larson
is the author of bound for the promised
land harriet tubman portrait of an
american hero
rosemary the hidden kennedy daughter and
the assassin's accomplice mary sarat and
the plot to kill abraham lincoln
she has served as an expert consultant
on feature film scripts documentaries
museum exhibitions public history
initiatives and numerous publications
she is currently a brandeis women
studies research center scholar
and her latest book as i mentioned is
walk with me a biography of family
fannie lou hamer which is released just
this month
karen hill
is president and ceo of the harriet
tubman home in auburn new york where she
successfully pursued federal legislation
to have the homestead become one of the
newest units of the national park
service
prior to that she spent more than 30
years working on affordable housing
development including a federal
appointment to implement the court's
order to desegregate the city of yonkers
earlier she was a program director for
the national urban league chief
executive of the affordable housing
implementation office and chief
executive of the american homeowner
education and counseling institute thank
you both for being here
and finally cynthia r copeland is
president of the institute for the
exploration of seneca village history
and co-chair of the reparations
committee for the episcopal diocese of
new york
she is a public historian and educator
with teaching and learning affiliations
at new york university steinhardt
bank street college of education
teachers college and a host of
non-profit cultural and educational
institutions throughout the country
so i want to thank you all of you for
being here with us tonight
and i'm excited to hear your
conversation and i
hand it over to you
thank you marcia
thank you marcia
hello kate and karen and we should all
remember to unmute ourselves um i am
just so excited to be here tonight and
um i'm particularly interested as was
mentioned with the current fight for the
right over uh voting rights it's just
horrendous to me as we think about it
daily in 2021
and then we think about the people who
fought to give us those rights and
fannie lou hamer is certainly one to
have an incredible um position uh in a
prominent position in pushing this
forward and so
a lot of people know of fanny lou hamer
but they know of her from being sick and
tired of being sick and tired
and sadly that's sort of the extent of
it they have sort of a general idea and
notion of who she is
maybe they have had
the experience of seeing her in old
footage at the um democratic national
convention in atlantic city firing off
her wonderful statement um but without
but really other than that there just
seems to be sort of a superficial kind
of understanding of fannie lou hamer and
kate you have done an incredible job
going deeper and offering an opportunity
for all of us to find out so much more
and to have um an incredible intimate
relationship with her and so we'll start
with you kate and i'm just wondering
what inspired you to write the book
well it's sort of easy and um
complicated but um you know fannie lou
hamer inspired me to write the book she
is such an amazing woman
and um
i you know she had been on my mind
for 25 years
and um
i don't know this last time when i was
looking a few years ago when i was
looking for a new project
she was there she was just like you know
knocking and saying hmm maybe it's about
time and i i so i decided to start
researching her life and i got hooked
just like i did with harriet tubman i
became hooked on her life and her
passion and her brilliance and
what she did and what she
i'm amazed at what she sacrificed to to
bring change in this country
and i hope that everybody
learns about her and celebrates her and
carries on what she could no longer
carry on after her death
and karen what does fannie lou hamer
mean to you
well
you know it's interesting cynthia
because um
in
one of the photos of
fannie lou hamer there's a real strong
likeness to my own grandmother oh my god
okay and my own grandmother was similar
in build stature and uh
you know
she was very bold
in uh in her being
and for me
i can remember i mean i i you know i'm
old okay
i can
remember
being
riveted
by
all that went into getting us
to
1965
and what preceded it
and it was a topic
of conversation
in our household you know we
we my parents and my grandparents we
lived together
and it was a topic you know
that these voting rights have to happen
and that there's a woman from
mississippi
and she's singing the songs
that my family really grounded in their
own christian faith and
and the amy zion church and the freedom
church and all the freedom songs and i
you know
it was like
grounded in me that this woman was a
part of the charge it was interesting
because
just to go fast forward
it was like
fannie lou and other women did this
groundbreaking
work
and then i feel
like unfortunately
they have they have been they were
forgotten because then the modern civil
rights era came about
and we had all of these men
um from whitney young
to
um
you know the leaders of the naacp
and dorothy height was catapulted as the
lone woman leader
not remembering or honoring
or acknowledging in a way
that
should have been acknowledged of fannie
lou hamer's
absolute
dynamic
change in the body politic within the
democratic party
now i say that because see everything
happens for a reason and every and and
things kind of come full cycle
because also at that time when i was
like 12 13 years old
and voting rights had been passed
and i remember voting in my family being
really really critical everybody who was
eligible to vote had to vote the same
way to be honest with you with tides i
used to be the little girl to go and
collect everybody's envelope with their
tithes on saturdays my grandmother could
deliver even if you didn't go to church
you had to have your time there are
certain things that were just sacrificed
voting was one of them tithing was one
of them
but then i thought that that struggle
was
behind us quite frankly go back to your
opening statement
so
i really come at this from like i do the
work of tubman
and one of my big
uh i'm so
i'm so
honored that kate would even like be in
this lead this charge because
she really has sort of taken the thread
of tubman to the next stage with hamer
you know and then i see
the women of today need to be lifted up
also because a lot of the movements that
are going on today are really being led
by women who don't want to be identified
as leaders but they are the leaders
but
you know tubman
was fearless was faithful and fearless
and i see
hamer coming from that same tradition
of being
faithful
and fearless and you almo you have to
have that
i'm convinced of it whatever you
whomever you worship
you have to have
faithfulness and fearlessness to do the
work to bring us into
equality
and it's unfortunate
it is unfortunate that still
today
this country there's a part of this
country that seems resolute
in not
granting
full and equal rights to all of her
people
you know not having her join the
franchise but harriet
would be so pleased that fannie lou
hamer is having
this time
because she doesn't feel
like with harriet not with our struggle
but having to explain a historical a
truly historical figure fannie lou hamer
seems very much
more of a contemporary an older
contemporary
because these struggles are very real
today and going on today when you have
black men being
shot in the back and and being held down
and
uh by
by law enforcement those are like
those are
recapitulations of what happened during
hamer's time we have not really advanced
to the extent that we can
look at hamer as a historical figure but
rather we need to lift her up and we
need to share her far
and wide and learn the lessons of faith
and fearlessness
it is interesting that
you brought up these threads and the
recurring themes and how you've
introduced the idea when we were
preparing and thinking about drawing the
parallels between tugman and hamer which
are just
unbelievable and you cannot if you if
you study those two women and especially
if you study them from kate's books and
her works you will really come to
have this incredible understanding and
it is interesting that um you know you
bring up this point that it is so fresh
and real through hamer because it's only
you know it's in our lifetimes right
many of us are you know if you're a
product of the
1960s civil rights movements and the uh
and and the post to a certain degree
because you know women's rights and
liberation came about and those who were
um who study that and who are
knowledgeable of it can really sense and
feel her presence and then they tap on
her uh uh
harriet who was you know 100 years
before that you know so there's just
some some uh a little bit of a of a of a
gap yet the more things change the more
they remain the same and we're still
fighting for these same rights over and
over again maybe getting closer maybe
women are starting to get more
recognition but this is both of these
stories are definitely women's stories
and i think that um you know i'd like
for kade and for us to get into a little
bit more of this conversation about what
exactly did hamer do and what was that
faith that uh carried her through to be
able to be
resilient to be resistant to be able to
um you know be so committed to her
community to her people and not just to
her people this was for everyone her
people first but this was going to
benefit everyone and she recognized that
and she just was you know she said she
was tired but she kept getting up and
she kept fighting and kept going back so
i'm hoping that maybe we can kind of
talk about what exactly you know i hate
to be like what are the high points and
what do we really know her about but we
don't have a lot of time together on
this talk and we do want to intrigue
people so that they will go out and get
that book and read it a little bit more
and have book discussions and really
give fannie lou hamer the
credit that she deserves and the
recognition and acknowledgement so let's
just talk about who she was how she
spoke truth to power this idea of you
know violence that shrouds the the lives
of black women in particular um you know
from harriet to hamer to the present
times all of these issues that we were
talking about that have been threaded
throughout so you know i throw it out to
us for a conversation around those ideas
well i i like to look at hamer as um
as we were talking about her faith i
mean she was born and raised in a very
strict baptist household and her faith
it was it just was a part of
her in total being and it was in their
home and in the earth around their house
and it was just part of her
but she had to survive extreme
uh poverty and circumstances in the
mississippi delta as a child and as a
teenager
and
she
her faith that many times was the only
thing that her
and her family's faith is what helped
them survive
the gnawing hunger in their bellies and
the violence that world around them and
the discrimination and the racism and
when she was an adult i i look at a few
moments in her life that transformed her
um
and and there were acts of violence
against her
and some people would have retreated and
receded and hidden or run away
and she thought about those things but
she turned to her faith and she prayed
that she would survive and asked god her
god
you know what do what should i do give
me a sign
and i look at her being reborn
a couple of times as a result of the
violence and the the the trauma that
happened to her
and at one point she said something to
the effect of as as she started emerging
in the movement or decided to commit
herself to the movement
she told um colleagues and audiences
that
she felt that those white supremacists
had been trying to kill her all along
and so what's the difference she might
as well go out and fight as long as she
had breath and that's what she did and
she changed people's lives because she
was so honest and authentic and direct
and she didn't mince words and she
called out people it didn't matter if
they were black or white she called them
on the carpet for
for their inconsistencies their
disingenuousness
and um because she had business to do
voting and bettering the lives of her
family her community the world and
that's what she did she really did
i think it's really um interesting the
way
that
tubman had to leave
where she was born
in order to do her work that changed
america to make a difference
and that
hamer had to stay
where she was born
to
to change america and make a difference
and
but
i think the key is
both of these women were incredibly
smart they had an intellect that came
from another place
that we don't often honor
and acknowledge
but they had an intestinal fortitude
incredible determination
amazing wit
real genius pure genius in their being
one knowing that she had to leave
to make the difference to show the
empirical value
of of
moving
from
the land of the enslaved
to the north
and then
one in the deeper south
knowing that
so that the deeper south was not left
behind she needed to stay
to make the difference that needed to
happen i mean imagine if she didn't do
the work that she did i don't know
you know the dixiecrats would still be
the dicks that's loud and clear
okay so i think that that's really
interesting that they knew they were
both in tune with
what was going to make the difference
without anybody
sort of coaching them one way or the
other but they knew it you know they
knew it instinctively right that's a
great observation and i and i now that
you say that hamer saw that herself she
knew that once she got involved in the
movement she could have moved to
washington dc or new york city and and
been part of the movement there and some
structured organization but she chose to
stay in the community in mississippi she
knew the the needs there were so great
and also
um
she was fortified by those students the
from the student nonviolent coordinating
committee the bob moses and and all of
the young people that that came to
mississippi
and um they were willing to
to go through
being hungry and the violence
confronting and dealing enduring that
violence
and when some of her neighbors were not
willing to do that so she found that
being there on the landscape in
mississippi was transforming people from
away and they were going to take that
with them someplace else and she
actually said that those snick
student non-violent coordinating
committee students
were for her the new kingdom on earth
that they were more christian like than
some of the people that she knew in her
world
and that motivated her
that if they could be so
so
moved and
driven
she was going to to show them the way
and be part of that movement
then we've got these students that are
coming from all over geographically
primarily you know you've got white
students coming down from the north um
who had never been in the deep south and
had only heard about it and you know
encountered something that they perhaps
weren't ready for and you also had uh
young folks who were from the region
where uh hamer was
and you also had um students who
are of sort of the upper elitist black
south if you will and so i'm wondering
if we can talk a little bit about any
sort of class issues that
came into play during these efforts to
try to move things forward we're talking
about these two women again
speak thinking of uh tubman and um hamer
about the intelligence and the
brilliance and the genius that they had
natural organizers natural risk takers
natural
folks that just relied so heavily in a
greater power to get them through and
having that incredible
commitment and just i just it needs to
be done you know just do it kind of
attitude but um there were people who
did not necessarily like those women for
doing that and um they weren't expecting
these folks to be um
you know as exceptional they were the
exceptional ones you know how is it that
you're going to have these commoners
that can't speak intelligently or to the
standard that they have become
measured against um so can we talk a
little bit about the internalized class
issues class districts just in general
and the difference between the deep
south and the south
so
go ahead go ahead karen oh no no you go
kate well i think
tubman could not read or write so um her
literacy was an issue for elites in the
abolition movement let's say
um but she had many other literacies and
and because of her strong faith and her
amazing
like her genius and personality
uh she
she navigated that class
um
environment
because she had work to do and she's
like okay
uh frederick douglass if if you don't
have time for me today i'm i'm i'm going
to go rescue somebody or i'm going to go
do something else
and that's not to denigrate frederick
douglass but i'm just saying he was of a
different class and and that played out
in their relationship
um and with hamer it was the same thing
she had a sixth grade education
but her genius was so vast
but she lived in a world where men white
and black men still were in control in
their own worlds and elite
men
didn't want hamer rising to the top they
thought she was uncouth
and
unsophisticated and they didn't want her
image uh in the national news on the
newspapers on television they wanted to
be the ones that were doing that but she
did the work she was on the ground she
was she was bearing the brunt of all of
that
violence and she was determined to bring
the people
up
and the elite sometimes did not see the
faces or hear the voices of the average
mississippi delta farmer let's that's
the truth
yeah i was going to say that um
with
tubman
she knew how to own the room
okay when she needed to get her point
across
she knew how to
you know we know with the the photograph
kate that you and i authenticated of the
young harriet
she knew that that was
the attire that she would wear to go
just
to seward's mansion or one of the other
abolitionists to
get her point across i know from the
work i've done on suffrage
that they knew that they needed
her more than she needed them
okay because she could articulate that
message
of women becoming a part of the
franchise
even though it would not include her
even though she was an owner of property
and i think that's a part of the beauty
of both
tubman and hamer is that they had an
ability
to see an america
that was beyond the current circumstance
which is really hard because i don't
have that ability
you know but they had that ability and
that's what they worked toward they did
not stay stuck
in current conditions
and then there were um
as far as the elitism there was
there's the exception of a
of a bob moses who had his education
who did
move
south i think he went from you know new
york dc then atlanta okay
and then he realized
that he needed to go deeper south
because what happens there's the south
and then there's the deeper sound
and where the real change that needed to
happen that would galvanize
everyone was the work that needed to
happen
in the deeper south so there were some
men who were willing to be
to be led
by
the circumstances and by hamer's
personality
for
for change and i just think that both
hamer and tubman
saw
an america that no one else saw quite
frankly
but and they were willing to put their
lives on the line to make
that
happen
and i think it's interesting that um
you're saying that these two women were
capable of envisioning
a future a
an america that would live up to the
ideals of the constitution and the
declaration of independence etc um and
i'm wondering if the fact that they were
working with
um
abolitionists in the case of harriet and
in the case of franny she had the uh the
snick groups and the sort of you know
diversity of peoples that were starting
to question
uh that which had been taught to them as
a as a means and so i'm wondering if you
think that you know these were
sort of the the
fuel
that could help to keep them going and
help them to believe that this was
indeed the case young people women that
were outside and accepting them and
having maybe not completely and fully
but giving them a bit of a platform and
being able to actually listen to the
plea and also knowing that
you know in god's eyes this isn't right
that ain't right you know that just
ain't right folks and you call
yourselves christians and they both had
that sense of that ain't right you know
so they pushed forward and tried to uh
uh hit people sort of morally but also
um you know economically they recognize
where this was going economically and um
just because uh the humanity looking for
the humanity in every single person i
may not necessarily appreciate what you
do and what you have done to my family
as a white supremacist or living in the
muck of white supremacy maybe you don't
want to be in it but you're in it right
um but i can see that you are a human
being and i want that recognition too
and i want it for my people and for all
people so i'm just wondering if you
think that maybe something like those
shifts that kind of made their
appearances um of course it was a lot of
their work and they're doing to get them
to get to those points but
could that have been um a possibility to
help them to envision and realize that
oh wait this is possible
well i know
uh with tubman
she was fortunate to have met
some of the most powerful abolitionists
in the country at the time
and while it took her a little bit to
trust them once
they earned her trust it did it it
motivated her and supported her and
energized her and those relationships
were very important to her and and um
you know they became like some of them
she became lifelong friends with so they
they were part of her transformation and
her her rising and being able to do more
of what she wanted to do and with hamer
it's absolutely the same thing she was
frustrated she did a few things that had
to do with the civil rights movement and
trying to get local people interested in
pushing for some rights and and trying
to make a difference in their world but
it wasn't going anywhere and she didn't
have the tools in ruralville mississippi
there just were the tools weren't there
and so when snick came to ruleville
it was the moment for her she knew that
they had come
and it was her one opportunity to try to
see if she could do something and when
they gave her the tools to try to
register to vote that's all she needed
she could see
that that they
wanted to work with her they weren't
going to lead her they were just giving
her tools and that changed her life it
really changed her life and those young
people looked up to her they like karen
you said she owned the room
and while she may have understood she
did have a powerful voice she had no
idea she could own the room with kids
and young people coming from around the
country who were well educated who some
of them were very well off
they they just looked at her in awe and
that empowered her and she knew that she
was making a difference
i think you're absolutely right i was
going to um
add to that and say that i just find it
and this is just my very own personal
views that
when you have a woman who
could neither
read nor write and you have a woman who
had a sixth grade education who was
doing a lot of the
of the um
keeping the records and and a lot of the
sort of administrative work to keep all
the plantation
running the way it needed to with a
sixth grade education
we have when you have
those are the only opportunities that
they had for how we value formal
education and how we learn
um in this country
there had to be something else
there had to be something on the inside
that manifested itself on the outside
with their actions
and there
it was like in their head that they had
um
these deliberate moves that had to be
made
in a certain time in a certain place in
order to make the difference
and
just
a level of commitment
and contentment
that it may not all be solved in their
lifetime but there would be these major
uh
steps moving toward
moving toward the promise of america
and i think that that that that's an
amazing thing that
that the promise of america
was in there being
now how does that happen
how does that happen
right when you see your people being
beaten and mistreated and
and living on the margins and but you
still believe in the promise
of america and for me
i have to juxtapose all of that
with what is happening today
um i think
history is great
but i have often said history just for
history's sake
doesn't mean a thing unless you can
apply
that history in a way that has practical
application that moves us
towards the mark
getting closer towards the mark
and that's when i see
hamer in particular the reason you know
kate is a wonder she's a personal friend
she's a great historian i love her but
kate kate was hankering to do this book
when these issues were grappling today
weren't on the front page of new york
times every day
okay
and there is something that grabbed hold
of kate even that said this book must be
written this is a book of our time and
this is a book for young people in
particular need to be fortified by this
book
and things i really truly believe i
believe in him
as deep as i can
that
people
are in certain places at certain times
to carry the message forward and to
continue the beating of the drums
cynthia okay the drum beats on and this
book is the drum of our time
i think kate as a sage is absolutely
correct um in bringing these issues all
together because they uh the book is
clearly timely it deals with the issues
of violence in women it deals with the
issues of the voting rights situation it
deals with the issues of you know
climate and and geography and what is
happening you know in these spaces it
deals with the issues of of um housing
right and uh education um it's all in
there and
fair completely and totally is right up
there and so um you know in thinking
about
you know kate how was it that you were
able to sort of organize the book um
because of all you know with all of
these issues going on and did you feel
like you were in some kind of a i don't
know like a time warpy tornado sending
you forward i mean i don't know what you
were in but it must have been you know
this incredible space where you're just
like wait a second
why you know this was happening that why
are we doing this again why can't we get
out of this and really choosing those
points that um really um you know
resonated with you needed to be spoken
about and i would also ask you if you
can just give the folks a little bit of
um
of a heads up about what i think is the
most difficult chapter in the book which
is the winona chapter okay
um well as far as doing the biography
karen is right when i started this uh
what has exploded on the scene in the
past few years had not quite happened
white supremacy was always there that
wasn't anything different but then
as i started doing the research and and
writing this it was like wow there
people are using the same language
today that they were using back then to
keep
um african-americans from voting
and giving the same reasons why and
it's it was freaky to me that this was
happening
but hamer
i think this for me the book is
important because it also
um is instructive on organizing
community organizing movement
organization
and that it can't always be just elites
there are people like fannie lou hamer
in our communities today
that need support that they're they're
able to rise up if people recognize them
as the ones that can be the leader you
know fannie lou hamer was recognized by
bob moses immediately like he knew she
was going to take the reins in
mississippi so i there are people like
that today so we have to pay attention
to them and support them and um and
understand that there will be differing
views and complications along the way
but
this has happened before and there is a
blueprint
but on both sides of this and we need to
be aware of it so it's it's it's
yeah it's timely very timely and i did
not anticipate that but i'm very
grateful that the book is out now
and as far as the book is concerned um
i wanted to make it as authentic to
fannie lou hamer as possible and having
come to know her over these past few
years researching her and interviewing
people that knew her
i felt it was
my responsibility to reveal some of the
things that happened to her life
and
one of them was this horrific
beating that she received in the winona
county mississippi jail
in 1963 that that transformed her life
changed her life it nearly killed her
and the chapter is very difficult
because it it details
um what happened almost minute by minute
and i did that because i had all the fbi
files i had all the interviews i had
details that had not been available
before
and i know that hamer would want
everyone to know exactly what happened
to her
so that's the warning
but you have to read it because she
survived it and she would want everyone
to read it and understand what happened
and and some of that is still happening
today
so don't look away you have to read it
and let it sink in and then
we can have more conversations about it
karen in reading the
uh book um what
what
new insights did you take away from the
story of hamer that you had known before
um
and you know what were perhaps uh the
most
troubling difficult phases to understand
and to sit with and rest with and what
gave you hope right well a lot of it was
like
deeply personal for me
um
you know i can
um
when she was given
that
hysterectomy without her permission
um
you know
that was
horrific
and and she wanted children so badly
um and that was deeply personal for me
because i remember as a young woman you
know i had gotten um uh
one of those
letters that said you know you need to
go you know after you get a mammogram
then you have to go back and you get
those let the letters scare the bejesus
out of me and you go back and so for a
couple of years i just got constantly
going to get you know to be screened
again again and again
and i was able to talk to
um
and
uh haitian-american
um
ob gyn who said who shared with me how i
had a grandmother who had a double
mastectomy
but because but she lived like another
30 years after that
and when my when when my doctor looked
at her records
my grandmother didn't have breast cancer
it's what they did to black women
it's what they did to black women
the easy way out
cut it out
get rid of it
so you know when i say this book has hit
me personally
i mean very personally
you know and that's happening
like it's not everybody needs health
care is the quality of the health care
that everybody needs
so i'm glad that merrick garland is
going to be suing the state of texas
okay
that's important to me
that's extremely important to me
and when i
was doing my work
in the city of yonkers
and this is i was hired
when that city was found to be in
contempt in federal court and they were
being fined
a dollar a day and their fines doubled
their fines got all the way up to 4
million and something dollars a day
that's when i was appointed by the
federal court to come in and do the dsa
work
and i understand
not everybody is going to be with you
all the time that was an extremely
lonely time for me
outside of my family
because a lot of black people
needed the jobs that they had you know
they were afraid to speak up afraid to
come to public meetings of you know even
though i was there to help the
conditions
these people did not want to be so
identified so there were
there was an incident where someone
accidentally was killed off the back of
a garbage truck the truck ran over you
know this stuff happens it's real
everything doesn't make it into a
headline
so
you know i relate to this book from i
try to do my walk as best i can as best
i am able
so now
to me
the hammer book becomes another guide
post
for me
another guide post for me
and i i really think
um
there's something
incredible about these women
their blackness
they did not try to hide from shy away
from
or mute
okay
you know and
a lot of the struggle has been about
who is the better looking who is the
fairer complected
to be the face of
and i so appreciate
harriet tubman i so
appreciate fannie lou heyman hamer
because it shows that in all of our
black nests
which we have to wear every day
these women were able to lead
you know they are ex
exemplars of how your blackness can
catapult you towards your greatness
and again
they had loving hearts i mean you have
to know the compassion
that they had to have
not only for themselves and black people
but for whites also because they're
trying to make america better this
wasn't just gonna help you know help
black people you know move the needle
towards free to move them the needle
towards enfranchisement through voting
this is mostly helping white people
and i you know it's so hard they don't
understand when you run acro come across
people who don't understand
that there is this possibility if we
truly believe in the promise of america
and the constitution is not perfect
hello since i have issues with the
federalist society it is not perfect
it is there for us to improve upon
and they knew that they knew that with
no education
and they knew it was a sixth grade
education so what the i won't say it but
what don't
okay
we're people who are
learning from harvard and yale and
princeton and sit in our great congress
who don't get it
who don't get it
or who get it and choose to ignore it
yeah um yes because that's because
they're so into self and see that's the
whole thing
self they didn't hamer and tubman did
not put self first because what they're
doing is advancing their own political
careers
they're not looking at greater good
they're not looking at how to improve
our constitution
they don't see where
inclusion is going to happen
you know i was listening to a news
report
last evening
um where you know the reporter was
saying how all these movements are
beginning to now
add up
you know they're becoming these small
victories are becoming bigger
and bigger
and bigger it is going to happen that
would be my message it is going to
happen i may not be here
they may not be here but it is going to
happen so why not
embrace that if not for yourself
if you love your children and their
children yet unborn you would want to be
on the right side of this because that's
a better america
i agree it doesn't seem that these two
women were also about family in the
deepest sense of the word and operated
from a place to
make for improvements make for hope make
for
love make for um
you know
opportunities um and it started with
family and then it sort of so it's kind
of like that micro to the macro to the
meso and so on and so forth but um but
they also came to realize that family is
everything family is you know the
nuclear what i've got but you know what
you're my family you know susie down the
street you're my family you know and
every and they just embraced and adopted
everybody they were everyone's aunties
they were everyone's uh you know big
mamas they were everyone's um you know
nurse needs they were everything to
the community and i'm wondering if um
you know you can sort of speak to the
ideals of
this nurturing that um it was a part of
who they were but there was the
nurturing but there was also the knowing
and the ability to lead without
necessarily calling yourself a leader
and understanding the whole idea of the
collective we don't get anywhere if
we're not working within the collective
spirit so maybe we can kind of talk
about that a little
well i know that's very much true with
um with hamer i think of her you know
her mother was an amazing woman ella who
did everything to protect her children
protect hamer raise her to be
who she became and we have to give
credit to ella townsend
but hamer also learned a lot
in that church hall after church and the
the church women would gather together
and they'd have their meetings and they
would you know raise money for this or
organize for that or help this family
that was struggling more than the rest
of them were hamer as a little girl
would go to these meetings and she
learned
really the basics of democracy there
because they couldn't experience it
anywhere else but in that church hall
that's what they were learning she was
learning them from those women
and she as she grew up she became those
women so there is something very
very specific about
i think women and black women in
particular in the black church that are
that are learning this community and and
the and expanding that concept of family
far greater and that's where hamer
really shined because she had the genius
there was something about her i don't
know what but it was something about her
that made her that
that much different that she could go on
and be a leader in the community
yeah i know for um you know for for
tubman
when she
uh
established
the home for the agent she had eight
women as the managers
now that was really remarkable that she
understood
that it was not enough
for her just to build these cottages so
that the indigent former slave could age
in dignity and grace but that she need
to pass it on
so that these women would be
the people who would provide the
governance
okay that is remarkable
you know they then she understood about
sharing it and passing it on
and you know for um on the tubman side
you know kate we struggled with her core
values you know faith family
um freedom community
self-determination
um equality social justice all these
things are they they're the same for
hamer
they are the same the core values are
exactly
the same
and they have made an indelible
imprint
an indelible imprint
um
on our progress
on this journey
that
you know
we're not where
we want to be but it gives me
great hope to know
that
we can get there as long as when we
acknowledge the tubmans and hamers of
our time support them
support the broader community
um
you know
they were servant leaders and i think
that's what their leadership style
so amazing and so different that they
believed in servant leadership
and you know
like
my thing is
we have a lot of leaders not a lot of
servants we don't have
leaders that are going to wash
somebody's feet
and they were the kind of leaders that
would
right which ties into a question that we
have um
from lisa who asks you know who do you
think ms hamer would tap
as this new generations
fannie lou
new type of servant leader
type if you will
we have our black lives matter movement
we've got a lot of movements out here um
we got stacey abrams we got you know
we've got folks out here so who do you
think they would
you know she was all about young people
um and so
certainly stacy abrams
um
[Music]
i think that she
she might
let the leaders
rise up
themselves she would not kind of anoint
anybody she would be supportive once
that person
kind of rises but she would be there to
support
and um help move that needle forward
so there are a lot of movements now that
yeah that you could not yeah that's kind
of the what bob moses did in tapping her
and noticing the genius and saying hmm i
need you to do more of this yeah
i'm reluctant to even name anybody
because as soon as you name somebody
there's like a target with twitter and
instagram and this that the other you
know so
i support all the sisters but i will say
this about
stacey abrams both her parents are
methodist ministers
there is a grounding
that comes
and they didn't have much and they have
a big family there's a grounding that
comes from having
a faith in your core
okay and and that's what i see as a
common thread
between
tubman
and
hamer
and
stacey abrams
know and we're talking about this idea
of the leaders and we talked uh in
preparation for the conversation that
snick didn't have leaders
black lives matter sort of operating on
that same type of model if you will
so they're finding ways to sort of
adjust to the different kinds of
circumstances that arise and uh which
can you know likely be
very useful and very helpful and a means
of survival in order to get through all
of the stuff that is being thrown at
them in so many different ways just
trying to
you know choose your battles pick your
battles which one are we going to stay
you know which ones what's going to
stick where am i going to give my voice
the loudest
resonance and speaking of voices
we know that hamer was known for her
incredible voice
music folk songs
um
played a major role
can we talk about
music in her life and the title of your
book
so music always was a part of her life
she was identified with having a
beautiful voice even as a little girl
and it was in her home in the fields
everywhere around her so she grew up
singing and
she grew up with the delta blues which
the birth side of the delta blues was
six miles from her home
and she just in her in church the
spirituals and the gospel music so it
infused her life
um
so everyone links hamer with this book
this lit with this song this little
light of mine uh which she's saying a
lot during rallies and things like that
during the the movement but her favorite
song was one that's called walk with me
and it's about asking jesus to walk with
me you know support me help me guide me
give me you know give me strength and
she's saying that she
in the winona jail after she had been
brutally beaten and assaulted
and she was barely conscious and she
asked her cellmate euvester simpson to
sing the song with her walk with me
and that fortified her to make it
through the night and survive that
beating so that's why it's the title of
the book walk with me
uh
looks like we also have a question from
esther who says that she hamer died
young
and her final year seemed so difficult
what kind of support did she receive
from the movement in her final years
she didn't receive a lot of support from
the movement the movement had sort of
fallen apart by the 1970s
a lot of the young people had gone in
different directions some of them got
involved in the black panther movement
and in other movements went on to
graduate school went on to jobs and to
do other things and they left
mississippi
and some of the leaders in mississippi
went on to
organize in a different way than hamer
was organizing
and she was involved in you know raising
money to buy land for food co-op so that
people could plant gardens and grow
their own food and and raise hogs so
they each have meat for the winter time
and
health care she wanted health care for
everybody it was not good health care
and accessing it was very difficult and
expensive and she wanted universal
preschool for every child i mean she was
struggling for all the issues we're
still struggling for that she understood
those basic things in her community
could be replicated throughout the
country
but her support system really fell away
and um it's tragic it is tragic in a way
um but they a lot of those people went
on to do great things in other parts of
the country but that left her still in
mississippi
struggling with that economy
that environment
and it's still you know in the bottom
you know five for health care and
education etc in the country so
mississippi is still struggling
and is there a landmark to
show
where she was from and to recognize her
down there yes
there is a monument to her at her
gravesite in um in ruralville
mississippi there's a beautiful statue
of her
and she is buried there next to the
freedom farm that she helped establish
in the early 1970s um so you can go and
visit her
but the area is still you know very much
depressed
very much can you talk a little bit more
about that as you went down to uh
experience the space and you know to
what kind of insights did it give you
and how did it inform your approach to
writing books
so i didn't make it to mississippi
because of covid and floods
um which is
the bad thing about this this epidemic
that i had to cancel trips down to
mississippi
and um and that mighty mississippi river
flooding didn't help
a couple years ago
so i was not able to go and see that
landscape you know i watched lots of
documentaries and and videos
online about the environment and of
course talk to family members of hers
and people that knew her who live there
so that i could fill in those gaps but i
did not go
but they all said the same thing it's
still
very much a depressed area
well throughout the conversation we have
noted just how much
violence that was a part of this history
and this story
we've talked about
the connections and the relationships
that were so important to hamer and
tubman
we've talked about
exploring activism and the engagement
and organizing ways what kinds of
messages can you all each of you leave
the audience uh as having been inspired
by both
tubman and hamer in the hopes that
people can sort of pick up on that
energy and
um work to uh perhaps emulate or honor
these two amazing women
well i can say right away that
go ahead hate
uh you know
i think that
the hamer book
is a new
opportunity it's a new opportunity
for all of us to learn um
not only
women
but men and and young people in
particular
who maybe did not know that it wasn't
that long ago that we were having these
fights about
voting rights in particular
and
and young people who perhaps did not
know
the extent to which so much of this
country still lives at the margins
still lives at the margins
and that um
you know
when we begin
to
connect
our center cities with rural america we
will be better off
i agree
a lot of my work in other spaces that's
a big issue
that that that people who live in in the
metropolis have to have a healthier
better relationship with people who live
in rural america if we really want to
overcome the social justice issues that
we've been talking about for the last
hour
but i would say that this book is a
touchstone and i really encourage people
to read it and to read it
not to zip through it read it in a in a
measured way that allows yourself to
take a step back
and see how you're connecting up with
the various chapters of the book because
it is so timely
and it is so relevant
thank you karen and i i just i'm just
briefly going to say launching off of
what she just said i hope that people
will read it
um and recognize the values that a hamer
had that are very similar to the values
that we all have but she took action and
so
in reading this too i'm asking people to
interrogate themselves and ask them just
like karen said to see what you can do
and where what you're thinking about
what it means to be an american and what
your role is in making this a better
world and a better democracy to fulfill
the promise of the declaration of
independence i think hamer can show us a
little bit about how we can do that and
don't be afraid to interrogate yourself
and look at the world around you
thank you
thank you so much for this amazing
conversation uh kate clifford larson and
karen hill
to the audience i do hope that you are
inspired and i do hope that you will
take the time to get to know
fannie lou hamer digest her
read about her um live with her walk
with her um it will really be a
transformative experience for you
so thank you very much and thank you to
the center for brooklyn history for
having us
and thank you to all of you
for
sharing this conversation with us this
powerful conversation with us
watch book tv now on